foreign
's YouTube channel
2022 a whole new year brings new
prosperities and many goals to achieve
goes to learn and get ahead and much
more after a rigorous survey we found a
list of top trending IT jobs in the
industry this week we will help you
learn about all those interesting
Technologies and get ahead to be Future
Ready For 2022. Today on Day 2 we will
learn digital marketing and SEO
digital marketing and SEO are one of the
few job rules that have emerged in the
recent years and have proven to be one
of the most highest paying jobs in the
current IT industry digital marketing is
a new concept of carrying product
marketing via digital media here you get
to Target the Right audience unlike the
traditional marketing practices where
you reach a mass audience and get
minimum potential customers in digital
marketing you recognize a spectrum of
interested audience and Target a major
audience with the possibility of having
maximum sales next we have seo seo
stands for search engine optimization
SEO and digital marketing go hand in
hand SEO is a process of getting traffic
from the free organic editorial or
natural search results on the search
engines simply put is the name given to
the activity that attempts to improve
search engine ranking today our digital
marketing and SEO industry experts will
train you on these concepts with
real-time examples for a better learning
experience so without further Ado over
to our experts greetings everyone this
is Rob Sanders and today we're going to
talk about what is digital marketing so
thanks for joining us here at simply
learn and let's get started let's start
talking about why digital marketing is
important so let's start there on the
why so if we're just a fly on the wall
and we're in an office environment we're
looking at two friends having a
conversation about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in everybody
every marketer is using digital
marketing for his or her business now
digit marketing has become more popular
than traditional marketing that's not a
surprise so in response hey over the
past few decades digital marketing has
evolved at a rapid Pace these days a lot
of people spend most their time on the
internet so what happens in the internet
every 60 seconds well a lot happens
every 60 seconds so according to Social
Media today I mean there's a lot of
snaps there's a lot of clicks there's a
lot of text there's a lot of videos
watched there's a lot of pictures being
taken there's a lot of voice activated
activity going on a lot of tweets emails
swipes there's a lot going on here in 60
seconds so there's a lot of activity on
the internet a lot and so the one
gentleman says hey can you also mention
a few differences between digital and
traditional marketing systems and then
the expert responds of course I can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper TV
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know what traditional
marketing reaches limited with digital
marketing reaches maximum and what we
mean by that is hey when you print
something you're printing it for x
amount of people if you're trying to
promote an event and you basically
create a thousand Flyers okay you figure
it's going to a thousand people maybe
it'll share it so you're looking about 2
000 people maybe just to be generous
well digital marketing we're promoting
an event we can promote it to a whole
lot of people depending on the platform
so 2000 is nothing when you're targeting
an audience on Facebook or Google search
traditional marketing non-versatile and
with digital marketing very versatile so
again going back to our flyer printing
an eight and a half by eleven okay
that's it you know with with digital
marketing running display banners you
have 468 by 6 60 200 by 200 250 by 250
300 by 300 I mean the list goes on on
the types of different display sizes not
to mention text ads not to mention video
or multimedia uh so the lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so meaning if you're
trying to get that TV spot there might
not be a spot open until one in the
morning okay well with digital marketing
there is no hours okay you can certainly
get your point out there and have people
see it instantaneously so with
traditional marketing there's a lack of
real-time results I mean this seems like
uh it's obvious but you know digital
marketing that's one of the biggest
benefits instant real-time results
instant okay nowadays go into analytics
you can look at real time reporting okay
so we could see real time results okay
tradition marketing can can be very
costly I mean if you're not only doing
postcards and printing postcards but you
have to mail those postcards so there's
postage fees where digital marketing
it's very very very cost efficient I
mean meaning you could pick and choose
who you want to Target when you want to
Target where you want to Target what you
want to Target and if you're doing
search you can put your bidding in place
you can put your hours in place you can
really control how much you actually
spend so that to me is one of the
biggest advantages to digital marketing
not only do you get real-time results
but you can control costs and then
obviously optimize based on the amount
of cost you're spending based on those
real-time results with traditional
marketing it's difficult to reach a
target audience you know with digital
marketing it's easy to reach a target
audience I mean you know I don't want to
bash traditional marketing too much I
mean if you're gonna put a TV ad in
place you know you're going to do it on
a TV show that tends to gear more so
towards your target audience but that
doesn't guarantee anything here we can
simply go to Facebook or Twitter or
LinkedIn and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to Target when
we want to Target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing Port
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure optimize campaigns
and what we really mean by that is
because you get instant time results
because you can control costs because
you can reach your target audience more
easily all those a result of okay you
can measure and optimize based on what
our audience is seeing and how much
they're spending to see it we can
quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now why digital marketing has been
answered with all the benefits that it
carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so you know that you
know you want to do digital marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just Define it
digital marketing it's just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and when
we talk about technology it could be an
app it could be you know a cloud-based
platform okay it could be a piece of
software okay so a lot going on on the
digital side in terms of variations and
what you can do but that's in a nutshell
what digital marketing is really just
using technology to promote your product
or service so we know because of the
benefits in digital marketing you can
promote your campaign on different
platforms okay so all those benefits we
mentioned about instant real-time
results cost efficiency optimizing
campaigns you could do that on search
you could do it on social via email on
mobile apps Etc so that's what we mean
by with the help of digital devices and
Technology well these digital devices
and Technology come in the form of
search engines and emails and mobile
apps Etc so when we want to go and
promote our product or service using a
campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what I consider the king of
them all and that's SEO so SEO stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get get
into subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with SEO because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic on the search engines
including Google so depending on where
you're located in the U.S market Google
tends has a large market share so you
want your pages on your website to be
found and clicked on organically and so
that means if somebody types in a
keyword you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but worldwide you search on a daily
basis so if you're ranking for those
relevant keywords you can imagine how
much traffic you can get okay so that's
SEO okay and here's an example so you
type in online shopping well you can see
the first listing here is a paid search
ad I'm going to get to that in a minute
in it the second organically is Amazon
okay so online shopping you think maybe
Walmart you think maybe Alibaba or
you're thinking probably Amazon okay so
no surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay-per-click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names synonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bid on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results I at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well myus.com is
bidding on that keyword online shopping
so they're actually appearing above
Amazon's organic listing but that's what
they want to do they want to be found
for that keyword so if they're not
ranking for it organically well they're
bidding on it and if somebody happened
to click on that listing then myus.com
is going to pay Google something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on time of day
depends on quality score there's a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however the benefit of sem is
visibility and getting traffic to your
website for keywords you're not found
for so that's why sem's such a popular
choice for a lot of companies okay let's
talk about digital marketing that's a
traditional type of digital marketing
channel it's been around a long time you
know we all send emails on a daily basis
and we probably all receive emails on a
daily basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you can send
your emails to a segmented audience okay
so if you have emails from females who
are 35 years of age to 44 that live in
say this southern part of the United
States you can segment that send them an
email and cater that email directly to
that audience and of course you can put
some nice call to action in there you
can design it really snazzy and you
could track it just like you can any
other digital marketing channel so email
is a very effective way to really reach
a target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out if you're
selling a product and the products
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purchase the product
and if you purchase it you're gonna get
30 off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
email marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can basically be a good partner of
yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third-party
affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
choose the Affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you can see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchased for example or
joined you could pay off that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know I would say it's
fairly new I mean if I think about it
we're in 2019 and I remember talking
about Facebook back in 2006 so you're
talking about 13 14 15 years of social
media it's definitely evolved over the
years and but the concept Remains the
Same it involves creating different
types of content depending on the
platform okay so you could be on
Pinterest or Instagram and be dealing
with photos or you could be on Twitter
tweeting out certain characters up to a
limit okay so it really depends on the
social media platform uh that really
drives the type of content you're going
to promote but we know social media can
be effective because people use social
media I mean Facebook is one of the more
popular platforms and if you want to get
your product or service out there you
could certainly pay to have an ad on
Facebook or you could just post your
content organically okay that's the
beauty of social most of your Social
platforms like LinkedIn and Twitter and
Facebook and Pinterest and Instagram
they'll have a paid form of advertising
that you can use to promote your product
or service or you can go the organic
route and you know post content
organically in hopes of driving traffic
back to your website so with social you
do have two options here but social is
interesting because a lot of different
social media platforms out there really
really depends on your product or
service okay so an example of social
media marketing especially on Facebook
with Facebook you got mobile and desktop
and you obviously have the opportunity
to post something organically and have
that liked or commented on or shared or
you can post an app and get that liked
commented or shared or clicked and have
people go back to your website and
fulfill the goal of what you want them
to do so moving on to content marketing
it's a Content marketing is really an
effective way of really Distributing
valuable content online and when we talk
about content marketing you know we're
talking about different types of assets
so it could be simply text in the form
of a blog post or it could be a video or
it could be an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create it content these days
especially in digital marketing and the
great thing about content marketing is
you're writing content for a targeted
audience so if you're trying to Target
an audience on say Instagram then you
know who your audience is and you know
what the type of content you're gonna
post on there so it could be in the form
of a video or infographic or just a
graphic and so that's the beauty of
content marketing really putting
yourself out there and depending on the
platform putting yourself out there with
various types of content so for example
if we look at YouTube you can see this
video here about digital marketing
certified associate well hey you don't
need to always write the content you can
produce the content in the form of a
video and post it on YouTube this is a
form of content marketing so that's
content marketing and then let's talk
about mobile marketing so content
marketing a again different types but if
we go now to mobile marketing you can
kind of segue from content to mobile
because the only difference here is with
mobile it's strictly on mobile phone
it's not desktop so mobile marketing is
really a strategy on its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app install and so
you can even compound that by running a
say Google ad as an example and and
running your Google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bit adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to really promote your app
or your product or your service Via
mobile marketing okay let's talk about
the customer life cycle so we know why
we want to do digital marketing we want
to know we want we know what the digital
marketing channels are because we just
talked about them from SEO to social to
affiliate to mobile to content to sem
okay you have a lot of different digital
marketing channels at your disposal so
now how do we go ahead and approach our
customers so that's what we're going to
talk about first so we're going to talk
about different stages of the customer
life cycle okay and the first one is the
awareness stage so we need to get our
customers aware of what we're selling or
what we're promoting okay so they
awareness stage is really what product
does your brand offer that's a question
we want to get out there and we want to
answer okay what does a customer need
your product or excuse me why does a
customer need your product that's a
question we want to answer with digital
marketing okay what solution does your
product provide okay that's an answer to
a question we want to make sure people
understand so these are questions that
we want to be able to answer in the form
of digital marketing whether that be
mobile or content okay so getting our
information out there that answers these
essential questions and if we could do
that then somebody's going to become
aware of our product or service okay so
what product does our brand offer why
does a customer need it and what
solution does it provide okay those are
some key questions that people tend to
ask themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do I really need this is it going to
help me in my wife okay and who who is
selling this I mean who is this brand I
mean that's those are just things that
run through people's mind intuitively
that with the right messaging the right
channel the right type of asset the
right targeted audience you can quickly
make somebody aware of your Brand's
product or service in this stage it's
help potential customers discover your
brand with the help of these different
marketing channels so in the awareness
stage you know content is key so it's to
me if we have a website we need a Blog
because if somebody does come to our
blog from say organic search SEO then we
can write about that product or service
via blog and talk to our customer talk
directly to our targeted audience
through that blog and if we're not
ranking organically we can use paid
search to promote it because paid search
on Google for example basically we can
be right at the top of their search
results and so somebody can actually
really see it when they do a search
because we know millions of people you
search on a daily basis you could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
Facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cj.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these Publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the digital
marketing channels you could focus on
now I will say one thing about display
ads display is part of search engine
marketing you could use display because
you can reach a large number of people
so even though it's listed here low
priority in the awareness stage display
ADS mean that if you're on Google's
Display Network you could pick and
choose your sites your demographics
keywords topics and audience you can
focus on all those different
demographics to really attract a large
number of people so low priority but
it's probably also good to focus on in
the awareness stage okay so content
marketing you must create a high quality
content that people are searching for
without content it's hard to get found
and so to me this is you know where the
blog comes in SEO take that content get
it optimized okay sem if we're not
ranking organically we can make sure
we're at the top of the paid search
results or the the search results for a
particular keyword we want to be found
for and then social media marketing
using different channels depending on
the channel if we're selling you know
training like simply learn does you know
LinkedIn is a good platform for us okay
and then affiliate you know basically
building up a nice network of Publishers
to get the word out so these are all
good channels that we can focus in on so
traffic sources may include paid unpaid
8 social referral display email or
direct so they they could come in the
awareness stage from all different types
of channels even though you're focused
on content I mean you could still get
traffic from mobile or email so now that
we got the word out via all these
different marketing channels there's
that consideration stage so you know
people are aware of us now they're
considering us and that's kind of the
next stage in the process okay so a few
essential questions to address on the
consideration stage hey what features
make your product valuable to others and
how will I increase customer engagement
towards my product so those are answers
to questions you want to ask okay what
features make your product valuable you
want to basically separate yourself from
the competition basically that's what
you're trying to answer okay so if
you're promoting your product or service
on paid search and other people are
bidding on the same keyword how are you
going to stand out and then how will I
increase customer engagement towards my
product so for example if you're on
Facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you got to
create something really snazzy or really
it's going to be attention grabbing or
something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's going to
separate your post from all the other
posts that are in somebody's Facebook
news feed okay so you really have to
work hard to really convince somebody to
get their consideration towards your
product or service so in this stage your
customer considers your product so help
them understand how your product is
valuable okay to me email works really
good here because if you have a targeted
audience this gives you the opportunity
to really answer these questions in that
particular Channel email you could
support that with a promotion and
display I think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to I become aware you
know you can really hone in and really
get them to take that next step okay
with display you can even do remarketing
so if somebody's been to your site
because they're aware of your product
they're curious you can cookie them and
remark it to them via display so display
to me is a good a good channel to use
here okay so you have email mobile
display you know sem these are all you
know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so people are aware we're
moving them further along the funnel
with email marketing we have the
opportunity to promote the product by
sending an email directly to our
audience so with this stage plan your
campaigns around welcoming emails
newsletters we can talk about product
descriptions add ratings and reviews in
the email you know we really just want
to encourage people to purchase the
product that's we're trying to sway them
over so email is a good source to allow
us to do that okay so with mobile
marketing we can promote the products by
setting relevant messages to our target
audience display again retargeting
because we can retarget an audience that
has been to our website I already did
some research about our brand our
product or service and now we're going
to reach back out to them to sway them
so remember we want to encourage
customers to buy a product by creating
detailed articles about the product that
always helps and that's content okay we
want to opt for a customer testimonial
okay that helps sway people and add some
guest blogging okay we can have
ambassadors blog on our behalf or we can
go out and blog on somebody else's is
site okay so blogging works both ways
it's ways of of showing yourself and
telling people hey we know you're
looking for this product here's why you
want to choose us okay moving on from
the consideration to the purchase stage
so they're aware of you they're
considering you and now we're on to the
purchase stage so the questions we want
to really make sure we address here are
how are my prices compared to my
competitors and is my brand more
credible than others okay so they're
considering you but that price point and
it may not even be the price it could be
the shipping for example the price could
be good but the shipping cost could be
high so you really want to do some due
diligence and research on what your
competitors are doing credibility that
goes back to the consideration stage and
testimonials you want to make sure you
have reviews and testimonials to really
Elevate what you're trying to tell
customers and that that is is hey I have
a good brand I have a good product I
have a good service come buy my stuff
come buy my product and service but you
really need to support that claim you
just can't go out and say it and so
supporting that comes in the form of
what other people say and that could be
reviews that could be comments on a
social media platform it could be you
know stars on say Yelp or Google my
business you know make sure you do your
due diligence and make sure you get
people to you know review you or provide
testimonials because people are going to
do their due diligence before they
purchase especially if it's on Google my
business or Yelp or TripAdvisor or
whatever it is you're trying to sell
they're going to be able to see those
reviews and so do your due diligence to
get the reviews and if it is a negative
review hey that's okay you can't please
everyone you're gonna get them that's
the world we live in just make sure you
show your upper hand and and respond
even to the negative as well as the
positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that I made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the Tipping Point to getting
them to purchase say look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their minds now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending out an
email means that if the promos going to
end at midnight send that email out and
tell people they have until midnight and
if they I purchased today you'll even
increase it to 20 percent and email is a
good channel for that mobile can reach a
lot of people through sms okay social
media reaching people instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gets prospects an
offer to help them make that purchase so
you have plenty of channels to choose
from in fact most of these channels the
only one really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is SEO but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a little priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
Publishers who especially those
Publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize Their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could I sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to you know push a product on your
customer but think about how you can
complement that purchases that
purchasers or customers product and then
how to improve the customer buying
experience so again this goes back to
you know what we just said about reviews
get somebody to offer a review and if
they don't give you a full complement of
five stars they only give you three and
a half stars then you know what that's
great feedback because then you can
learn from that and then the other
question is will the customer refer us
to others and if so why so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchasing okay
so let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know to me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you could
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice Channel
you can send in a nice message even you
know social media you know you can thank
your community for supporting you on
this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throw in an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase as a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media you know you could even post a
blog you know promoting you know the
success of a product and then offering a
promotion okay so there's a lot of
things you could be doing here on the
post purchasing stage so to me even
looking at content again you could even
you know put a survey together you could
even put a survey together for for your
Affiliates okay you could even post a
poll on Facebook so it's just working in
with these different channels to get
some feedback about your product and
service so with email mobile you can
engage customers with follow-up emails
or customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you could say
hey look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give them an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're gonna say hey look I really
like this product and they're giving me
10 I'm going to to go ahead and purchase
from these guys again so give those
discounts those active customers or on
the affiliate Network give referral
opportunities to your customers so if
it's an affiliate publisher hey if
they're getting people to your site you
know reward them or if it's an email and
you put a four to a friend get an extra
10 off it doesn't hurt because you're
incentivizing people to help you sell
your product so with social display and
content use those banner ads or use that
content that you display on social or
the blog you're gonna write to give
customers advice in order to maximize
the value of the purchase so again you
can use these platforms to also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do I get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale across sale it could
be a pair of shorts or a water bottle or
an accessory with an exclusive discount
so that's another example what you can
do on the post purchase stage so in
today's world everywhere you go it's all
about digital so today this lecture is
going to be about all the different
marketing channels available piece them
together kind of put together a little
digital marketing course for you so
first off before we get started we're
going to talk about what is digital
marketing and really digital marketing
covers a lot of areas it's very Broad
and really what it refers to just
marketing that a company does a person
does an individual a group an
organization and and they do it in the
form of an electronic device or with the
aid of the internet that's really what
digital marketing is it's just having
something digitally not something
tangible like a billboard or newspaper
or TV and with that there are lots of
places where you can apply digital
marketing and so electronic devices we
think of mobile devices and so you could
certainly use mobile as a form of
digital marketing or to help you with
your marketing efforts digitally okay
you can create apps you can run
advertising on mobile you can
communicate with different people your
target audience via different devices
like WhatsApp and messaging okay uh
there's also search engine search
engines is where a lot of people get
their information from at least start to
do their research to get information you
got social media lots of different
social media platforms all the way from
you know tweeting in to blogging to a
social sharing to social content okay so
a lot of of platforms under the bucket
social media you also have traditional
forms of digital marketing like email
you can use different email platforms to
send out emails so lots of different
ways to communicate your product your
service your message to a large number
of people that are really targeted to
your efforts how is digital marketing
useful well we know provides different
metrics why do we know it provides
different metrics because it's all
digital okay so anytime you send out an
email or post something on Facebook
you're going to get data back when you
get data back you could take that data
to determine how well that post or that
email performed and if it didn't perform
up to expectation you can make changes
to improve performance that's called
optimization okay so that's the Great
great thing about digital marketing it's
useful in that we get data in some cases
instantaneously and we're able to make
changes in order to optimize that
campaign we can also you know provide
personalized user experience so meaning
if we know who our targeted audience is
on say Twitter or LinkedIn or Facebook
we can really cater our messaging to
that group probably most importantly is
that digital marketing compared to
traditional forms of marketing allow us
to really reach a global audience very
easily very easily at a very low cost
that's the key so if I want to Target
people in India or or Nepal or Pakistan
I can certainly do that and I can do
that with the snap of a campaign and I
can get data back and based on the data
I can tailor that experience even better
really just allows us to really hone in
on a particular audience anywhere in the
world very quickly so these are just
three of the main reasons why digital
marketing is useful some other
experiences or uses for digital
marketing again it provides a cost
effective alternative to traditional
marketing so you know for those that are
familiar with purchasing advertise on
say TV or radio you have to pick a spot
you have to pick a program and then pick
a time slot associated with that program
so somebody's watching a program and and
that program tends to draw on a specific
target audience then you want to show
your ad around the time in that program
is slotted to air on TV because you know
you're likely going to reach your
audience however to purchase that time
slot could be competitive and could be
very costly where there are forms of of
advertising and paying for advertising
digitally and those forms are cost per
click or cost per impression and so
using a cost per click or cost per
impression model allows you to really go
head to head in kind of an auction style
format where you can control how much
you pay and potentially get that Prime
spot in front of your target audience so
it really does become cost effective and
it allows you to make small Investments
to get a really substantial return on
Roi so let's just say your cost per
click is only 10 cents but you're
selling a product for ten dollars well
all you need is one click and one sale
to generate a very substantial return on
investment and so knowing that you get
metrics back on a campaign you could
slowly or quickly optimize that campaign
towards a very positive Roi then another
use for digital marketing it just
enables targeting users based on their
actions and preferences so again we can
really hone in on who we want to Target
it really depends on the platform but if
you take Google Google ads for example
and you want to Target the Display
Network well we know we have
demographics we know we have topics we
know we have interest we know we have
retarget audiences in-segment audiences
we have age we have gender so you have a
lot of options available to choose from
to really hone in on who you want to
Target and we talk about remarketing is
another form of digital marketing so you
can set up a marketing campaign so if
somebody comes to your website and does
not purchase the product or service that
you're offering you could take action on
that behavior so I can retarget a group
of people who didn't purchase that's
retargeting or you could do it via
remarketing and basically that's the
beauty of digital marketing allows you
to really Target users based on their
actions some other uses for digital
marketing it helps build brand awareness
and reputation of your business so we
say brand awareness if you're just
launching a company and nobody knows who
you are if we use Google ads as our
preferred method of digital marketing
and establishing campaigns we can choose
that Display Network that Display
Network on Google ads reaches a large
amount of people so you can really get
your name out there and really Target
your attended audience and allow that
targeted intended audience to really
understand who you are because they're
going to see your ad in the form of a
banner or in the form of a video or in
the form of text and so that's the
beauty of digital marketing you can
really reach a lot of people and a lot
of people who might be interested in
your product or service and then digital
marketing provides a platform for you to
be interactive with your audience
helping you stay relevant and
competitive and the best example I can
give here is YouTube and so YouTube's a
really it's a search engine for videos
but it's a very video sharing platform
and so if I upload a video then I can
entice people to comment on that video
or like the video or share the video and
I can really interact with that Audience
by responding to their comments or you
know putting together a playlist or
giving them more videos okay so I can
really interact with my audience and I
could do that on multiple platforms not
just YouTube and video I can blog and
and interact based on somebody's
comments I can have a website and have
live chat and interact with my audience
so there's lots of different ways to
interact with an audience and that's
what digital marketing provides so I
already mentioned a few examples based
on the use as a digital marketing I
mentioned Google's Display Network I
mentioned YouTube and blogging and
social media platforms like Facebook
well there are lots of different types
of digital marketing channels out there
and we're going to talk about a few of
them today going to start with search
engine optimization and so search engine
optimization as you probably know from
the name involves search engine and it
involves really making your site
relevant in the eyes of that search
engine so if you're in the United States
you know that Google has a large market
share meaning a lot of people use Google
on a daily basis so we want to make sure
we do everything we can to optimize our
site in order to make our site relevant
for those coveted keywords now why do we
want to make ourselves relevant for
those coveted keywords that we want to
be found for on search well because a
lot of people use search and when a lot
of people use search and you're found
for those keyword queries then it's
going to increase the flow of organic
traffic to your website so the higher
you rank in theory the more traffic
you're going to get and so when we talk
about optimization okay how do we
optimize our site in order to be
relevant and the eyes of Google well it
really comes down to a two-pronged
approach you have on-page SEO you have
off-page SEO on page has everything to
do with your website in order to make it
relevant off page has everything to do
with your website but not on your
website it means that how can we become
relevant by linking to other websites
for example how can we become relevant
by getting our content on other
platforms so we become relevant in the
eyes of Google so that's off page SEO so
SEO is always going to be two-prong what
you do on your website and what you do
off the website to make sure your
website your domain whatever that domain
is.com or dot org is relevant in the
eyes of Google and so let's take a look
at on page SEO first so like I mentioned
it involves optimizing your website and
when we say optimizing your website
there's a lot of things you can do on
your website to make it relevant in the
eyes of Google and we can look at the
content okay we can look at the source
code and so there are a lot of different
components to be looked at here so you
have the header tag you have the meta
description you have the alt tag you
have how fast your page loads you have
internal linking you have a site map you
have lots of different things going on
here and so for me one of the first
things you should do when you create a
page on your website is to make sure the
title tag is unique and includes those
keywords so if we look here at this
example the title tag is important
because that's what shows up in search
results here you can see the title tag
on Google is up to 65 characters so you
always want to include that keyword in
the title tag then you have your URL and
then you have what you call a meta
description so that's underneath the
rail underneath the title tag and again
this is in search results so organic
search results somebody types in a
keyword you want to be found and you
want your title tag to stick out and you
want your meta description to
specifically describe what it is you're
offering okay so again if somebody's
looking for stock imagery then you want
to make sure that you know that person
who's looking for stock imagery can come
to your website and they can in this
case search for millions of royalty free
stock images photos videos and music and
so you want your description to really
get that person to click on your listing
an organic search that's the whole point
so that's the point of a title tag and a
meta description is you really want to
be found for what somebody's searching
for and you want to be able to show them
that you have what they're looking for
you have something here underneath your
organic search results called sitelinks
and site links are just other or links
two pages on your website and so
unfortunately this is not necessarily in
your control this is in the control of
Google so if Google wants to offer up
site links underneath your title tag
amount of description they will add them
and it's based really on the amount of
content you have and that goes with site
search so you can see also there's site
search there underneath the meta
description all of that is contingent
upon your website do you have a lot of
content and if you have a lot of
relevant content then Google will
naturally add in site links underneath
your organic listing to links to other
pages on your site so that's on page SEO
and then we're going to look at off-page
SEO okay so off page SEO involves using
promotional methods Beyond just
optimizing your site for example
optimizing your title tag and Mana
description might not be enough to get
you to rank for that coveted keyword
query so we need to do some link
building we need to get our name out
there on other websites okay so we need
to be able to establish some external
links or backlinks from high quality
relevant sites to our site and it may
not just necessarily have to be a link
because Google recognizes linked lists
backlinks so just having a reference on
a high quality site may be good enough
to get you in the eyes of Google to
become more relevant okay so that's off
page SEO in definition so really what we
want to do is we want to establish a way
to get links from other websites to our
own or references on other websites to
our website we want to build those links
to help us gain in ranking so there's
lots of ways to do that you have social
media again you have social content
sites like Reddit medium quora you have
blogging okay there's lots of ways to
establish yourself out there on the
internet you just need to make sure the
quality sites and you need to make sure
they're relevant and so when you do get
a link on an external site pointing back
to yours you want to make sure it's a
follow so you want to make sure that
Google knows to follow that link from
that site to yours so if you're out
there establishing content on a
third-party website or another website
and they're going to link back to you
just make sure that it's a follow do
follow not a no follow okay and I'm
going to show you an example of what
that looks like here so if you're not
sure what the difference is here I'm on
backlinko.com and really a no follow
versus a do follow is simply in the href
so in the href if you don't have
anything in there other than the link
then the search engines are going to
follow that link from that external site
to yours and if you have a no follow in
that link then the search engines are
going to ignore the link so you're not
going to pick up the backlink or
external link to your site and that's
simply that side just adding the real
equals nofollow okay so if you see that
in the link pointing to your site from
that external site then that means
you're not going to get credit for that
backlink so you always want to shoot for
a do follow link because that means
you're going to get credit for the
backlink okay so again do follow links
allow searching and crawlers to follow
the link and if they can follow it
you're going to get what they call link
juice and that's going to establish some
reputation to your domain a nofollow
link basically doesn't allow the search
engines to follow that link so it
doesn't pass on the link juice now again
search engine like Google are smart
enough to pick up the association
between a website that talks about your
website and your website so meaning if
you don't have a link and you don't have
a if you have a nofollow link on that
site don't fret because you know Google
has come a long way they're not
necessarily focused on links though it
does help so for example if you are on a
very prominent site and there's no link
then you still may get credit because
Google does recognize linkless backlinks
and that's what they call a linkless
backlink it's just having a reference on
that site but you always want to try and
get that follow not the do not follow
okay so here you can see an example of
off-page SEO okay like TripAdvisor would
be a good example a link that redirects
from TripAdvisor to you know the Oprah
Magazine as an example so the Oprah
Magazine is going to get a a back link
from TripAdvisor to the site so if
Google crawls TripAdvisor then they're
going to be able to see this link and if
it's a follow link they're going to give
the Oprah Magazine that domain credit
from TripAdvisor so for SEO because
there's a two-pronged approach involved
you have on page and off page there's a
lot of tools here a lot of tools so
let's take a look at some of these tools
we're going to look at Google Keyword
Planner we're going to look at Moz
ahrefs we'll get some tools that will
help you with both on page and off-page
SEO so let's start with Google's Keyword
Planner so why are we using Google's
Keyword Planner because we want to find
keywords okay so we can't do on-page SEO
we can't optimize our title tag and meta
description without a good keyword that
we want to be found for so what we want
to do is we want to go into Google ads
now that's a paper click platform okay
so if you want to be found via paid
search you're going to use Google ads
but form an organic search perspective
we can use Google's Keyword Planner so
we need a Google ads account we have a
Google ads account then all we need to
do is go to tools then we need to go to
Keyword Planner and the Keyword Planner
is a good tool because it allows us to
find those coveted keywords so we can
discover new keywords and that's exactly
what we're going to do so for example
we're going to find you know use the
keyword mail delivery if we have a
business that delivers mails to people
what keywords do we want to optimize for
so we're going to be in Google ads we're
going to go to go to tools we're going
to go to Keyword Planner we're going to
discover new keywords and we're simply
just going to type in a keyword so we're
going to click get results and Google's
Keyword Planner is basically going to
give us some information so the keyword
we we chose was mail delivery and
they're telling us that on average over
the last 12 months there's 22 200 search
queries on average over the last 12
months okay so I could see if I click
hover over the graph here I'm going to
be able to see the average over 12
months okay so here I could see the
average over 12 months from July to June
2019. so here what do I want to do I
want to look for Trends because here I
could see the averages go up and down a
little bit but 22 200 is the average
over 12 months and then Google's Keyword
Planner also tells me how competitive
that keyword is so if it's highly
competitive but it's got a lot of search
volume it could be a keyword I may want
to cover it but the beauty of the
Keyword Planner is that they also give
you other keywords to look at okay so
meal delivery service is 49 500 okay so
here you got some other ones best food
delivery service
9900 again some of these are very
competitive but some of them aren't and
so you want to be able to do your due
diligence do some analysis and figure
out what keywords work best for you that
aren't going to be competitive but at
the same time give you some church
volume so if you do rank for that
keyword you should expect x amount of
clicks on that keyword based on the
volume so that's Google's Keyword
Planner alternatively you can use a tool
like moz.com so if I log into Moz we
have a tool called keyword Explorer and
so here I can just type in that same
keyword meal delivery targeting the
United States in English and Moz is
going to give me some information on the
keyword so here they're going to give me
a range in terms of the monthly volume
and again to give me a difficulty score
so they're going to tell me how
difficult this keyword is so out of a
score of 100 it's 53 and they're gonna
tell me what my expected click the rate
could be if I'm ranking for that keyword
more importantly they're going to give
me some other keyword suggestions just
like Google's Keyword Planner so here I
can see prepared mail delivery mail
delivery service mail delivery companies
so there are a lot of different
suggestions of keywords that I can
choose from and if we scroll down we
could see basically some Mansions we
could see the analysis who's ranking for
these keywords so we can really get some
insight as to who's ranking how much
volume how difficult it is what my
estimates could be if I'm ranking
Etc so a lot of information built into
moz's keyword Explorer tool so Moz is
keyword Explorer tool could be a good
option for you if you don't have access
to Google ads and Google's keyboard
planner so if you're working on SEO for
a website and you curious is about what
the off-page SEO situation looks like
well you can use a tool like age prefs
it's free tool you can go here if you're
working on a specific domain and you're
focused on off page you can simply type
in that domain here and then you can
check the back links for that domain
okay so I'm gonna go ahead and type in
my new name my domain and now I'm going
to get a sense of what my backlink
profile is for my domain so here I can
see the number of back links the total
backlinks and notice 85 percent of them
are due follow links so Google is able
to recognize those links and then I
could see referring domains so I have a
124 different domains pointing to my
website and so here I can get a snapshot
of the top 100 backlinks pointing to to
my website and so this just gives me a
snapshot of what's going on with my off
page SEO performance again it's a free
tool it's good to use because it gives
you an idea of what your off-page SEO
situation looks like okay another tool
you could use is pingdom okay you can
set up a free trial here it's good for
14 days and it allows you to you know
look at page speed it allows you to
monitor the site itself in terms of you
know visitors maintenance Etc so you can
use pingdom as well however it's only a
14 day free trial but it does give you
some good insights into SEO now page
load time is one of those on page SEO
factors and so if you're doing on-page
SEO for domain you certainly want to go
into Google analytics and you want to
measure the page load performance of the
pages on your website and so here if I
go to Google analytics and then I go to
behavior and I go to site speed and I go
to speed suggestions here I can see the
pages how many pages I've received over
a period of time and then the average
page load time now if you see the
average page load time is slow and in my
opinion anything over two to three
seconds is going to be slow you need to
be able to take action and so the great
thing about Google analytics the page
load time reporting is it actually gives
you some suggestions so page speed
suggestions so all you need to do is
click on the link here in this case this
particular link or URL on my website has
seven suggestions if I click on that
then page speed insights is going to
open up and what's going to happen is
Google analytics slash page speed
insights is going to analyze this page
and give me some feedback on how the
page is performing not only on desktop
but on mobile as well and so here I can
see if I analyze this page I can see
some of the opportunities to improve the
page load time on desktop and again on
mobile here so here you can see a lot of
the opportunities and a lot of the
issues I have that I can address now if
you're going to manage SEO for a website
then you're going to need an SEO
platform so again Moz is a good example
because we showed you the keyword
Explorer but they also have many other
tools available built right into the
platform for example rankings okay you
can get crawl information so when the
Bots crawl aside what kind of errors are
coming up here I can get some page
optimization so I can choose a keyword
and I can choose a page and Moz is going
to be able to give me feedback to see
what more I could do to improve my
on-page SEO performance okay we
mentioned keyword Explorer in terms of
looking for keywords okay you also have
something called link Explorer as well
so if I go back and choose link Explorer
from my list here then I'm going to go
to a link Explorer and I could type in
any domain again just like on the hrefs
except mods goes a little bit deeper
here okay so they're telling me how many
linking domains and where my keywords
are ranking okay and then I have some
other reports that I can leverage for
off-page SEO I can look at spam scores
for certain websites that are linking to
me because you can disavow yourself from
us being associated with those sites
here you got a link intersect tool so
you can compare one domain against
another to what links are pointing to
that other website site so a lot of
different reports and tools available to
you for off-page SEO under moz's link
Explorer so Moz has a lot of different
tools available and again my
recommendation if you don't use Moz
there's sem rush there's bright Edge
there's a lot of SEO platforms out there
to use but if you're going to focus on
SEO you are going to need an SEO
platform now if you have any more
questions on SEO you know feel free to
go to simplylearn's YouTube account
you'll be able to find a video there for
SEO tutorial for beginners you know take
a look at the video it goes really in
depth about everything we just covered
about on page and off-page SEO so take a
look at the video and if you have any
comments about everything we covered
with SEO feel free to comment underneath
this video here and we'll be sure to
respond accordingly especially if you
have any tips and tricks that you do for
SEO so let's move from search engine
optimization to content marketing and so
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves simulating interest in a
Brand's products or Services by creating
and sharing online material so when we
talk about online material that can come
in many forms or assets say some
examples are blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
ebooks all of this is content generated
it's just in different forms and so you
want to be able to take any one of these
forms of content and be able to
distribute that in some form or fashion
okay so for example blog can be part of
your website a video could be something
you upload to Youtube an infographic
could be something you actually share on
LinkedIn so all these other assets could
be integrated throughout they could be
shared or used on your website okay for
people to grab and share and use and
comment on okay so that's what content
marketing is you need to be able to push
out content so that people have a better
understanding of your product or service
the process of content marketing is you
really want to decide what goal you want
to achieve with your content marketing
campaign you want to Define your buyer
personas to determine the audience best
suited for your content okay so what are
you creating who is it for and then you
want to run content on it to determine
the best type of content that can be
used and we talk about content audits
we're talking about you know content
that has already been posted or people
sharing it are people downloading or
people viewing it and so you want to be
able to understand over time what people
are reacting to so that you can reuse or
continue to use that content that seems
to resonate with your target audience so
you want to choose an appropriate great
content management system so if it's a
Blog you want to use WordPress maybe so
you want to start brainstorming for
ideas for new content ideas so in my
opinion maybe put together a Content
calendar and jot some ideas on that
content calendar then you want to settle
on a particular type of content you want
to create and then you want to be able
to publish and manage your content so
some top popular tools used for Content
marketing you have buffer you have
buzzsumo follower Wong HootSuite so
let's go ahead and take a look at an
example of a Content marketing
management system and we're going to use
WordPress and so if we go into WordPress
here on the back end we're logging a
login and so the reason why we use
WordPress is because we can post blogs
so in WordPress if I go to post here I'm
going to be able to see all the
different posts that have been posted
over a period of time and the great
thing about WordPress is you can
optimize it for SEO so if I go in here
and look at this recent blog post that
has been posted I can go ahead and edit
it and when I edit it okay I'm going to
be able to look at this blog post in a
visual format and I can also look at it
in HTML form so notice I the great thing
about WordPress is I can use imagery I
can insert videos I can insert
infographics I can attach a white paper
case study to it and then again we have
something called yoast SEO plugins and
we've installed a plug-in here so
that'll help us with optimizing that
particular blog post for that particular
keyword we're trying to Target and so
here you can see our Focus keyword is
remarketing and retargeting okay so we
have that in the title tag okay we also
want to make sure it's in The Meta
description and so here we have an
internal link we have it in the
introduction okay we have it you know
spread throughout the content so yoast
does a good job of allowing us to make
sure we're integrating that keyword into
our blog post but the key to blog
posting is we want to again follow the
process we want to be able to choose
content for our intended audience and in
this case with a blog post we can ride
up to you know 500 to 3000 keywords and
the whole point is we're trying to
introduce our audience to a particular
topic that resonates with our product or
service and so that's the great thing
about blogging that's the great thing
about WordPress is that you know it's
very easy to use uh you can integrate
with SEO you obviously have commenting
you have different plugins that you can
add in there uh very easy to edit and so
there's a lot you can can do here with
WordPress and blogging so another
example of content marketing is video so
with video you have the ability to
upload this video to popular video sites
like YouTube or video and you can
optimize that particular video with
title tags and and hashtags and
descriptions and you can see the
interaction here so you can see how many
views how many likes shares the ability
to share the ability people for saving
it and there's just a lot of
interactivity when you have video you
can also use video as I mentioned on
your blogging platform if it's WordPress
you can also use video and social media
platforms like Twitter LinkedIn and
Facebook so video is a very popular form
of content marketing lots of good video
tools out there to create a video a hike
quality video is what you want to put
your product service in the best
Forefront okay so that people can react
they can share they can comment they can
follow they can like okay so that's what
you want to do is think about video
because video is very versatile and
Powerful in terms of getting your
message out there so let's move from
content marketing to social media
marketing and social media marketing
really involves creating content if it's
that blog if it's that video that you
created for Content marketing and really
using different platforms to increase
your visibility whether that be traffic
whether it be engagement whether it be
brand awareness or any other marketing
goals that you have that's what social
media is good for because social media
will take that content take what you're
trying to get out there and really allow
you to hone your marketing goals against
that okay so if it's Facebook and you
got some videos that you want to post up
there okay what's your goal is your goal
to then post the video to get traffic to
your website or to build brand awareness
or to just get people to react by
sharing or liking and so that's what
social media is good for it's really
good for taking content and really
Distributing it to your target audience
okay so uh sharing content allows you to
you know generate user generated content
or it allows you to create interactive
content and again you can use
infographics or you can apply content
with imagery or post videos or do things
that are interactive like polling and
contests so a lot of flexibility in
terms of the content that you could
share on social media and so you want to
establish a process for social media
marketing so this is the digital
marketing course of it so you want to be
able to have a process and you want to
be able to set up goals that you want to
achieve with your social media campaign
because just posting content for
content's sake is really not going to
generate anything for you so you want to
set up those goals ahead of time then
you want to understand what content
would be best suited for your target
audience so if our goal is to generate
brand awareness then maybe an
infographic is what we want to do okay
maybe that's the best choice of asset
for our target audience based on the
platform with social media we also want
to research what the competition is and
find out what works for them so it's
very easy to do on social so if you
already have a competitor on Facebook
you can always go to your competitor's
website and you can always see you know
what they're posting and what kind of
reaction engagement they're getting for
a particular post so it doesn't help
before you go live to do some due
diligence about your competition you can
also conduct a social media audit and
again what we mean by audit just like on
the content side we want to be able to
see what's worked and what's not worked
in the past and with digital marketing
recall you can get instant metrics back
so if you posted something last year and
you're thinking about posting it again
you probably want to do an audit to see
over the past year what posts have
worked and have not worked for you then
you want to pick and choose the social
media channels or platforms and to find
a strategy for each of them because if
you have a video then the video may work
on say YouTube or Instagram but they not
necessarily work for LinkedIn and
Twitter and so you want to be able to
pick and choose the asset the strategy
and align it with the appropriate
platform then you want to take
inspiration from case studies and other
famous Brands so again continue to learn
I mean that's the beauty of social media
marketing most big companies
medium-sized companies even smaller
companies that have performed well are
out on social media so take a look at
some other companies that inspire you or
some other companies in your industry or
even again your competitors and see what
they're doing and what they're posting
and what kind of Engagement they're
getting so you should always you know be
able to seek out what others are doing
on social and to me this is important
create a social media content counter
and this isn't necessarily the very end
of the process this goes back to the
beginning of the process so when you're
establishing goals and you're
establishing kind of type of content you
want to use that should all be part of a
social media content calendar and I'm
going to show you an example of one here
shortly and then again you want to be
able to test evaluate and adjust your
strategy because again you're getting
metrics and if you post a video on
Facebook and it's taking off then
meaning in terms of likes and shares you
probably want to consider maybe doing
another one that complements that so
here's a broad example of a Content
calendar okay it's in a spreadsheet
Again by no means does one size fits all
but just to give you an idea if we're
blogging what we want to do is we want
to pick our target audience maybe that
be country or particular demographic and
you want to come up with some topics
ahead of time here and you want to maybe
put the status up there of you know it's
just a draft or an idea when it actually
does go live you want to turn it on live
you want to pick your date add some
comments okay create your content and
you know what's good about a Content
count is you can also work in seos you
can assign keywords and then you could
add those keywords to Moz for ranking uh
you can create your title and meta
description then you can carry that
content forward and choose a particular
social media platform to post to so
that's the beauty of a social or excuse
me a Content calendar is it allows you
to think about things up front and then
prepare the content accordingly so you
can optimize them for organic search and
post it on social media for off-page SEO
and for social media marketing and so
you just want to get organized ahead of
time using a spreadsheet in this case
Google Sheets to lay out the topics
ahead of time so you can write the
content for your intended audience that
to me is the way to go now remember
there's lots of different forms of
content that you can use with social
media marketing here we have video so
you can see this video can be posted on
YouTube or LinkedIn or wherever and the
whole point is you want to be able to
measure engagement here you can see this
is just an image it's just a file and
this has been posted on Facebook so here
we can see many likes and comments and
then share hairs and so you want to be
able to leverage different forms and
different assets across social media to
see actually what works and what doesn't
work and again look at what other
companies have done whether they be
competitors or not see what type of
assets they're posting and what's
working for them now when it comes to
social media marketing there are lots of
tools available okay you got buffer
HootSuite sprinkler post planner later
Sprout social I mean the list of social
media marketing tools is endless and
just like SEO you will need a platform
to work with so with SEO we showed you
Moz as the SEO platform with social
we're going to show you sprout social
because with Sprout social if you have a
Content calendar if you have a lot of
different assets you want to be able to
organize those assets and content across
multiple channels and the great thing
about using a social media calendar is
yes you can publish and organize your
post accordingly you also have most
social media platform tools have
listening so you can listen in on
keywords and audiences different brands
and industries and conversations that
are being had about a specific topic
okay and again most social media
platforms if not all have reporting and
so this is important because you can
actually see you know what how your post
or different assets are performing in
terms of Engagement and so to me that's
important if you're going to focus on
social media as a platform as a channel
you want to have a social media platform
tool that will help you organize your
content publish it accordingly listen in
and and get that report to help you
figure out what's engaging and what's
not engaging again so that you can you
know react to the content content that
you're using and sharing so that's
Sprout social as an example but you will
need a social media platform now the
other benefit to social media is in some
cases you can actually pay to have your
post out there and so for example on
Facebook we could set up a paid campaign
to Target our intended audience and so
with Facebook Facebook owns Instagram so
you have the ability to really put your
content out in front of your target
audience on Facebook and Instagram and
so what you need to do is go to Facebook
ads manager and simply just create an
account or campaign
um you want to be able to create a
campaign and by creating a campaign that
means you're gonna have to go through a
particular process here so if we first
we want to do is choose our objective
okay so you always want to have an
objective for your campaign so so is it
going to be brand awareness is it going
to be to drive you know traffic is it
going to be to drive conversions so you
want to choose a goal or objective if
you're advertising really on any
platform then you want to be able to
choose your audience so who are we
trying to Target so with Facebook you
know you can Target any specific age
gender demographic based on interest and
behavior so you can choose specific
placements and you can assign a budget
okay and then on the ad side you have
different types of ads that you can use
you can do single image or video you can
do a carousel okay meaning you can
rotate different images as a collage or
different videos as a collage and again
you can choose exactly where you want
your ad to be shown for example desktop
or mobile news feed Facebook and stream
video you got Instagram feed you got
even mess messenger so you have a lot of
options available to you on where you're
at or video is going to be shown and
then you can support that with a
headline description and you can send
that traffic back to your website you
can even test call to action buttons
okay so you can expand your ad with a
call to action button and so you can do
a lot here this is just Facebook you can
really do a lot of specific targeting
now with Facebook advertising it's a
cost per click model so anytime somebody
does click on that ad you're going to
pay but it allows you to really get your
content out there in front of your
tenant audience if you're not doing it
organically meaning you're not posting
on Facebook on a regular basis or maybe
you want to supplement those organic
posts then doing this is a good way to
really get your brand out there if it's
awareness if to drive traffic or to
convert Facebook is a good option
LinkedIn Twitter all these social media
platforms offer that up that option up
to do paid advertising now if you want
more information about social media we
have a great video on YouTube already
how to start social media marketing it
really goes into the details about
organic social and what I just covered
with paid social specifically on
Facebook so take a look at that video
and again if I missed anything on the
social media side feel free to comment
or add in your best practice whether
that be part of the process or a
different platform that you use for
social media okay let's switch to our
next digital marketing channel and
search engine marketing says search
engine marketing is an advertising model
that is good for driving traffic to your
site because you're paying each time
someone clicks on your advertisement now
how is that an equal trade well because
you can advertise on channels like or
search engines like Google or Bing or
Admiral which has a a big Network that
includes Google you can actually pay
your way to the top of search engine
rankings and so if you're at the top for
paid search and somebody searches
something like shoes or something to
that effect your ad can appear at the
very top even above local search even
above organic search and so the
visibility is there it's a good way for
you to then get that traffic that uh
that you you covet for certain keywords
and because you're getting traffic or
other potential to get traffic you're
going to pay each time somebody clicks
on these ads so you have multiple
choices on the type of asset you want to
use including text image video Etc so
there's more to to it than just Google
Bing adroll I mean you have LinkedIn you
have Twitter you have Facebook so you
have lots of different ways to advertise
and get your ad in a more prominent
position you just have to pay for it and
I just showed you that under social
media marketing Facebook you can create
an ad have your ad targeting your
audience and in return you're gonna pay
Facebook works the same way for most of
these networks okay so when you actually
set up a campaign like anything you do
when you set up a campaign you want to
determine the goal you want to achieve
for the campaign you want to do that up
front especially when you're talking
about paying per click if you're paying
per click then you definitely want to
make sure you determine what your goals
are so you can measure them accordingly
then you want to choose in this case a
relevant list of keywords you could do
it for your brand meaning you could
choose your own brand keywords you could
choose keywords related to what you're
your brand is trying to offer whether
that be a service or product and once
you choose a relevant list of keywords
you can finalize those keywords and then
bid on them so once you start bidding on
them then what you're going to do is
align those keywords with a headline so
it's all done within the framework of
any platform you're advertising on
really the key here that I want to
really emphasize is when you establish a
campaign or set up a campaign you need
to establish what the goal is because
when you actually choose your keywords
and write your ads and launch the
campaign and start paying Google or Bing
or whomever it is you're advertising
with you want to be able to measure
those goals so that's really the
important part here because regardless
of where you advertise you're going to
be able to monitor campaign results and
so with Google you can even import
conversions into the campaign so for
example if I go to Google ads for
example if I go to tools okay you can
see I'm running campaigns what am I
trying to accomplish with these
campaigns well in this case I'm trying
to get donations people click on
donations so I can go to tools click
conversions and then I can see what
conversions are added to my account and
that way I can measure my campaigns
against these conversions okay if I
don't see a conversion air I can
certainly create one or import it from
in this case Google analytics so that's
the important thing you want to be able
to measure your campaigns with your
conversions and then just as important
you want to be able to optimize your
campaign because if it's not performing
if you're running a campaign you're
running up costs and you're not getting
conversions you're probably not going to
be continuing to run those campaigns so
you want to optimize your campaign and
retarget potential customers so
retargeting is always a good option
retargeting is targeting someone one who
that went to your website and basically
acted in a certain way meaning they went
to a certain page or abandoned the card
or actually purchased or downloaded
something okay you define what action
you want that audience to take in order
to retarget to them okay so the whole
point is you can configure your
retargeting campaign based on certain
behavior on your website and the whole
point there retargeting is you're
pulling people back to your website so
in addition to optimizing you know
search campaigns you can one of the
benefits of search engine marketing is
you can run retargeting campaigns so
here's an example of an ad okay so here
you could see it's a good ad in the
sense that it's using everything
available to it so for example here I
could see three headlines so Google in
this example allows you to add in three
headlines so here you can see simply
learn official site get certified I'd
get ahead then you can see
simplylearn.com so they're taking
advantage of three headlines and then
here you can see two description lines
and so each description line you can
have up to 90 characters and so you want
to be able to take advantage of what
Google gives you the more information
you can add the better well here you can
see some other types of ads here you can
see a banner ad for slack okay here you
can see betterment.com running an ad
okay so this looks like an ad that is on
YouTube so because you can see after a
few seconds you can skip the ad okay so
here's a video ad here's an image ad
here's a text ad so depending on what
platform you advertise on you have an
option on what type of asset you want to
use you know the one thing I like about
Facebook is they offer up a multitude of
options in terms of assets you can run a
single image ad you can run a carousel
meaning you can have multiple images you
can run a video you can run a
combination video image you would
obviously run text okay with a thumbnail
see you have a lot of options in terms
of the type of AD you can run so before
we move into our next Channel let me
just show you an example of you know how
an ad actually looks on a particular
website so here you can see I'm on
buzzfeednews.com okay here you can see
uh Volkswagen Golf is running an
advertisement in Spanish on this
particular site so they're either using
Google or some other platform and having
that platform if it's Google post their
ad on this particular site so here you
can see it's a banner app and if we're
in Google ads and you're setting up a
text ad let me just run through you with
the text that it looks like remember you
want to always take advantage of what's
offered to you because especially text
ads you have very few characters and
with very few characters it's hard to
get your message across so with Google
you have your final URL which is where
people are going to go to after they
click on your ad but you have one not
one not two but three headlines that you
can take advantage of so we're talking
about help and child hunger help today
you know you can always add in visit our
website for more info I mean you want to
take advantage of what's available to
you now again here you can see in this
example I'm only allotted 30 characters
and so if you go over then your ads not
going to get approved so you really have
to be cognizant of the character counts
and getting your point across because
writing text ads is not the easiest
thing to do when you're limited to
characters now with Google you have what
they call display path so after the
domain you can add in a couple of
keywords in there and then you have
description line one and description
line two so again take it advantage of
what's available if you're not sure what
copyright grab some from the website and
paste it in there you want your ads to
be healthy and have as much information
as possible and then the one thing I
will say about Google ads is they also
have extensions so extensions are
exactly that they're extensions to your
text ad so here you can see I have four
extension these are actually site links
so Google ads offers up something called
ad extension so it could be call outs
site links it could be location
extensions app extensions they have a
number of different extensions that they
can append to your ad so take advantage
of that as well remember the whole point
of ads is to make a compelling case for
your product or service so that somebody
can click on the ad and go to your
website and then perform the action you
want them to perform now if you have any
more questions about Google ads feel
free to check out our in-depth video
about Google ads it covers everything A
to Z on Google ads you know we also have
videos on our simply learned YouTube
playlist for Facebook uh Twitter social
media marketing so if you're curious to
know a little bit more about search
engine marketing you know check out any
one of these videos that we have listed
on our YouTube channel okay so let's
move over to affiliate marketing now and
so with affiliate marketing really it's
interesting and unique in that affiliate
marketing involves paying out
commissions and who are you paying
commissions to while you're paying
commissions to website owners or
Publishers or people who have websites
with lots of content or people who have
websites that attract a lot of users and
so the whole point is you want to be
able to find those websites to advertise
your product or service okay these
people who are selling your product or
service on your behalf are going to to
get commissioned or incentivized based
on whatever action you put out there so
it could be registrations just getting
your Affiliates to help you with getting
people registered or signing up for your
email or you know for a lot of you
conversions you're trying to sell a
product say you want help in selling
that product or it could be
subscriptions okay signing up to
something okay so you determine what it
is you want to incentivize your
Affiliates for you also determine how
much you're going to incentivize them
and that's the great thing about
affiliate marketing it's it's no
different than having a sales team
um to support you what are the stats for
affiliate marketing well you need to
find a platform there are lots of
different affiliate platforms out there
you know Commission Junction or cj.com
comes to mind because these platforms
are going to help you find these
Affiliates or Partners okay so they're
the broker and all this and so what once
you set up your platform you're going to
establish rules guidelines post images
and Banners and assets for those
Affiliates to use on their websites and
more importantly again you're going to
establish the commission so the
commission doesn't have to be the same
for all Affiliates it could simply be
you know your top Affiliates get a
higher commission as opposed to just
some other Affiliates who get a starting
commission you establish everything on
the platform the affiliate platform that
you choose now Affiliates apply to
advertise on your behalf so they're
going to say hey I'm interested in
selling your product or service so
you're going to use that platform if
it's Commission Junction to approve or
disapprove the re Affiliates request to
advertise on your behalf and really what
you want to try and do is leverage the
platform as best as you can a lot of
these Affiliates are out to make money
and some of them are really good you
need need to be able to choose the
affiliate that is going to represent
your brand product or service the best
so it's simple customer clicks on an ad
or link okay on that affiliate website
and they go to your website and they
perform an action so that could be a
purchase or registration a subscription
a download an email sign up you
determine that and the great thing is
these affiliate networks the CJ's
commission Junctions of the world will
record everything they're Tracking not
only traffic from the affiliate website
to your website but they're also
tracking the conversions the transaction
is validated and credited to the
affiliate by the broker and then the
affiliate is paid his or her commission
so that's how it works so the more the
affiliate sells or converts on your
behalf the more they're going to make
and that's the beauty of the affiliate
Network so here's an example of
affiliate marketing okay here you can
see a an advertisement here okay so you
can see profit from our experience earn
up to 12 advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce list leader so somebody
clicks on that link joins and then this
person is going to get a commission
based on somebody joining for free again
I mentioned Commission Junction there
are also some other affiliate marketing
tools out there uh Amazon Associates a
win trade doubler Max Bounty I mean
there's a there's there's a lot out
there
cj.com is the one I've used in the past
but you know give some of these other
platforms a chance okay it doesn't hurt
to even be on multiple platforms you
have nothing to lose okay when you're on
a platform basically the platform again
is acting as the mental person they're
introducing you to Affiliates and so
every time you actually pay an affiliate
a commission they're going to get their
cut of it so they're going to get a
small percentage as well so just keep
that in mind but you know give it a try
I try one or two of these Affiliates if
you find you're getting quality
Affiliates that are selling your product
or service great if you don't then you
know feel free to change you know
affiliate networks it's that simple but
the key here is find the Affiliates you
think are going to best represent your
brand product or service because those
Affiliates are likely going to be the
ones to convert for you and if you're
small business starting out and you need
some help affiliate marketing is the way
to go okay let's move over to Native
advertising okay so native advertising
so neither advertisements means that
your ad is showing up next to content
that basically naturally fits so these
are advertisers that are featured on a
platform alongside the content okay that
isn't paid for okay so for example here
you can see a paid post okay this is by
Spotify okay this paid post okay was on
BuzzFeed this particular post was
probably on a news article related to
music because they're talking about you
know bands that probably wouldn't exist
without Led Zeppelin okay so for Spotify
you using native advertising allows them
to put their ad next to content related
to their ad here you can see another
BuzzFeed article okay 11 great Amazon
deals that will be music to your ears if
your audiophile here you can see an
advertisement next to the article so you
can see the ad about Led Zeppelin and
here you can see the actual article is
about music so the whole point about
Native advertising is making sure
there's a connection between the ad and
the article so Spotify is advertising
okay their product and service on an
article on BuzzFeed which happens to be
about music so a good example we use
BuzzFeed just a second ago so if we go
to BuzzFeed here you can see see them in
TV movies and here you can see got an ad
here if we scroll down uh keep scrolling
down we can see another ad here for HBO
and so this ad makes sense because it's
placed on TVs and movies so people who
go and read the content are going to see
an ad related to that content so that's
generally what Native advertising is you
need to be able to be able to place the
ad on the right pages okay so you're
going to need an ad Network for that so
we talked about paid search advertising
we talked about Google ads so Google ads
has the ability to place your ad
natively on particular pages that are
relevant to that ad so that's really
what Native advertising is all about
making sure that your ad is placed next
to content that's naturally relevant so
if you need more information about
affiliate marketing feel free to visit
simply learns YouTube channel we have a
nice uh in-depth video about out
affiliate marketing to get more
information about the platforms how it
works and all the tips and best
practices about how to run a successful
affiliate marketing campaign so let's
turn our attention to email marketing
now so email marketing very traditional
form of digital marketing spent around
the longest it's kind of the grandfather
of all digital marketing channels so
email marketing really is used to
personalize emails in order to convert
that recipient or that perspective user
into a customer and so like all the
other digital marketing channels we want
to follow some type of flow or process
or methodology and the first step in
email marketing is you have to identify
your target audience okay when you
identify your target audience you're
going to create a segment okay so in
other words you don't want to send one
email to everyone because not everyone
on is going to be interested in that
email so in order to get somebody
interested you need to be able to send
an email tailored to that audience okay
so that audience can respond and react
accordingly so once you target that
audience and create segments email
segments you're going to create the
campaign and set up an appropriate call
to action one note here is when you
create the campaign and set up that
appropriate call to action that call to
action is going to be aligned with your
goal so what is the goal of the email
campaign is it simply to get people to
click on something and purchase or is it
simply to get people to click on
something and sign up or watch something
or submit some information or download
or whatever the case you need to
establish that up front just like you
would with a search engine marketing
campaign or any other type of campaign
you want to run so there are lots of
tools out there there just like with
affiliate marketing you want to choose
an appropriate email marketing tool
there are plenty to be Had Each work in
a very similar nature some offer
different pricing models meaning you
know you can send an email to ex
recipients for flat fee or you pay a
small amount per email address each one
is slightly different in terms of how
they price but in terms of the features
they all work in a very similar fashion
and we're going to show you an example
of one here shortly so when you choose
that email marketing tool you're going
to test your emails before you send them
out and then when you test your emails
you're going to use that email marketing
tool to actually send the campaign after
it's been tested okay so you want to
send the campaign you can immediately
send them out or you can schedule them
now a best practice with an email is
when you actually send one out you're
sending an email out to your target
audience you want to create probably two
emails per segment audience why because
you want to add an attractive subject
line and copy to the email but if you
send two emails to the same target
audience then you want to test the
subject lines you want to be able to see
what subject lines going to entice
somebody to open the email okay that's
the beauty of email marketing is you can
do that okay so you can set up your a
design based on your target audience but
it's always the subject line that people
see first so you want to write an
attractive subject line and copy that's
going to entice somebody to open the
email so why not send two emails to each
target audience that way you can see
what email subject line works best so
that's the whole idea about performing a
b tests to test out different ideas it
doesn't necessarily have to be a subject
line it can be the same subject line two
emails but the difference being the body
of the email now it's totally up to you
but the idea here is to always split out
your emails per target audience and just
like any other channel whether it be
affiliate or search engine marketing
organic search you want to analyze
performance and in the case of emails
it's always about open rates how many
people are opening then how many people
are clicking and then how many people
are actually responding are they
converting or downloading or whatever it
is you want them to do you need to be
able to monitor the behavior because for
example if your open rates don't work or
they're low then you know something's
wrong with your subject line so you want
to be able to make an adjustment so
here's an example of an email from
Airbnb it's a simple email okay they're
just simply trying to get somebody to
click on that call to action to take the
survey okay that's really all it's about
here with this particular email so who's
their target audience well their target
audience could be somebody who's already
stayed at a Airbnb property or it could
be somebody who used the app probably
Airbnb has already targeted this
audience and they're sending this survey
to a particular audience so that they
can get the best results okay so that's
a good example of a targeted email with
a good call to action that's getting
somebody to take the survey so they're
probably measuring I mean people opened
it how many people clicked on the CTA
the call to action and then how many
people actually filled out the surveys
you need to follow each step and track
each step accordingly okay so again some
popular tools used in email marketing
let's take a look at MailChimp here uh
but I will mention like Marketo is a
good marketing automation tool now owned
by Adobe Marketo allows you to send
those drip campaigns so if somebody
doesn't purchase right away you can send
up follow-up emails like say one day out
or seven days out or 14 days out so
HubSpot Works in a very similar fashion
you want to be able to methodically plan
out your emails that's the point I'm
trying to make here so let's take a look
at MailChimp so if we go over into
MailChimp a very easy interface okay
here if we go under audience we can
actually see who our audience is if we
could break out our audience into
different groups you can have a simple
test list you can have people who
purchase people who subscribe to
something okay so you can break out your
audience into different groups okay when
it comes to campaigns you can see
campaigns that are already been built or
you can create your own campaign okay so
in the case of MailChimp we can actually
see what campaigns have been dropped or
sent out already and then we could see
the opens the clicks and then the
conversions so MailChimp has some nice
reporting so you want to be able to
measure the reports or how well the
campaign performs so here we can see
specifically how many people opened
clicked how many people bounced or email
addresses bounced and how many people
unsubscribe from the list and here we
can see you know the top links that have
been clicked okay the subscribers with
the most opens did anybody perform any
social media activity okay what
locations open the email okay so you can
actually see a lot of good information
here writing MailChimp and you want to
be able to react to the emails you send
out so if an email is not performing
okay you want to learn from that so you
don't make the same mistake again the
great thing I like about MailChimp too
they have a lot of nice templates to use
so if you're trying to create a template
here you got some templates that you can
leverage so that's MailChimp kind of in
a nutshell MailChimp you can pay up
front buy credits and with those credits
you could send send out emails to a
number of people okay so that's how
MailChimp Works they do have a free
trial so you can set up an account using
the free trial now if you need any more
information about MailChimp or email
marketing in general take a look at the
email marketing webinar we have set up
honors simply learn YouTube account now
let's finish up with online PR or press
releases so we talked about SEO and
social and search and affiliate and
email marketing and and content native
advertising let's talk about online PR
here because with online PR it really
does involve working with digital
Publications or blogs or other content
related websites for example content
related websites could be newspaper
digital newspaper sites like the New
York Times okay the whole point of
online PR is you want to try and get
some publicity day on those on those
websites publicity means awareness for
the brand it means traffic to the
website and eventually some loyalty
future customers and conversions
channels that can be used to maximize
your online PR efforts for example you
can connect with reporters on social
media to develop a relationship so you
can just follow some reporters see if
they're covering specific Industries or
verticals and if they are similar to
what you're offering then it's probably
a good idea to reach out to them you can
use engaging user reviews to help
humanize your brand or you can respond
to comments that help generate
productive conversations so those are
all certain things you can do to
generate awareness and Buzz for your
brand so really the one thing I want to
point out about online PR is basically
you can also hire a PR firm and they can
do some of the heavy lifting for you or
like I said you can reach out to
different reporters or different
influencers even to help push your
product or brand now if you're trying to
go at it alone on the online PR which
you could do if you don't reach out to
reporters or influencers or you're
active in trying to build your brand
through a conversation you can always
use a third-party service like pr.com so
pr.com allows you to you know basically
create your own profile you know submit
content to your own profile or even
submit press releases if you submit
press releases then other news agencies
are going to pick up on those press
releases so it's a good way to get your
press releases out there likes of Yahoo
and Google might pick up those press
releases and give you some you know much
needed visibility you can also use other
tools like you know p ER newswire for
example so it works in a very similar
way again it's a press release
distribution Network so you can go ahead
and sign up for an account get that
press release out there and they do the
distribution for you or you can also use
aggregation sites so there are lots of
different aggregate sites out there and
so what aggregate websites do is they
help disseminate and distribute your
content so here you can see some of the
new aggregator websites of 2019 you got
Feedly Panda Tech Mimi Metacritic
e-science news the morning news so you
have a lot of options available to get
your content out there okay so what
these sites do is basically pick up
articles that fit their website fit
their theme fit their target audience so
you do have options in the form of
third-party tools as well okay so if you
don't hire a PR firm which could be
expensive you can certainly go at it
alone by signing up for any one of these
particular products or services today
we're going to talk about digital
marketing tools so fasten your seat
belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the best digital
marketing tools so past present and
future digital marketing tools is the
way to look at this with a good focus on
a lot of different marketing channels
here so we're going to focus first on
SEO talk about some of the tools related
to on page and off page we're going to
switch over to paid search talk a little
bit about paid search tools we're going
to talk about email marketing and some
of the email marketing platforms and the
tools within those platforms the center
of it all is web analytics so Google
analytics is the tool we'll be taking a
closer look at in today's webinar and
all that it has to offer okay affiliate
marketing we'll talk about some of the
tools available to you in for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available all the platforms available so
we'll hone in on a couple of examples
there and then we'll also talk about
some competition tools available for you
so there's a whole Suite of tools the
one caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that I use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so it'll be good good to
kind of see what else is out there so if
you have something to share share it by
all means what we're trying to do is
share what we think are you know best
practices and some of the most popular
or most used tools out there in the
industry so that's what we're gonna do
the goal is to get you to better
understand some of the tools we're using
a little bit more detail and what we're
going to do is start out with search
engine optimization okay so search
engine optimization or organic search we
have a mixture of paid and free so
there's a lot of different platforms but
if you're focusing on SEO you certainly
need to use an SEO platform so there's
sem Rush okay you also have Google
search console which is free so if you
don't have a SEO platform you definitely
need to be using Google search console
and so we'll take a closer look at that
there's Google Keyword Planner which is
actually situated under Google ads and
so if you're running Google campaigns on
Google search Network or even the
Display Network you have access to a
great tool called Keyword Planner and if
you know anything about SEO you'll know
that using Google's Keyword Planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
Moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another SEO
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool and screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
hrefs that help us with all aspects of
SEO primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small subset of what really is available
out there in the market so let's go
ahead and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about SEO is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
Keyword Planner and Google's Keyword
Planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in optimizing for
because not only one are they relevant
but two they're going to have high
volume and low competition so let's take
a look at an example in Google's Keyword
Planner so here I am I'm in Google's
Keyword Planner and as I mentioned
before Google's Keyword Planner is
situated under Google ads okay so you
have to have a Google ads account to use
Google's Keyword Planner and so when
you're in Google ads you simply go to
tools and then under Tools you're going
to select Keyword Planner so what we
want to do is look for keywords we're
focusing on organic search not
necessarily paid search so organic
search we want to hone in on some
keywords so let's just use one of the
examples that Google's given us here
meal delivery so we're going to just
type in mail delivery and get some
results so notice I can enter a domain
as a filter and so in other words hey I
could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if I wanted to
but I'm asking Google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
I'm going to click click get results
notice I can add another key to it if I
wanted to but I'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that I can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what Google Keyword Planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here I
get a column for competition so I'm able
to see whether that's a very competitive
keyword or not and then just to give you
an extra Edge when you're choosing
keywords you can get a sense of what the
keyword May cost if you wanted to bid on
that for paid search so for mail
delivery I can see it's anywhere between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range
16.61 so that should alert me to the
fact that hey if I'm gonna try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's compared additive by
telling me high competition but I know
that the cost per click seems a little
bit high and what is a little bit High
well you know I could see some other
keywords here that you know a dollar to
three dollars okay I could see some
other ones that are even lower than the
seven dollars they're suggested so
that's a indication that the keyword is
highly competitive so the idea here
using Google's Keyword Planner is one we
want to get an idea of what other
keywords are out there that are relevant
so it helps stimulate some ideas for
relevancy two we can get an average
monthly search volume so we want to know
on average over the past 12 months how
many search queries I can expect from
this keyword and then three I can get a
sense of the competition how competitive
is this keyword so if I try to optimize
for this keyword and I want to rank for
it organically is it competitive if it's
competitive then it's probably going to
take me a bit longer to be be found for
this keyword on page one of Google so
that's the whole idea behind Google's
Keyword Planner and note that you could
change some of the settings here so if
you want to choose a different language
okay you can hone in on a longer or
shorter period of time you can even
choose a specific location so I chose
Texas I can certainly choose the entire
United States to get a sense of what the
volume would be for the total us so you
have settings that you can change and
manipulate to get you the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind Google's Keyword Planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively I can
certainly use another tool to find
keywords so I have a mods account so I
logged into Moz and Moz has a tool
called keyword Explorer so if I use that
same keyword I used in Google's Keyword
Planner mail delivery I'm going to ask
Moz to give me some data on that keyword
so this is for the entire United States
and again I can change that if I wanted
to okay so I can hone in on a specific
country or different country so what
Moses tell me hey for this keyword in
the entire United States I'm looking at
anywhere from eleven and a half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume now
what Moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between 1 and 100 and so I
could see this is pretty much right down
the middle in terms of difficulty okay
so if it's zero it's an easy keyword if
it's if it's a hundred it's very
difficult and then that means you have a
lot of competitors who are optimizing
for this keyword that are ranking for
this keyword and so Moz gives us the
volume they give us the competition and
they just like Google's Keyword Planner
gives us some other keyword words that
we can potentially hone in on so here I
could see keyword delivery plans
delivery services
Etc so I can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so Moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis related to the
keyword you know they also give you some
good keyword suggestions so Moz is a
good alternative tool and we'll be
coming back to Moz related to SEO for
some other of its features but for now
if you don't want to necessarily use
Google's Keyword Planner because maybe
you're not running Google ads you can
always use Mazda remember Moz has
basically a freemium version I mean you
can sign up for a free account and you
can sign up for a free account as a test
trial and you could test it for a period
of days and leverage its tools during
that free trial to get a better sense of
how these tools work so we want to be
able to use Moz we want to be able to
use Google's Keyword Planner not only to
search for all those relevant keywords
available to to you but we want to be
able to choose keywords with high volume
and low difficulty low competition we
also want to select primary and second
keywords wisely so remember when you
optimize you're optimizing a page for
more than one keyword so you want to be
able to have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so Moz gives you that
information and so we want to be able to
leverage the tools available to us to
choose the right keywords so if you need
any more information on this we got a
nice webinar on keyword research for SEO
so take a look at that video on YouTube
to get more specific details about using
SEO tools for keyword research and all
about keyword research in general for
SEO so let's talk about some some other
reasons under SEO what we would use some
of these tools available to us well we
want to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze linking to our web page
okay which ones are good which ones are
not good okay we also want to perform
some competitor analysis so these are
some of the reasons why other than
keyword research why would we use some
of these SEO tools so we have tools
available to us some Majestic hrefs
again Moz let's take a look at Google
search console and I want to hone in on
Google search console because it is free
and it's a must if you're going to work
on SEO you need to be working in Google
search console and so the whole key
behind Google search console so is you
have a website and you need to get that
site verified once it's verified once
Google can recognize that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
Google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what Google does is through this
platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these Pages back to their server
they're letting us know if we actually
have any issues so here I could see I
have some issues with 112 pages and some
of those issues are listed down here so
there could be a crawl issue a 404 you
know reader interact okay so you can see
there's some five unique issues across
112 pages so here I can see submitted
URL Mark no index there's a hundred of
those pages we have some redirect errors
there's seven pages that you know fall
victim to this error and so we can
really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if Google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by Google then we should
probably address the error and so that's
the great thing here about going into
Google search console is you can under
index go to coverage and get a sense of
what Google's indexing and what they're
not indexing okay so these are the
errors I could see they've certainly
were able to crawl and index
9115 Pages uh they were able to crawl
okay and they excluded 54
000 plus pages and then we also have
some pages with some warnings so this is
kind of an overview of what Google Sees
when they crawl our site so when they
say crawl they're coming to our site
they're following links on the site and
every link they follow they're either
going to index that page or they're
going to report to you an error or an
issue that they found if we want these
Pages indexed we need to address the
issues the errors and so that's the
beauty of this report here is Google is
telling us firsthand what the issues are
so we also want to take a look at the
sitemap so you have an opportunity to
submit a site map and a site map is just
a formatted file that includes all your
website URLs and so you're going to have
this file sitting in your root directory
and you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml XML being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let Google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap URL
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what Google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see that we discovered 1
419 URLs so I can go back under coverage
and I can see some of the issues that
they found but if I go back under
sitemaps I can see that these are the
URLs they discovered via the sitemap and
so the whole point of a site map is we
want to be able to get and push the URLs
to Google not have Google come to our
site and discover them so this is a
quicker faster more efficient way to
communicate with Google all the URLs
that you have on your site that you want
Google to index and so that's the beauty
of search console now while we're in
search console we might as well take a
look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report okay so Google
is a staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so the beginning on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
Googled is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site fares
Via Mobile and when I say fares Via
Mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to Google
standards and so if there are any issues
Google's going to let you know what
those issues are so here I could see
Google's recognized 206 Pages before
different issues okay so here I can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here I can see for
206 Pages text too small to read click
elements to close together the viewport
not set to device with and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if I
actually click on it the error I can see
what those 10 pages are and so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
Google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
Google telling Google look I see what
the issues are I'm going to fix them and
then I want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with Google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
Google's attention Google's going to
validate them and get these Pages
indexed quicker so if you ignore the
issues then the errors especially for
mobile then you stand the chance of your
pages not getting indexed so the mobile
usability report to me is an important
report because we want to better
understand whether Google's picking up
issues on mobile and if they are we want
to address them get Google value them so
Google can index them quicker now
there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you in Google search console and that's
the links report so the links report and
Google search console shows us what
pages have the most links okay so here
we can see the home page is 26 000 plus
links if we hone in on interior Pages we
can see the links to those pages okay so
we can get a sense of what are the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on other websites pointing to
these pages I can also see internal
links so Google's recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another so external links internal links
both factors for SEO when ranking so
then I could see top linking sites what
sites are linking to my site and then I
can see top linking text so Google
search console has given me kind of an
overview of what my leaking structure
looks like okay so externally I want
links from other websites pointing to
various pages on my site and I certainly
want my pages linking to one another on
my site and so I'll be able to better
understand what that structure looks
like using Google search consoles links
report okay there's one more report that
I think's of interest in Google search
console and that's the performance
report so the performance report is a
report that actually you you can link up
with Google analytics so you can see the
same report and analytics if you're able
to link up Google search console with
analytics and you should be able to do
that all you need to do is make sure you
use the same email address that you use
for analytics and search console so it
needs to be the same email address you
could certainly link up the two and have
this data imported into Google analytics
so what is this data that we're talking
about well it's called performance so
what we can actually see is the queries
the actual queries people are typing in
to Google so when they're typing them
into Google we can actually see how many
Impressions the keyword queries received
and how many clicks the keyword queries
received and then I can see
click-through rate and average position
okay so here I can see for this
particular keyword on the first line I
could see over the course of the last
three months it received 209
297 Impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used or
typed in as a query at least that many
times and that's how many times my
listing appeared and the Google search
results Pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209 000 plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and Google
can obviously do this for you is you
would simply just divide the 209 297
into the 120 000 397. okay so that's
really going to give you that's going to
give you a click-through rate and the
click-through rate in this case is 57 so
over half of the clicks occur when this
listing appears for this keyword okay so
we can get a sense of the click the
array for each one okay and you could
simply just use the filtering here now
we can also see average position okay so
we could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to Pages we
can go from pages to countries so we get
a sense of how many Impressions and
clicks I'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
I can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now I
mentioned the beauty of the Google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to Google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
Google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so I could
see the same data that I see in search
console but this time I'm looking at it
in Google analytics and so here I can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my Impressions my clicked array bike
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when I
link up Google search console with
analytics I'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these SEO
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from site maps to keyword
research but we also want to hone in on
you know what domains are driving links
to our site so I showed you an example
in search console we also want to hey
maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and Impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
Google search console report but if you
have a platform like Moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a Moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see for the keywords that we've
chosen that we want to optimize for we
could certainly see where they rank the
great thing about Moz is it's a great
tool not only for rankings and on-page
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so if I go ahead
and take a look at a domain for example
example I'm just going to type in this
domain I'm going to be able to get what
they call a domain Authority so a score
out of 1 and 100 I'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
Moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links I have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if I click on the linking domains I'm
going to be actual able to see the
actual domains pointing to my site as an
external link and not only can I see the
domains I can actually see the domain
authority of those domains so if there's
a domain for example that doesn't have a
good domain Authority and the site
appears a bit scammy per se then we can
disavow that so I can certainly look
look at all the domains that are linking
to me and then I can highlight the ones
that have poor domain Authority what
must even takes it a step further they
also give me a Spam score so Moz is able
to measure how spammy a website is so if
I have a combination of say a low domain
Authority and a high spam score then I
probably want to disavow myself from
that site and so I can use this report
here you can see here as I keep going
down for example I can see this
particular website has a domain
authority of 26 and it has a Spam score
of 16 so not a good combination this
should alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that I
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
Authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is I'm
able to hone in on not only who's like
link linking to me meaning domain but
how many linking domains does that
domain have what's the spam score of
that domain what's the domain authority
of that domain and then I can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about backlinks domain Authority spam
Etc everything you need to use in order
to measure off page SEO so that's the
great thing about Moz is they have not
only on page SEO tools but off-page SEO
tools and Moz is a freemium so to speak
so here you can see if you just go to
mods.com free Dash seo-tools you'll be
able to use some of these tools
available to you not just for SEO but
also for local SEO as well so here you
like some of these tools you get start
your free 30-day trial so I use and lean
on Moz a lot for all that it has to
offer from choosing keywords to rankings
report to checking issues on my website
to even checking who's linking to me so
this fits in the mold with everything I
need to do for SEO so in addition to
that keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on SEO so
we've done a webinar on SEO tools and
we've also done a webinar on SEO tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or SEO in general take a look at those
two videos and check them out and that
should kind of complement what we've
talked about with using some of the
tools Google's Keyword Planner Moz and
Google search console okay let's switch
over to email marketing tools and so
with email marketing tool tools we have
a lot available to us in the form of
reporting in the form of Platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from A to Z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with MailChimp because mailchimps
a freemium version when we say freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know MailChimp to me is a tool I use I
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're going to take a look
at MailChimp but there are certainly
many others available you know more cat
is a good tool you know Marketo is a
good toll because if you have a business
and you're trying to funnel people
through your pipeline so to speak
meaning they they sign up as a lead and
you want to nurture that lead from the
beginning to the end meaning at the end
they're actually going to turn around
and purchase while Marketo is a good
tool for you to use because you can then
set up trip campaigns or also known as
email campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular Prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about Marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a HubSpot is a very powerful
tool it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to you
know emails so this is another freemium
tool that you could use you have another
freemium and send in blue email platform
and then you also have convertkit
another email platform there's more
Dimension that we can't even fit on this
screen now if you have a favorite email
marketing tool that you use Constant
Contact vertical response they're plenty
out there Emma you know feel free to to
note that in the comment section below
this video I'm curious as to how many
people actually use you know different
tools because there are so literally so
many email marketing tools out there why
because email marketing has been around
probably the longest amongst all the
other digital marketing channels and a
lot of people use email on a daily basis
so it's no wonder why there's just so
many tools available and so with these
tools you can certainly send bulk emails
now in the case of Marketo you can send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's a actually what you want to do as
a strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like I
mentioned with Marketo you want a
workflow set up where hey if somebody
does this you're sending email B Etc so
you want an email marketing tool that's
flexible enough to handle what your
business strategy and goals are okay so
you want to be able to also use a tool
that you know has various email
templates available okay you don't want
to be stuck with just a vanilla template
again you want to be able to customize
an email for your audience you want to
be able to manage your list
appropriately meaning if you have 10 000
users or emails in a list you want to be
able to manage them accordingly you know
break them up or or have sub lists so to
speak and then most importantly you want
to make sure you have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of recipients clicked on your email what
links do they click on you know which
which emails bounce so you want some
detailed insights right in the platform
that you're using it just makes it more
simpler and easier and more effective to
manage you certainly want to create that
smart automated campaigns meaning you
don't even have to send out the email
and then you want to be able to have
some flexibility to set up email
delivery based on a specific time of day
so these tools also allow you to your
segment contacts based on geolocation
you want to be able to use a tool that
allows for multivariate testing again
you want to analyze performance and
optimize campaigns you want to trigger
automatic responses somebody purchases
something are you using a tool that will
automatically send that email out so
these are all the reasons why you would
use an email marketing tool so let's
dive in and take a look at an example
and we're going to use MailChimp as our
example today so let's dive in and take
a look at MailChimp so with MailChimp
once you log in you know you're going to
be able to see some historical campaigns
that you sent out or are you going to be
able to create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on August 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to you know pick and
choose who we're sending this to who
it's from what the subject line is and
then we can certainly design the email
so if we click design email now again
this is important because with email
marketing you want to be able to cater
your email to your intended audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with intended audience and so
here you can see MailChimp allows us to
do that okay you can see some of the
layouts here okay you also have themes
that you could choose from okay you
could search for different themes or you
can even just code your own so you can
just paste an error code in or you can
import it so MailChimp allows that
flexibility you're not stuck with one of
their templates and so if we go back to
the dashboard the one thing I like about
MailChimp though is the reporting okay
so yes it is easy to choose a template
and map that template to your audience
but I really like make the reports that
they have to offer so you know here you
can see there's some lists that we've
sent to and we choose one of our
audience lists then we can see some
really detailed reporting here and so
here I could see this email that was
sent out in June I could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers I saw two thousand plus open
it and 157 clicks so I can view this
report in more detail just by clicking
on view report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so I
can get down really to the nitty-gritty
I can actually see you know on the
content what was clicked and what wasn't
clicked so here I sent two different
subject lines so I'm able to compare the
two against one another okay so I can
really go into detail about one of them
here so if I click view report I can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here I'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16 I
only had an open rate of 2.5 percent so
the industry average is 18 and so here
I'm able to see the list average for the
click rate and the industry average for
the click rate as well so then I can see
some specifics about it how many people
unsubscribed then I could see a graph I
could see the top links that were
clicked okay the top subscribers put the
most opens I can link social to it if I
want to and then I can see geographic
information so the point being is
MailChimp really goes into some nice
detail here about the email campaigns
and how they performed so the great
thing is too with the MailChimp you
could link it with a Google analytics
you can link it with e-commerce okay so
if you have an email and you're you're
selling products and somebody purchased
that product MailChimp is able to
integrate in with your shopping Commerce
platform for example woocommerce so if
somebody did purchase you can send out
that thank you email MailChimp even goes
a step further and if somebody did click
on a link go to your shopping cart add
something to the shopping cart and then
abandon the car you know MailChimp
allows you the opportunity to retarget
them via email so MailChimp is flexible
and that's what you want in a email
marketing platform you want something
that's flexible that you can cater to
your audience you can manage your
audience list and you can get detailed
reporting on your different campaigns
for that audience so that's MailChimp
and summary and so most email platforms
do a lot of similar features or have
some similar features but that's what
you ideally want to look for in an email
marketing platform so here's a tool that
doesn't get talked about enough when it
comes to email marketing and that's
Google's URL Builder and the reason why
we're going to talk about this tool
today is because most people in the US
use Google analytics as their web
Analytics tool and the one thing about
Google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
Google you can certainly track the
performance right in Google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using Google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
MailChimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call UTM
tracking so for example if I have a URL
that says visit Florida and I'm going to
send out an email I have up to five
parameters that I can use Okay so so
here's my email or URL that I'm using in
the email so I have up to five
parameters that I can use to track this
particular email so let's go through
some of those parameters so the first
one is campaign source so what's the
source of the campaign well we could
certainly identify MailChimp if we're
using MailChimp as the source now the
the thing about the URL Builders you
always want to use lowercase because
Google analytics is case sensitive so as
a rule of thumb just stick with a
lowercase so our source is going to be
MailChimp because that's the platform
we're using if you're using you know
Constant Contact or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit Florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to Florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice I got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so Google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email I would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do I say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say you have 10 000 recipient recipients
I want to be able to split out the email
into two segments one segment that's
going to get subject line one and one
segment that's going to get subject line
two so in this case I'm going to put
whatever subject line one is in the
campaign content field so now I have
four parameters and once I've entered in
my variables in this parameter Fields I
now have a revised or pended URL so my
original URL was visit florida.com
Florida Dash beaches.html my original
URL I've now appended that with some UTM
parameters and now I see my original URL
appended with the UTM parameters based
on those variables so I can copy it just
by clicking the copy URL I can go to my
browser I can paste that URL in there
and I want to check to see if it works
so here I could see this particular page
loaded Florida beaches with my etm
parameters appended to the URL so that's
for the first subject line that's for
the audience it's going to get the first
subject line I want to do another one
for the second subject line so now I'm
going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore 2.
I'm going to copy that URL I'm going to
check it okay so I could see that the
page loads with those U10 parameters and
so now what am I going to do I'm going
to use the first URL and the second URL
in my email okay so any link that I have
in this case I'm using subject line two
so for the email with the second subject
line going to that segmented audience
this is the link I'm going to use in the
email so if you have one or two or three
links in the email this is the URL
you're going to use because when
somebody clicks on that link you're
going to be able to see that that click
in Google analytics so if I jump over to
Google analytics after I send out my
email I'm going to go to acquisition I'm
going to go to campaigns I'm going to go
to all campaigns now based on the
variables I put into my parameters
meaning Source medium campaign name
content or term that's what I'm going to
look for in Google analytics so we can
start with source and medium so if I
click on source and medium as my primary
Dimension here I can see MailChimp and
the actual dates was used as part of the
variable for for source and then what
can I see the medium being email so now
I can see for this email that was sent
out in MailChimp in May I could see how
many users how many sessions and more
importantly how many conver versions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here I could see the
campaign name okay so I could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email drove in traffic and conversions
and if I'm doing subject line testing I
can choose content as my parameter so
here I'm going to change it to content
and now I can see the subject lines in
this case if I go back to my source
medium I'm going to be able to see what
subject lines from my emails generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the URL
Builder again you're taking a URL that
you're going to use an email and then
you're going to pan that URL with
different parameters campaign so Source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get it appended URL which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go back over to
Google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that Medium of that
content I.E subject line and so that's
why the URL Builder is so important
because MailChimp gives us some good
insight as to how the email performed in
terms of open and click rates but what
we really want to see is how that
campaign performed once it drove traffic
to my website so that's the whole idea
behind the URL Builder if you're using
Google analytics you'll be able to use
the URL Builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
tools kind of the central focal point of
all digital marketing and it starts
really with Google analytics Google
analytics is a freemium meaning that
they have a free version that you can
use there is also a paid version of
Google analytics but given the Advent of
Google it's popular especially in the
United States a majority of users are
using the free version of Google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just Google so we have Adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
YouTube analytics which is part of
Google but YouTube has its own separate
analytics insights so a lot of these as
you can see are free to use they're
available no reason why you should not
be using uh an Analytics tool to measure
your marketing campaigns or website
behavior and why would we want to use
these tools again well again we want to
really measure Behavior we want to
measure what's going on with our website
so we want to be able to identify the
location of where our website visitors
are coming from and a lot of these
analytics tools use IP address to
identify the location of a website
visitor so if you're trying to Target a
specific country then you want to be
able to see that the visitors to your
website are coming from that specific
country or location we also want to
measure the engagement of our website
Behavior so we get traffic to the
website what are they doing how long are
they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use is web
analytics to measure how successful our
website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want them to find what they're looking
for quickly you want them to be happy
with their experience you certainly want
them to pay for the products very
quickly and easily and efficiently and
you want them to come back and that's no
different than a website so we want our
website to perform in a manner that's
going to suit our audience and that's
why we want to track engagement so why
else well we want to really look at
who's coming are they returning visitors
or new visitors you know ideally you
want a nice mix between 50 new and 50
returning because you know returning
visitors are loyal there's some loyalty
to that they already know your brand
they're coming back to your website new
visitors are curious and you want new
visitors because that means more traffic
so you want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
Google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing UTM
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non-google campaigns you
want to use UTM tracking and Google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically Google analytics will help
you see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with UTM tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web Analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do I.E are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you could turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into Google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with UTM tracking all those
good things that we can can get and a
good Analytics tool so Adobe mix panel
spring metrics you know they all work in
a similar fashion and that they're
really measuring website behavior and so
if we're in Google analytics really what
we're doing is we're measuring the
performance of our website broken down
into four components audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and Google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
Rob Sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
San Francisco California came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device
and they're a returning users so they're
painting a picture for you okay so
they're not giving you a list of names
that would not be legal but they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when I say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and I
got a demographics overview here's a
picture I'm painting well I could see
that 25 to 34 year olds are the majority
of the age group that is coming to my
website okay I can see on the gender
side of it I can see that 63 percent of
my traffic and again this is year to
date that I'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so I'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well I can
also look at Geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
I go to location under Geo I'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
I can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here I could see
United States is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the US and then 16 from
Argentina 13 from Mexico 10 percent from
India so we have a nice mix of traffic
from different locations in the world
coming to our website so that's Geo but
more importantly let's take a look at
mobile so if we go to mobile overview
how are people coming to our website are
they on a desktop or laptop are they
using their mobile device are they using
a tablet and so Google analytics breaks
it down very nice for you and so we
could see percentages in actual numbers
by device category and so in this case I
could see year to date I can see 62
percent are coming from desktop 30 35
percent are coming from mobile and so
that's important because most people
start their Journey from mobile and that
is growing and that's going to continue
to grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from Mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in Google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to acquisition so
acquisition reporting tell tells us how
the traffic was driven to the website so
if audience tells us who is coming to
the website acquisition tells us how
that traffic got to the website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and I'm a Believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines or indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents the
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by Channel if I go to all
traffic channels report I can see in my
Dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic and this is
year to date then I can see paid search
then I can see direct which means
Somebody went directly to the site I
could see referral email social then I
could see more paid search broken out so
these are the different marketing
channels now analytics allows you to
look at a specific source and medium so
the source would be the actual website
or search engine in the medium would
differentiate how that traffic actually
got to the site so if we're talking
about a search engine did they come to
the site via paid search or do they come
to the site via organic search and so
all we need to do is change our primary
Dimension from default Channel grouping
to source and medium and we could see
specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here I can see
Google organic it's 71 percent and and
then Google CPC or cost per click at 15
16 of our traffic so then I can look
down I can see email in here being
organic I could see some referring sites
I could see some social in terms of
mobile Facebook okay so we can see a mix
of the different sources of mediums
driving traffic to the site okay so you
don't always have to look at Channel per
se you can look at it via source and
medium and if you're running Google ads
under acquisition analytics has a whole
section of Google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on Google ads
remember we looked at the Keyword
Planner in Google ads so if you're
running campaigns on Google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see campaigns other
campaigns that we're running so remember
that UTM tracking that we set up for
email well we want to be able to track
the performance of email and any other
non-google campaign with UTM tracking so
when we do that we'll be able to go to
campaigns all campaigns and we'll be
able to see the campaign performance if
we look at source and medium we'll be
able to see what campaigns drove traffic
to the website so here I can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search
consoles so we looked at search console
earlier we talked about SEO tools well
remember I said you can link up search
console with Google analytics well
here's search console and we could see
queries devices landing pages countries
so all the performance metrics that we
could see in search console because we
have it linked up with analytics we can
see it right here so this gives us a
nice snapshot of what what keywords are
driving traffic to the site organically
I could see The Impressions I could see
the clicks then I could see the clicked
array and then the average position so
in theory the higher something ranks the
more traffic you're going to get so
that's the idea behind it we want to
make sure that we're ranking for our
coveted keywords and if we are we want
to be able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clicked so that's the great thing
about you know Google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
Google search console and Google ads you
can connect them directly to Google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in Behavior we have
a number of different reports so
Behavior tells us what's the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so really what I would
do do is from there go to site content
all pages and so this gives us an idea
of how many pages were actually viewed
so site content all pages tells us what
page and how many times it was viewed
during a period of time and again we're
looking at year to date so I can see
engagement related metrics associated
with a page so this particular page here
on line one I could see how many pages
unique Pages which is equal to sessions
so I can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session I could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and I can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so I can
also see percentage of exits meaning
what page did people exit the site for
from so these are all engagement related
metrics so here is where I want to react
and optimize my website performance so I
if I see a page now performing well
meaning it has a high bounce rate or
maybe low time on page then I'm probably
going to optimize it meaning test it or
change it to improve performance so
these are all pages but I could
certainly look at landing pages okay so
landing pages tells us the behavior of
the page when somebody landed on it so a
landing page means that somebody came
from organic search or paid search or
another Channel landed on this page so
here I could see this particular page on
line one had
4970 sessions okay and I can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of Bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under Behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how fast or how slow our Pages load so
this is important from an SEO
perspective because if a page isn't
loading very fast then chances of it
getting ranked in Google are not very
good so Google's organic search
basically takes page load time seriously
so if a page doesn't load very fast then
we need to be able to fix it so we can
go to page timings I can get a good
sense of the average page load time of a
particular page and what Google does
here is under speed suggestions they
actually will give me some ideas and
speed suggestions on how to address a
page that's loading very slow and so
when we load up the speech suggestions
report what Google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here I can see if I
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that I can
address when trying to improve the page
load time of that particular page so
here I could see there's some server
response time issues image sizes
probably need to be resized I can remove
unused CSS okay so there are a lot of
different things I can do to improve the
page load time on this particular page
okay this is for desktop I can also see
mobile so mobile a lot of the same
issues so if we address these these
opportunities then we could see a lift
in page load time we see lift and Page
load time we're going to probably see a
lift in organic rankings or even user
engagement because if a page takes a
long time to load a user is probably not
going to stay on that page very long so
to me site speed is an important report
under Behavior now one more report here
that I want to point out under behavior
is events and to me events are important
so if you're trying to measure
engagement on your website you need to
make sure you have event tracking set up
and when we talk about event tracking
we're talking about measuring things
that analytics doesn't measure by
default so if you have a button on your
website if you have a PDF download if
you have a submit button on a phone form
submission if you have a subscribe
button if you have a video if you have
an external link anything that is going
to trigger engagement on your website
you need to measure with event tracking
and event tracking is simply set up by
breaking out the event into a category
and action and a label and so here we
could see for our particular website we
have categories already set up for event
tracking so here for example I can say
on line six video I could see how many
people actually watched our video okay
so here's the action video Start okay so
over this period of time I could see I
had 49 unique events 50 total so that's
how many people actually watched the
video and you can always report to label
and that'll tell you what page people
watched in this case the video so event
tracking is important because we want to
be able to measure engagement so if we
go to events under behavior and you
don't see any events listed you probably
need to get that set up and that is set
up through Google tag manager so what
you want to do is you want to be able to
set up your events through Google tag
manager which is another Google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you set up your events when
you set up your events for your website
with a category in action and label
you'll be able to measure those events
and analytics under Behavior under
events and the important thing here is
you'll be able to measure engagement so
I'll be able to see how many people came
to the site and how many people clicked
on a button downloaded a PDF submitted a
form played a video did whatever we
wanted them to do so events are
important so let's move from the
Behavior to conversions and this is
important because we want to be able to
measure conversions on a website so
analytics has four types of conversions
so if I go to admin down at the bottom
and then I go to goals I could see that
I have four different types of goals
that I can use now right now I have
event related goals set up for the
website for this particular website so
we just talked about event tracking so
if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if I
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it I can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here I could see if
somebody goes to donation Dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like Channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least one minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if I look
at this example here if a user came to
my website and looked at more than three
pages in that particular session then
analytics is going to fire a goal
conversion so four types of goals you
don't have to set up all four different
types my recommendation is at least have
one goal set up if you're not sure what
goal to set up then at least set up a
duration or pages per session okay so at
least you can measure how long somebody
stays on your website or how many pages
they went to okay so when you actually
do have these goals set up you can go
back into conversions we can go back
into goals we can go back into overview
and we can measure our goal completions
over this period of time so here I could
see 313 goal completions total with a
goal conversion rate of 1.88 and then I
could see it broken down by goal type so
remember the only goals I have available
and set up all are event related goals
so 69 newsletter signups 156 donate
click buttons I have 32 contact form
submissions 37 email click completions
and then 11 phone number click
completions so I can measure engagement
as a goal and so goals generally are
important to the business so you want to
make sure that if you have a goal for
your website then you want to be able to
set that up as a goal in Google
analytics so that way when you're
looking at example channels if I go back
to my channels report I can then measure
Channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if I want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the Donate Now button
I could see that I could see
year-to-date 10
887 users which meant 11 1000 sessions
76 clicked on that donate Now button and
that comes out to 0.65 conversion rate
okay so that's important so you want to
be able to measure any Dimension whether
that be Channel Source medium keyword
campaign mobile device could be
demographic gender or age you want to be
able to measure any Dimension against
the goals you have set up so you can
measure performance and that also
includes Pages or landing pages as well
so that's a quick overview of what you
can expect to see in Google analytics
again audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so a lot of data in Google
analytics but you want to be able to
take advantage of the data in order to
improve website performance now let's
jump over to YouTube analytics because
if you have videos on YouTube If you you
have a channel set up some playlists
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your video is
performing and so here I could see I'm
in YouTube all I did was I went to my
account then I went to the beta the
studio version of YouTube and then from
there I went to analytics so my account
YouTube Studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
I could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
000 and I've netted 48 subscribers and
this is an overall okay so I can
actually see when I publish videos and I
can see the date they were published and
here I'm looking at you know total views
over this particular date range I can
also see specifics on a particular video
so I could see the top video in terms of
minutes here I could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here I could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview I could certainly look at some
other information if I click on reach
viewers I could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here I
could see the different traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here I could
see 25 came within YouTube itself I
could see how many times the video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested video so I could see different
ways in which the traffic found my video
and actually watched it here I could see
externally how people were able to find
my video us and I could see 46 percent
found it via Google search see some lots
of information here about sources of
traffic how the traffic got to these
videos so I could see then once the
traffic found my videos how many times
they actually saw it and viewed it and
then watched it so that's how many times
I was able to reach viewers via
different sources and then their
reaction to that how many times they saw
it and watched it here I can click on
interest viewers so again I could see
the top videos in terms of watch time I
could see the top playlist so here I
could see my partners playlist was the
top playlist so I could see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
YouTube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here I get see 88 of
the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them if they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in YouTube itself about how our video is
performed again this is good Insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if I just click on one particular
video I can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself I could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via YouTube search I could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it I could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or an
overview of my channel so that's all all
available to you in YouTube analytics
under YouTube studio so take advantage
of us if you're publishing videos on a
regular basis you want to hone in on how
your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
YouTube analytics or YouTube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
YouTube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into YouTube itself especially
YouTube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about YouTube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition's
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like Sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool all social
blade there's a popular tool out there
called spyfu that's freemium as well Moz
we looked at Moz earlier for keyword
organic Moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
Freeview tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simply learn I use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition's doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in the ranking so the reason why
we have this is the top bullet point is
because SEO organic search is a
long-term strategy on page off page
website very tactical and creative
there's a lot going on with SEO a lot
going on and sometimes it takes a long
time to rank for something and a lot of
SEO does depend on relevancy relevancy
being how many quality backlinks are
linked to you so it's always good to
leverage what your competitors are doing
so you can see how you stack up and so
that's why this is up there as number
one we want to be able to really take a
look at what our competitors are doing
another example would be hey how much a
traffic a competitors gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competitions doing
okay we can also identify our
competitors top performing content for
Relevant topics and we can determine
what our competitors website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our computer
editor's data and compare it with their
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ahead
and take a look at a few examples how we
can leverage all these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with Sprout social
and Sprout social is a tool I use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do with Sprout social
definitely generate reports for your
social media platforms you could set up
post that get published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example RV rentals in Twitter so
what we're doing is we're actually
listening to see who else is tweeting
about RV rentals so we could do this for
Twitter we could do it Facebook some
other social media platforms the whole
idea here on Sprout social is to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
so we could have easily put in a brand
name we're just going General here
because we want to rank for the keyword
RV rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go RV
rentals Cruise America RV we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword RV rentals now if I
want to hone in on a particular
competitor I could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so RV share so here I can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay I can get a sense of
everything about out this tweet and so
here I can scroll down and I can see
what's been shared by other people for
this particular brand and I can see a
lot of people are as an example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so to me it just gives me a sense in
this particular example on Twitter as to
what our competitors doing okay let's
start our attention to SEO so remember
that first bullet point we want to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
when it comes to backlinks and so Moz
has a great tool called link Explorer
and Link Explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain I can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of you know how
many links my competitors have external
Intel internal I can get a sense of the
domain Authority I can get a sense of
page Authority linking domains so I can
really do a uh comparison across my
domain and my competitors domains to get
a snapshot of how I compare against my
competitors so this gives me an overview
of everything I need to know organically
now Moz also has a another great tool
under link Explorer called link
intersect and I like link intersect I
use it a lot because if our competitors
really have a number of external links
and domains pointing to their site and
they have a better domain Authority and
Page Authority then you know I want to
be able to you know see what they're
doing where they're linking who's
linking to them I want to get be able to
get a snapshot of why is their domain so
much better than ours in terms of
authority and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so I can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then I can find
Opportunities and so you just click on
opportunities and you can see where my
site intersects with their site and if
it doesn't actually intersect then I
have an opportunity to actually try and
get a link on that particular site so
that's what the link intersect report
does it allows me to see where my links
intersect with my competitors and if it
doesn't intersect then I have an
opportunity to generate a backlink so
that's ideally what the link intersect
tool is in mods it allows me to really
get a sense of you know where I'm
linking and where my competitors linking
now what we can also do is also take
advantage of another report under moz's
link Explorer and the discovered and
lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so really within mods
we can get a good snapshot of what
websites are linking to our competitors
we get a good snapshot of the overall
links to our competitor sites and
specifically what sites so the whole
idea is if it's good for our competitors
meaning they're linking from a site that
has good domain Authority and low spam
score then it's probably a site I want
to be able to tackle as well okay so you
have discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in moz's
link Explorer tool now there's one more
report we can leverage in Moz and that's
the inbound links report and so we can
go ahead and type in our competitors
domain here and again we can get a
snapshot of what their domain Authority
is Page Authority for the home page but
really this is what we're after linking
domains so this particular domain has
over 9 000 linking domains so what we
can do is actually go through and see
based on domain Authority I could sort
by domain Authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here I can
see Reddit
so a lot of Reddit here which is a good
site for backlinking New York Times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here Washington Post so I can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course I don't want to go
through 9 000 links I can really just
hone in on a specific link Source or
link type or link state so I can really
filter it if I wanted to I can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as I
could see what URL is linking to this
particular competitor site what the
anchor text is with the page and domain
Authority is so this gives me a really
really good Insight on all the
backlinking that my competitor has and
again if I'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on Reddit
then we probably need to be on Reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from Reddit which has a domain authority
of 90. then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so inbound links is just another
good report you can leverage in Moz
under the link Explorer reporting tool
now if I want to get a good snapshot as
to what my competitors doing on search
exactly well look no further than spy
Foose so spyfu is a another tool that
you can leverage from a PPC SEO
perspective you know from an SEO
perspective you got some backlinking
data as well just like you did in Moz
from a PPC perspective you can get some
good keyword insights and so here I just
went ahead and typed in the domain and
what this is going to do is just give me
an overall snapshot but for my
competitor's domain so here I could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the estimated monthly
SEO clicks they're getting based on the
volume of those keywords okay I could
see here the keywords their top
competitors also rank for the rank
history 12 years this particular
domain's been around a long time okay so
that's on the organic side I can flip
over to the paid side and I could see
that they are doing paid search I could
see 5000 plus keywords they're bidding
on okay based on that what they're
actually paying and then I could see you
know some of the other competitors
listed here from a paid perspective and
an organic perspective I could see the
shared keyword overlap okay now again
you can pay for this because it's
freemium and get some really good
insights as to how your domain compares
to your competitors so I'm using the
free version and here the free version
spy Fusion just giving me some overall
data on the specific domain I entered in
and so I entered in my competitors you
can certainly enter in your own domain
to get a sense of organic keywords and
paid keywords so you can see top
keywords top paid keywords okay this is
Google ads okay so this is what
recommendations as to what to purchase
okay here you can see some even some at
Google ads history I could see exactly
what ad copy my competitor actually
wrote and for what keyword and then I
could see some organic ranking history
here as I keep scrolling down this
overview report so I can see for RV rent
where they rank and then I can see
inbound links just like I did in Moz spy
Foos providing me with some insight as
to hey what links are pointing to them
and what the domain strength is and how
many clicks they expect to receive so
this is all free data take it or leave
it but it's all free data available to
you under spyfish spy view gives you
kind of an overview for free some really
in-depth analysis if you actually pay
for it and it just really hones in on
what your competitors are bidding for
paid wise and what they're ranking for
organic wise and so spy food is a really
good tool to leverage if you just want
to get a snapshot of how your competitor
uh overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to Google analytics because in
Google analytics under audience I can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all Anonymous data so I can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if I hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and I hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that I get then I can see hey
analytics in this case in this example
I'm sharing
8863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and I can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how I stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our Locale and if we do that
Google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment it we're
going to be able to see in this case
just New Zealand so we're going to
adjust for New Zealand and we're gonna
go with the
4999 and so we could see there are about
you know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so for
focused on the New Zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
Anonymous web properties so now if I go
back to the report after I've honed in
I'm looking at channels and I can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how I compare against the
competition I can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate so that's just
channels I can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your your industry so you're
getting a good idea as to how you
compare against your industry just by
making some adjustments in the
benchmarking report you obviously want
to make sure you're looking at the same
industry adjust for your country or
region adjust for the site size meaning
how many sessions you actually get on a
daily basis and then analytics will do
the rest they'll compare you against
those in your industry and so I find
this to be a good tool because it allows
me to stack up our site against those in
the industry and obviously if we're not
driving as many sessions especially say
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmarking report now if
you want to get some good insight as to
what the competitors are doing and you
don't want to use a tool well look no
further you can always go to google.com
Okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a key
word and we're going to type in RV
rentals and now we're going to be able
to see who's bidding on that keyword so
we could see we have a number of
different uh companies bidding on the
keyword we're interested in okay here I
can see some featured Snippets okay and
then I could see some organic search
results okay if I scroll down I'll be
able to see some other companies bidding
on that same keyword meaning they are
paying for RV rentals so if I clicked on
somebody's link here they're actually
going to pay Google for the click and so
this just gives me a good sense of you
know how many people are actually trying
to rank for this keyword or trying to be
found for this keyword so that's all I
did I just did a search now from an
organic perspective if you really want
to hone in on your competition you can
always do the syntax all in title colon
and then hit enter so now I could see I
have 163
000 results and when does that tell me
that tells me that I have a 163
000 websites with RV rentals in the
title tag so if you're trying to
optimize for the keyword RV rentals as
an example then you know that you have a
000 different listings ahead of you that
you need to jump over in order to rank
for the keyword RV rentals so using the
All entitled syntax and the keyword
right after that actually just gives you
a more accurate picture of how many
sites are actually ahead of you for a
particular keywords so that's the whole
idea so if I get rid of the syntax and
you can see for RV rentals I have 132
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
keyword RV rentals in the title Tag and
Title tag if you're working on organic
search is one of the key important
factors for ranking so you need to have
that keyword in the title tag so that's
the whole idea behind you using the All
entitled syntax it gives us a good idea
as to what our competition is doing and
how many sides we have to jump over to
get to number one on Google Now if
you're running Google ads just as we did
with RV rentals we went up there and we
saw we typed that in as a query and we
saw how many advertisers there were for
RV rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns Google ads actually has a good
report that I really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and when auction
insights allows us to see is what
competitors or domains are bidding on
the same keywords we are and so what
Google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here I'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and I can see our competitors okay so I
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one key word every
keyword has a hundred percent impression
share how much of that impression share
are you getting and when we say
impression share meaning eyeballs when
we talk about eyeballs are we getting a
majority of the eyeballs or our
competitors get a majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position I can see how often I overlap
with my competitors okay I could see how
often I'm above a particular competitor
I could see what percentage I'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then I
can see how often I outrank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so I can see all
this good insight as to what competitors
are bidding on the same keywords I am
okay so this is if you're running Google
ads okay so if you're running Google ads
okay you can just click on the auction
insights report you can find them at the
top navigation just by clicking on
campaigns and by doing so you'll be able
to gain some insights as to where you
stack up from a paid search perspective
against your competitors so let's turn
our attention to paid marketing tools so
if you're doing some advertising on
Google Bing LinkedIn you probably want
to work within those platforms as the
tool of choice so you know if you're
doing paid search on say
googlesearch.com or display you could be
doing display advertising on you know a
network like adroll or Google or you
could be doing social media paid ads say
on Facebook so whatever it is you're
doing you probably want to work within
that platform itself to get the ideal
data that you need okay so here are some
of the tools some of the places you can
go of course if you're working Google
ads you also have Google ads ads editor
that you can leverage okay and I'll show
you that in a couple minutes you have
Google ads Keyword Planner of course
both of these are paid if you're running
campaigns okay so Bing if you're running
campaigns on Bing okay you get all this
good data that you can digest through
some reporting okay you also have some
third-party tools out there that you
also have to pay for and word stream
okay so word stream is a third party
tool that you can leverage Bing and
Google are actual advertising Network so
you would advertise on the platform
itself and get all the data you need
right in the platform and leverage a lot
of the tools that they have available in
the platform as I mentioned you could
also use Google ads editor so Bing also
has their own editor as well so and as
well as Facebook so you can use an
editor type version and I'll show you
that here in a couple minutes but let's
talk about why why we want to use the
tools in the platform itself well we
want to be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting are they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that because if we want to monitor
our cost okay across different locations
and devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to measure
by device okay so we also want to
analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitor section
Google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so Google it's self does
provide some information in the case of
auction insights as to how your
competitors are performing against you
on Google search so that's on the paid
search side then you have display okay
so display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example Admiral okayo seltra is
another paid version of or pay tool you
can use in wide orbit so these are some
of the paid marketing tools you can
leverage of course I like to stay if I'm
advertising on Google I like to stay on
and Google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage ad roles reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and AD performance so
same kind of concept here we want to be
able to monitor whether we have the
right keywords and write customer
engagement so when when it comes to
display we want to be able to make sure
we're choosing the right audience of
course that means looking at not only
audience insights but our Target
insights as well are we reaching the
Right audience when it comes to display
and Google has a good breakdown that I'm
going to be able to show you here in a
couple minutes okay so we want to
improve our campaigns by monitoring our
competitors display ads as well so there
are tools available that'll help you do
that and that's on the display side if
we look at Social okay why what tools
can we use on social well you got
Facebook ads manager okay you got ad
espresso quiet tweepy you get all these
cool paid search tools again I usually
stick with where I'm advertising so if
I'm advertising on LinkedIn or Twitter
I'm going to leverage that platform but
just know that there are other tools
available for you so a social like
display it's all about targeting our
audience so for these some of the tools
like on Facebook we can review and
relaunch or ad campaigns based on target
audience we can measure conversions and
gain insights in this example about
Facebook users how are our users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to Target People based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel preferences Etc so
social allows us to do that and then
with Facebook as an example we can
monitor any a B test we run for example
if we're running call to action tests we
can measure the results that right in
Facebook and I'm going to show you an
example of that here shortly so let's
jump right into Google ads and look at
some tools available to us from the
search side of the house so for running
search campaigns right in Google ads we
could see campaign data we could see
keyword data we could see add data so
for example if I want to see what ads
are performing I'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now I could see what ads
are performing in terms of clicks
click-through rates
Etc and so that way I can go ahead and
pause ads activate ads so that's right
here in the Google ads platform itself
now if I want to look at specific
keywords I can do that so I can see what
keywords are driving traffic and clicks
here I can just sort by clicks and now I
can see not only what keywords are
driving clicks I could see what the
click-through rate is I can see the
Impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that I'm betting on I
could see how much I've paid made by
keyword and more importantly I want to
be able to see conversions or conversion
rate and then with Google ads you have
qualities for so we want to be able to
measure quality score so this is a
Google ads keyword reporting and so the
great thing about the keyword reporting
is that there's some other features
available to me here so here I can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords I can also see a
Search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms I can actually see what
specific keywords people typed in and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query I can see what match type
triggered that particular ad and so if I
see a keyword query that I don't
particularly care to be shown for or I
want my ad shown for then I can go ahead
and just select it and I can add it as a
negative key word okay so that tool is
available to you right in Google ads
okay and then you have the auction
Insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see basically you know who
else is bidding on the keywords and what
the impression share is what their
average position is what their overlap
rate is position above right top of page
absolute top of page right now rankings
here so once we have Google has data
then they'll be able to share that
information with you okay so that's just
key words but there's a cool tool that I
really like and I leverage it for SEO
and pay-per-click and that's Google's
Keyword Planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on Keyword Planner
we'll be able to Leverage The Keyword
Planner and the whole idea behind the
Keyword Planner is do we want to
discover new keywords or for the
keywords we have selected we can get
volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if I click get started okay so
Google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much I
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
I happen to click on that keyword I can
add it to a plan and then once I've
added to a plan then I can go ahead and
look at that plan and measure what kind
of volume I'm going to get and how much
I can expect to pay so now once I've
added my keyword to that plan I can go
ahead and see how many clicks and
Impressions and costs and click the rate
and average cost per click I can expect
to spend so and this is based on a
maximum CPC of dollars so I can go ahead
and adjust my plan accordingly if I want
to in order to see basically how much I
can expect to spend so that's the whole
idea behind the Keyword Planner in terms
of choosing new keywords and once you
choose keywords you're interested in
bidding on you can actually do a
forecast to see exactly how much you can
expect to spend how many clicks how many
Impressions you can expect to get and if
you have conversion set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of Google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so there are so many
different tools and features within
Google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so really I'm just going to
highlight some of the more important
tools and features so I mentioned the
Keyword Planner I imagine the campaigns
keywords and ads reports another thing I
would look at in Google ads again and we
mentioned this as one of our key
defining why would we use it bullet
point and that's because of devices so
we mentioned devices why would we use
Google ads reporting tool because we
want to look at devices and we want to
be able to see what devices are driving
traffic from what campaign and then the
cool thing about Google ads is right in
Google ads platform you can go ahead and
do a bit adjustment so if I increase my
bid adjustment for example on mobile
phones then my particular ad in this
particular campaign is going to show
more than on computer so I can always
decrease it for example do a bit
adjustment on computer and that means
I'm going to show my ads less so I can
go ahead and do bid adjustments based on
device that's the cool thing of working
writing Google ads platform is you can
make adjustments right here in the
platform based on devices well you also
have local locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and if I see
a particular location I'm not interested
in advertising well I can always select
it and I can always just pause it or
remove it so or I can change the bit
adjustment on a location as well so I
can make a lot of different changes
right in the Google ads platform for
those seasoned and search advertising
paid search advertising especially on
Google ads you can always use Google ads
editor all you need to do is just do a
search for Google ads editor you can
download it so basically what Google ads
editor is it's a it's a tool it's the
software that you work your can with
your campaigns on locally so you're
making changes to your campaigns on your
computer and basically when you're done
making changes you can always upload
them to Google ads to the account on
Google ads in the cloud so to speak so
that's the whole idea behind Google ads
editor it's a great tool for you to use
if you want to make household changes
really quick for example I'm looking at
an account with a bunch of campaigns so
now if I click on one of those campaigns
I can see the ad groups here okay so for
example I just wanted to turn off all
these ad groups I can just highlight
them all and just click status enable to
paused and I can revert back if I want
to okay so you can make household
changes so here I could see the campaign
the ad group level if I choose an ad
group then I can see some keywords and
again I can make changes at nauseum here
I can copy I can paste I can delete okay
so I can make a lot of changes really
quick write in Google ads editor and
that's the whole point of editor is to
go ahead and work locally while somebody
else is working locally on the same
account you could both be working
simultaneously and being more efficient
on getting things done in the campaign
now if you are working with somebody
else on the campaign you want to make
sure that you get recent changes so if I
say get recent changes to all campaigns
what Google editor is going to do is
contact Google ads in the cloud and
download all those changes so here I
could see the changes being download and
editor from Google ads and when it's
done it's going to highlight all the
changes that have been made and so once
I'm done reviewing those changes I can
go ahead and click done and now I know I
have the recent latest changes in editor
so now I can go ahead and continue to
make some changes and when I'm done
making changes I can go ahead and post
them so that's the beauty of Google ads
editor Bing has a version Facebook has a
version it allows you to again go with
the keyword level the ad group level
okay you can look at ads itself and make
changes to the ads okay you could do a
lot of different things write an editor
in fact you could do pretty much most of
what you could do in Google ads you
could do in Google ads editor and so
that's Google ads Editor to me I would
recommend it if you're experienced with
Google ads again it's software you have
to download it you're going to use it on
your computer as software but when you
make changes all you need to do is post
those changes or get recent changes that
have been made on Google ads and so
that's Google editor ads editor and
summary now let's go back into Google
ads and talk about display advertising
because display is a different network
but the platform's still the same and
some of the same tools are available
from the search Network as well as for
the Display Network right in Google ads
so if I want to take a look at a
campaign and AD group on the Display
Network I could just click on that ad
group and I can look at the ads that are
running for that particular regular Eye
Group on the Display Network so here the
difference being on the display network
is you can use image ads on the search
Network you can only use text ads so
here I can look at image ads and I could
see how they're performing in fact you
could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so Google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now I can see clicks
Impressions click-through rate Etc right
on on my ads and extensions report in
Google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so we want to be
able to see okay of the audiences we
have set up up what audience is
performing best okay so here I can see a
Breakout by audience again I could see
the same metrics I could see on the
search side I could see clicks
Impressions click the rate more
importantly I want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword
add whatever the dimension is so here on
the Display Network we can get a sense
of demographics okay so unlike the
search Network the Display Network
allows us to see demographic data and so
now I could see an age breakout or an
age range breakout that Google provides
us and I could see again based on the
age range breakout which age range has
the most clicks Impressions
Etc including conversions so you also
have the opportunity on the display and
I worked at keywords you have the
opportunity to add topics and you have
the opportunity to see placements or run
placements so here if I click on where
ADS have shown I can actually see where
my ads have shown up for this display
campaign and Google ads allows you the
ability to go ahead and you can exclude
it from the ad group exclude a specific
placement from a campaign so you could
take action on a specific placement and
I could see the type of placement
whether it's a mobile app whether it's a
site I can go ahead and see exactly
where that placement was so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the Google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media media paid search
advertising I just want to remind you we
do have you know a nice tutorial on
Google ads okay so take a look at the
Google ads tutorial we have set up on
YouTube okay if you search for Google
ads tutorial 2019 this is a good uh
tutorial on everything related to Google
ads so check out this video because in
today's webinar we're just mentioning
tools across the board and if you are
advertising on Google ads as most people
do then you can see just how powerful it
is and all the different features that
are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complimentary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on Google ads and if you have any tools
or features on Google ads whether it's
the search Network or whether that's the
Display Network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in Google ads so let's move into uh
Facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on Facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we could see if
we're in the Facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we could see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on Google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if I click on one of these ad
sets I'll be able to see an actual ad
that's running here and so for the
actual ad that's running I can then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so Impressions
similar to Google ads how many people
are actually looking at the ad and I can
see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so now I can go
in and I can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to my
expectation so if I click on more tools
and then creatives I can just simply
click on creators and then I can
actually see the creators I actually
have running for that campaign I
selected so now I can see all the
creatives that are running and I can see
the results of those creatives so
Facebook ads manager also has a
different reporting so if I click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
I could see some standard reports by add
ad set age and gender and then I can see
all reports here listed out by placement
by placement and device time of day
country Etc so if we just look at age
and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so you can
see by campaign I'm looking at all
campaigns here and I'm looking at just
age and gender I can certainly deselect
one of these and I can look at a
specific time range so now I could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here I could see 35 to 44 female I can
see the reach Impressions and how often
they're actually seeing my ad now this
is key for Facebook because if
somebody's seen your ad a lot they're
probably going to tune out to it so
that's what makes the frequency metrics
so important on Facebook because then we
can go ahead and you know turn off that
particular age and gender if we needed
to and we could see how much we spent so
this just gives you some idea of the
type of reporting that's available in
Facebook ads manager now the great thing
about Facebook uh reporting and ads
manager is you know I can group or
ungroup uh my Dimensions if I needed to
I could change the view and arrange
columns I can get rid of columns just as
you would in Google ads reporting very
similar stature here so I have a lot of
flexibility here on how I review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you could pick and choose
as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here I can
pick and choose I can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again I can choose
different demographics so I have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how I want to you know view the
performance of my campaign view the
performance of my ad set or my ad now
remember if you're in Facebook you can
always go in and edit the campaign you
can edit the ad set remember in the ad
set that's where a lot of your decisions
are going to be made including how you
want to drive the traffic okay what your
budget is okay you can basically choose
your audience here so you're going to be
able to choose what type of campaign
it's going to be and based on the
campaign you're going to go ahead and
choose the kind of audience you want to
focus in on you're going to be able to
choose the location the age range the
gender so all of this is going to be set
up in the ad set or the campaign or the
ad if you go ahead and edit an ad
remember you can do a b testing as well
so you have a lot of different options
and features available to you writing
ads manager when you're managing your
paid search campaigns on Facebook so if
you want some more information about all
the different features and tools and
Facebook ads manager check out the
Facebook ads tutorial 2019 a webinar
that we did earlier this year in
addition you can also look at another
one that we did on Facebook called
Facebook advertising tips and strategies
so that should give you some sense of
everything related to Facebook ads and
how to take advantage of the Facebook
ads manager platform so if there's
anything on social that we may have
missed or that you use feel free to add
a comment below the video we'd love to
hear your feedback okay let's talk about
some affiliate marketing tools let's
turn our attention affiliate marketing a
lot of affiliate marketing platforms out
there the number one probably is
Commission Junction also known as CJ
they are an affiliate platform they have
an a freemium model meaning you can have
a free trial but basically you're gonna
have to move on and pay for the platform
likewise for house offers you have
volume you really when it comes to
affiliate marketing a lot of platforms
out there click Inc hey when so a lot of
these are Brokers per se and when I say
Brokers like for example with CJ you as
a merchant or you as a publisher can get
in touch with a merchant you as a
merchant can get in touch with a
publisher meaning CJ helps bridge the
gap between you finding somebody to
build your network with okay so that's
what really affiliate marketing is and
you really need a platform to kind of
put it all together and and so a lot of
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
we're actually going to take a look at
CJ and go through some of the features
in the platform here shortly but let's
just take a look at why we need these
affiliate marketing tools well these
affiliate marketing tools identify you
know Affiliates influors employees other
Advocates you want to partner with so
again you could be on the merchant side
you could be actually selling a product
and you're going to want somebody to
help you sell that product somebody with
a website who's an influencer who drives
a lot of traffic to their own site who
you know does sell reputable brand Etc
so you need somebody to help you
introduce you to these sites okay so CJ
and some of these other marketing
platforms affiliate marketing platforms
do that okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with Affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do I mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am I only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there there but whatever
platform you use you're going to want to
be able to set up terms and conditions
with that particular affiliate so you
can set up a terms and conditions for
say 10 off all sales as an example okay
well you're getting a platform that will
help you broker that contract okay
contract terms or program terms
furthermore you're gonna need a platform
to help you track hey is this affiliate
helping me drive traffic or is this
affiliate driving traffic to my products
and is this affiliate helping me sell so
you the these platforms help you do just
that okay so you can gain a High website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social so
you have a lot of benefits to working
talking with affiliate marketing in
itself and the tools available will help
you gain website rankings as one example
we want to be able to track certain
metrics okay so an affiliate marketing
you have earnings per click EPC as an
example most platforms measure EPC from
a seven day period to a three month
period okay you can also figure out what
the actual cost per click is just like
you do on say Google search you can
actually measure that in affiliate okay
you want to eliminate fraudulent clicks
Impressions and conversions so any
affiliate platform worth its weight is
going to help you understand you know
how many Impressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
Impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so these platforms are
really built on helping you manage your
relationship with the affiliate by
offering uh all sorts of reports and
tools you know the other big benefit
here to affiliate marketing tool is hey
we can influence our customers
throughout their buying Journey so we
could set up different promotions based
on hey did somebody go to the website
did somebody see our product does
somebody click on a product did somebody
go into the shopping cart with our
product did somebody purchase our
product so then all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
Journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're going to have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience that's similar
to yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
public Publishers link so we're going to
click on the Publisher's link and
remember when you sign up Publishers you
have to have program terms and so if we
click on Publishers program terms we're
going to be able to see all the
different program terms available so
here we could see the different program
terms we have set up for certain
Publishers so if we just click on that
we'll be able to see that's the default
program term so remember you could set
up your own program term for any
publisher so as a best practice if you
have Publishers who are actually
performing well who are selling your
products maybe you want to offer them a
little bit more on the commission side
maybe you want to sweeten the deal maybe
you know These Guys these Publishers get
better program terms versus say other
Publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you can
see what the terms are the action and
the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products CJ is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful in the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately CJ has templates CJ
has some default program terms that you
could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
publisher is performing well sweeten the
deal offer them a better program terms
and so you can align Publishers with
different program terms and so that's
the whole idea behind program terms is
you want to be able to align Publishers
with that so when you sign up a
publisher they're going to get a line
with the program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our Network
these are our Publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your our Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cj.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much are
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search we're
paying Google X amount per click it's
the same thing here we can't or these
Publishers can't make any money if they
don't generate clicks so that's why you
have an EPC model or metric so to speak
so you can measure earnings per click CJ
does it over seven a period and over a
three month period so you could sort
based on seven day or three months to
see who's earning the most per click in
terms terms of Publishers now you can
select under Publishers groups now you
can group your Publishers okay so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea behind affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get a line with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing Publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm gonna
repeat it is you want to get Publishers
and you want to start building your base
of Publishers because the more publishes
you have the more chance you are to sell
your product remember if nobody clicks
on your product then nobody's gonna buy
your product so if you have Publishers
who are promoting your product for you
you then you have a good opportunity to
sell it so the more Publishers you have
on board the better the opportunity so
now once you have Publishers you can
start grouping these Publishers
accordingly to whatever makes sense it's
a business decision just know the
options available in CJ to group
Publishers let's turn our attention to
social media marketing tools social
media always a great topic to talk about
so we're going to finish up all our
digital marketing tools with social
media we talked about SEO paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay the first one I can think
about it here is HootSuite HootSuite is
a great social media marketing tool to
use okay it's a freemium okay you can
set up a free trial here you you
basically a base account and then you
can use HootSuite to do a lot of things
anything from setting up landing pages
to actually publishing content to
listening HootSuite to me is one of the
most powerful social media marketing
tools available you got buffer buffer is
a paid version but you can actually set
up a low cost or free account actually
on Buffer and then move to a paid
account okay you got tweet deck it's
been around a long time that is actually
free and I would recommend tweetdeck and
we're going to take a look at that here
in a couple minutes okay and then you
got Sprout social Sprout social is
another social marketing platform summer
to HootSuite do a lot of reporting a lot
of publishing you can a lot of listening
and so we're going to take a look at
Sprout social today as well before we do
that let's go over why these tools are
important to us from a social media
perspective you're pumping out a lot of
content so you need to be able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working lightly with just one
platform like Facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products Etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be Instagram Pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you can manage
everything in one place then these
social media marketing platforms need to
be able to make it easy for you to add
and manage different accounts okay so a
lot of them have the ability for you to
add you know not just one Twitter
account but multiple Twitter accounts
and not just one social media platform
but multiple social media platforms and
a good social media marketing so worth
its weight will help you monitor the
results so monitor social media posts
that help Drive leads and sales in other
words you're going to have a lot of
different metrics associated with each
social media marketing platform okay
which one is actually doing its job okay
so you want to be able to easily manage
these platforms applications and
websites very efficiently okay so
instead of having to log into each
platform you just log into one place get
a sense of what's been posted what the
engagement is did they purchase Etc and
what you want to do is be able to
individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in these social media marketing tools
okay you don't want to send out a
blanket message across different
platforms you want to be able to go
ahead and customize a post depending on
what that post is depending on what the
product is what time of day what target
market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprouts social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that
platform's going to have its own metrics
if you will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook insights
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads okay you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can and measure all that in one place so
if we log into sproutsocial I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log into Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprout social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I could
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I could see Impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information is our ready and
Facebook insights so if it's available
on Facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like Sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to officially jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example Sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you could
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and Publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do we could schedule
it for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go voila schedule so this is
on Twitter okay so you know we could
choose another platform here it's just
that easy to schedule so you want to be
able to schedule accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to look at the behavior of it
so it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on when something got published you
could see the reaction of it and react
to it so another thing here that I like
about it's about social heat Suite A lot
of these other platforms do it really
well you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example uh mail delivery
you know if we do mail delivery and
Twitter search we'll be able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local Okay so
this is Sprout's social's example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later.com so
later very similar Sprout social in that
it does a lot of the same things you can
actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15. local time and again
I have five profiles set up for this
account so I can pick and choose the
profile that I want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and I can
visually see it and that's important so
here I can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if I click
on this image here okay I can get a
sense of when it was used and I can view
it on a calendar I can out label for it
so that's another benefit later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so I can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being hacked
similar to The Listening tool in Sprout
social and they have analytics so you
can actually see right in later.com how
your particular social media platform is
performing so I could see it here over
seven days I can see the number of
followers have increased I could see the
growth rate I can see the number of
Impressions that I've received okay so I
want to be able to see how my particular
platforms perform in over a period of
time so I can look at reach the law
profile views website clicks okay so I
can get a lot of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if I wanted to I can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
Discovery actions comments saves Etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
data on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag has been used or saved
how many Impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet Tech so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity okay so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter uh so you can actually add a
column and pay attention to something
really specific okay so for example
search okay so right now I have men's
health but I could type in let's just
say World Cup okay so I could see the
you got the Cricut World Cup you got you
know the soccer football World Cup going
on so you know we could pick a
particular topic to follow if we wanted
to so again here I'm following Men's
Health so I can now see you know
everything that's been posted on men's
health now if I click on for example one
of these hashtags here that's trending I
can actually see who's tagging or you
using that hashtag Friday feeling in
their tweets and so the whole idea
behind you know tweetdeck it serves up a
interesting overview so to speak of not
only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or you
know other things that are being said so
if you really want to pay attention to
your brand or something really specific
like you know your competitors or a
specific product then you can just do a
search on that and so that's the great
thing about tweaktag it allows you to
kind of just look and listen in on
everything going on in Twitter now we do
have a good video out here on YouTube
how to start social media marketing so
if you haven't had a chance to look at
it take a look it goes over some of
these tools that we cover today like
Sprout social later.com you know
Facebook insights so it does cover in
more detail some of what we covered on
these social media marketing tools so
take a look at how to start social media
marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing Tools digital
marketing tools everything from SEO to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video SEO for
example so vid IQ you know we want to
use vid IQ to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into YouTube you can see vid IQ
is a browser extension or browser a
plug-in if you will so I can go and take
a look at a specific a specific video
and see how many hours it's been watched
how many views minutes watch subscribers
Etc you know the great thing here I can
look at the entire entire account so I
can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid IQ extension into my Chrome
browser so vid IQ actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid IQ because it's good
for video SEO okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so you
know if you're doing SEO and you have a
lot of content on your site well you
know what we want to be able to use a
tool maybe a third-party tool to give
some objective reasoning as to what more
we can be doing so you got tools like
SEO site checkup or site analyzer these
are pay tools but you know if you're
really heavily invested in SEO then they
may pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know Google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for Content optimization you know
there's also other key Reddit but but
you know this Keyword Planner uh in
Google there's also a word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a Google
ads platform and so if you don't have
Google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to Google's Keyword Planner
so having a third-party keyword tool
will pay divins and say well because
those dividends pay off in the form of
not only pay-per-click but also SEO and
if you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in Social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
Reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in Google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts SEO so
there are other tools available you got
a third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by Google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of and determine in how you
can improve your page load time my
favorite topic conversion rate
optimization so you got a couple in here
crazy egg and zarget okay so I'm gonna
show you another tool called hot jar so
here if you log into hotshot.com you can
set up an account it's actually free and
with the free account you can have hot
Char measure the heat map not only the
heat map but the click mapping the
scrolling of a particular page and so
here you can see we're looking at a
particular page here so hot jar allows
me to you know see on that page where
people are clicking
um I can also see where people are
moving I can also see you know the
scrolling of a particular page okay so
you can see here on the page I could see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking mostly if
I switch over to move mode then I can
see on that particular page age where
people are actually moving their Mouse
and then I have my scroll analysis so I
could see you know how far down people
actually scroll on the page and so again
with a paid account you can measure up
to 10 000 page views with the free
version you can measure up to 2 000
pages and so 2 000 Pages allows you to
get some insight as to what people are
clicking on or where they're moving or
how they're scrolling on a particular
page and so I definitely recommend hot
jar they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hotjar so hotjar.com is a
tool I would recommend as well so one
final tool and I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention it and that's Google optimize so
Google optimize is a Google platform
that allows you to a B test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page to see which one performs
better and so with Google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of Google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see I have
an account set up and optimize you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page the original didn't have
the photos to the top of the page and so
we can go in a report in here Google
optimized does all the heavy lifting and
so here you can see we can look at
bounces or we can look at you know
basically a measure the test up against
the metric that's important to our
business and again the whole point is to
improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at Google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me Google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different test and that means
you have the ability to really improve
website performance okay so Google
optimize is a tool that I would
recommend today we're going to talk
about why you would want to rank using
SEO and SEO is search engine
optimization also known as organic
search you also May us here a say
organic listings where we're going to
talk a little bit about why you'd want
to rank your website in organic search
okay what is search engine optimization
then we're going to follow that up with
how does Google rank websites so why
does it rank one website over another
and how do we get our website to rank
number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of SEO or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're going to finish that
off with the do's and don'ts of SEO so
let's get right to it and talk about why
SEO so we're going to use a basic
example and let's just say you have a
Blog talk you're a food blogger you're
passionate about food and your Niche is
ice cream and let's just say you have a
lot of ice cream recipes you want to get
traffic to your blog you want people to
read your blog and you're curious why am
I not ranking for my blog why when
people type in ice cream recipes and say
Google my blog posts don't appear at the
top of organic rankings and there's a
number of reasons why you wouldn't be
ranked for your blog post or your ice
cream recipes and the main reason would
be your competitors so there could be
somebody else out there who is also
passionate about ice cream and has been
blogging along longer than you and they
have more content and more blog posts
and more pages for Google to rank so
that's usually the number one reason the
other reason is improper usage of
keywords and we're going to talk a
little bit or it's actually a lot more
about you know keyword usage in your
content so what kind of keywords do you
want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is poor link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say WordPress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
Google would you really want to rank a
website or blog post in this example
number one on Google rankings if if that
particular page loaded very slow no you
wouldn't because when somebody clicked
on that link in organic search and went
to your website they're going to have a
bad experience because the page is going
to load slow so Google doesn't want
their users to have a bad experience you
don't want your users to have a bad
experience and so that's why web page
load time is a critical factor for
ranking so we need to make sure that our
web pages load fast and then your user
experience is not good enough so Google
again based on my example about the web
page load time Google wants people to
have a good experience when they go from
their search engine to your website and
there's a lot at play there specifically
web page load time but also you know
Google doesn't want any spam content
Google doesn't want any pop-ups or
overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is Google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a Blog with a hundred recipes you want
Google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on Google organic search so
let's move on to what is SEO so sticking
with our ice cream Blog theme really SEO
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
Google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
particular keywords so if you want to be
ranked for ice cream recipes well
there's certain things you need to do so
that's generally how it works we need to
apply search engine optimization to
increase a page for keyword we want to
be found for so let me give you an
example so let's just say there's a
hundred students that participated in an
essay competition and so the competition
in this particular case is evaluated on
the basis of is the content relevant are
they using suitable titles for their
essay do they have structure when
they're participating in this essay or
talking about the essay and do they have
a suitable synopsis and is the content
neat and readable these seem all logical
for an essay competition well guess what
they seem logical for SEO because that's
exactly how SEO works it's exactly all
those points I just mentioned about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called The Meta
description and then again the the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page SEO
that is Google rank website and
basically Google follows three base six
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to you
know have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank those pages that they've indexed
from number one to Infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query so really it's about
crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which Google has Bots and what these
Bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these Pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spidering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what Google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index So based on
this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into Google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found then they're not going to show up
for Relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to Google Search and if
I type in the keyword simply learn okay
I could see I have one way in 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learn pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are one million 10 000 Pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see something that says add next to
it okay so we could see that there are
paid ads here but when it comes to
organic search those are generally below
paid ads and so that's where Google
counts the one million 10 000 results
and so that's a whole idea behind
crawling and indexing Google's able to
cross simply learns website and based on
all the pages that they gather they're
going to make those pages available in
organic search so if you type in a
keyword and your web page is not
available for indexing then you're never
going to show up for that keyword so
that's why it's important to make sure
your website is available for crawling
and indexing and so when a user types a
query on search Google search the most
relevant websites that are in Google's
index are going to pair in the search
results so in the example I gave was
simply learn well simply learn is the
brand name of the company simply learned
so there's a lot of relevancy there so
that's why you see simply learn show up
here organically number one like we
mentioned about what is SEO and why SEO
we talked about that user experience so
there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learned example simply
learn is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in India the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the United
States why because Google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in India their
results may be a little bit different
than the results show up in the U.S
because Google has different Bots and
these Bots are crawling different pages
at different times and so Google's index
is updating continuously but it's not
real time syncing so if you do a search
in India you may not see exactly the
same thing because both search engines
the Google in India and the Google and
the US are may not be exactly synced up
so an example would be you know if
you're looking for Cafe so if you search
a cafe and and say San Francisco you're
going to see different results now if
you do a search for cafes in Mumbai
you're going to see different results
there's going to be local search here at
the top there may be some paid search
but again you may see different results
because one location but two Google
search engines in India and United
States google.com aren't exactly synced
up exactly at the same exact time you do
that search so location is important
language is important and relevancy is
important along with user experience so
all those are important factors in how
Google ranks websites okay so we're
going to talk about the types of SEO now
so if we want to rank for a particular
keyword on Google we're going to have to
apply search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page SEO and off-page
SEO so first we're going to talk about
on page SEO so on page SEO is nothing
more than optimizing your own website
and so when we say optimizing your own
website there's certain elements on your
website and on your web pages that we
need to take into account and so some of
those elements are headers meta
descriptions title tags linking so all
of those elements are something we can
control as an end user who wants to rank
our web page and our website on Google
and before we do anything with our
website the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page SEO you can
change the title tag The Meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed But first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
why do I choose Google Keyword Planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google is going to do
is they're gonna give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data from mobile as well as
desktop and so we could see a trend here
that for each particular month over the
last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months I could
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
Google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here I can see Google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the Google's Keyword
Planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that I might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one
keyword so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing Specialists social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is one
thousand per month on average of the
last 12 months I can also see the
competition is medium but for some other
keywords I can see the search volume
being high like digital marketing course
at 2900 per month but also the
competition is high and so what I would
recommend is a best practice is to
collect all your relevant keywords okay
and put all your relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet and when you put all these
relevant keywords in a spread sheet you
want to get the data on those keywords
and the data I'm referring to is the
volume of competition so in this case we
have volume from Google planner Google's
Keyword Planner and I have competition
from Google's Keyword Planner and so if
I go into a spreadsheet and I put all
that information in here I'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that Google's
Keyword Planner if I go back just gives
us low medium and high and if I want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe I want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what I can do is go into Google and I
can type in that keyword so if I type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 Million results so I could see 76
Million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now now that's a
whole lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 per month on average and so what
I want to do is get a more clear picture
of the competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
can see every one of them how to become
a digital marketing specialist and why
is that important because now that tells
me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax all
in title and then your keyword in this
example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize is for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO so
okay you want to
great content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search it's got to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they type type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
trunk handed it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're going to see it and they're
going to click through to your website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
Bolder than anything else Google
displays so the second thing you want to
optimize is the meta description and The
Meta description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keywords
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's going included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organization relational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from H1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an H6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an H1 or an H2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to Google that hey this
header with this particular keyword in
it is important so if you use an H6 with
the keyword in it it's telling Google
hey this is an H6 but it's not as
important so an H1 and an H2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content 10
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link and if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation
thinking naturally and seamlessly go
from one relevant article or page to
another and so that's the whole idea
behind link building and internal link
building it allows Google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to Google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end you
user experience and it's about allowing
Google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to internal linking we want
to be able to use natural language and
so what do I mean by natural language or
natural language processing so what
Google does is in terms of natural
language processing they're looking for
the content and the keyword it needs to
be relevant so when your website is
about digital marketing you don't
necessarily want to rank or try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing one
it's too broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key or
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing and examples or what
is a digital marketing strategy or how
to become a digital marketing specialist
so those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with a
site map it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap an XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply we type in say sitemap.xml just
as an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking gain and
also updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page SEO
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off-page SEO and you could do all the
off-page SEO you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page SEO and so off-page SEO is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember I talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page SEO we used internal
linking for off-page SEO we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our website
sites recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and Authority
because we want Google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off-page SEO methods then
Google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page SEO synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we're have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
Authority and so what I mean by high
domain Authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
Authority is going to improve and when
our domain Authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website than other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
have any link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are in credibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing Specialists on Google they may
type in our brand name in this case
simply learn and so these are all the
benefits to off-page SEO so it's nothing
more than having links on other websites
that are pointing back to ours and again
there's lots of benefits its drives
helps Drive traffic and increases our
Authority so those are things that we
want to take advantage of when we want
to rank and the key behind off-page SEO
or link building is always going to be
content so from an on-page SEO
perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or it can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that some people could link
from so the whole idea is understanding
who else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out there that has content somewhat
of yours so that you can you know get a
link on that particular website or blog
post and so some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just Facebook or Twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's media there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
Reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a Blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure sure that you're are able
and willing to put an external link on
your blog post or website pointing to
their content that's how the web Works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of SEO so we talked a
lot about why SEO what is SEO how do we
rank for SEO what is on page SEO what is
off-page SEO and so let's just wrap up
with some of the things you again want
to do to rank your page for a particular
keyword and some of the things you don't
want to do so the first thing on the
list is optimize for white hat
techniques and what I mean for opting in
for white hat techniques is basically
everything I just mentioned today you
want to do keyword research you want to
choose a natural language processing
form format so you could choose keywords
that are going to be relevant natural to
the content and you don't want to opt
for black cat Tech techniques and blad
hat techniques are probably not even
worth going into detail but one example
is choosing a keyword arbitrarily like
say digital marketing and just stuffing
that keyword into the content so that's
probably not something you want to do
because again it's not going to be good
for the end user so stay away from black
hat and focus on some of the techniques
we talked about in today's presentation
the other do we want to do is get
backlinks from relevant sites so that's
off-page SEO again it's what I mentioned
earlier it's about linking your quality
content to another person's website that
also has quality content we don't want
to have a backlink from an irrelevant
site why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same
same way as if you were on a quality
website we do want to use our keywords
naturally because title tags are what
people see first on organic search but
you don't want to use the same title tag
on every page of your website so we want
to stay away from doing that so you want
to have a unique title tag for every web
page on your website and ideally what
does that mean that means using our
keyword research to choose one or two
keywords per page and optimizing your
web page for those one to two keywords
so you ideally what you want to do is
have one to two different keywords for
every page on your website we definitely
definitely definitely want to write
engaging content so the content should
be engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
play plagiarize or just copy content
from others websites because it's not
one probably going to be relevant to
what you're writing about two it's
duplicate content and it's somebody
else's so that's a black cat Technique
we want to stay away from I can't
emphasize this enough we need to do
keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a key word
that has low volume High competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuff in so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and Google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural naturally
linking from one page to another not
only does it help Google understand and
crawl all the web pages on your website
but it's good for the end User it's good
user experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure Google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
SEO and off-page SEO then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly search
engine optimization starts with the
keyword because we want to be found for
Relevant keywords and so the first step
in search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research so it is
the most important step and so what is
keyword research all about well it's
process of identifying keywords we want
to be found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the Italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about Italian restaurants or
somebody types in the best Italian
restaurants or Italian restaurants in a
specific City we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
based on the factor of how much traffic
or volume a particular search engine
query has and it's based on competition
and really the underlying Factor here is
that all keywords in your keyword
research should be relevant so you need
to understand what those keywords are so
are they relevant to the content that
you want to be found for if they are
then really the two factors you want to
look for is the volume how much volume
or traffic each keyword has associated
with it and then the competition how
many other their websites are trying to
be found for the same keyword so those
are the factors involved with keyword
research you always want to choose
relevant keywords and then once you find
or choose those relevant keywords you
want to be able to find out exactly how
much volume and how much competitions
associated with each of those keywords
and so when you look at keywords you're
always going to choose relevant keywords
but there are two types of keywords
there are short tail keywords and there
are long tail keywords and we're going
to talk about both of these here so
let's start with short tail keywords so
short tail keywords are generic keywords
generally they're less than three words
in a keyword phrase for example Italian
restaurants so short tail keywords
generally have very high search volume
that means that if somebody types in
Italian restaurants then there's going
to be a large amount of volume with that
meaning that generally a lot of people
type in the keyword Italian restaurant
months however with high volume always
comes High competition so if you want to
be found for Italian restaurants know
that if you are ranked number one or
number two or even on page one of Google
you're going to get a lot of traffic
however to get to page one of Google or
even position one or two it's going to
take you a while because there are
probably a lot of websites who are in
front of you who want to be ranked and
found for the same keyword so the whole
idea with short tail keywords is it's a
lot of visibility it's a lot of traffic
a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition and generally the underlying
Factor here is that if you are ranked
for very broad or short tail keyword
like Italian restaurants then chances
are it's not going to be as relevant so
if you get the traffic to your website
then chances are the conversion's not
necessarily going to happen because we
don't necessarily know the mindset of
somebody typing in a very short tail
generic keyword like Italian restaurants
they could be doing research on Italian
restaurants they could be a chef who's
trying to get recipes for Italian food
it could be a tourist looking for
Italian restaurants in a different city
or it could be a person just looking for
Italian restaurants near their location
or where they're living and so there's a
lot of different factors with short tail
keywords so you just don't know because
it's so generic and because it's so
generic if you do get the traffic for
that generic keyword then the chances
that conversion are going to be lower
than say if it's a more specific
relevant keyword so let's take an
example of a short tail keyword let's
just stick with Italian restaurants so
I'm gonna go to a tool called Moz and
while Moz has a tool called the keyword
Explorer and within Moz so if you go to
moz.com and then use the keyword
Explorer you can get an idea of how much
volume and competition are associated
with particular keyword so in this
example we're using Italian restaurants
it's a very broad keyword we could see
that the monthly volume is between
seventy thousand and a hundred and
eighteen thousand per month okay so that
means for a particular keyword in the
United States on a search engine you're
going to get about 70 000 to 118 000
people who type in that keyword and so
if we were look at the difficulty of
that keyword you could see that it's
fairly difficult because out of 1 to 100
it's got a score of 43 so it's fairly
difficult however if you notice the
click-through rate is very high so Moz
estimates that we'll have a forty
percent organic click-through rate for
that keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to longer tail case
words however if you want the visibility
then you want to use short tail keywords
if you want the conversion then you want
to switch over to longer tail keywords
so longer tail keywords are more
specific they usually consist of more
than three keywords so tie in
restaurants very generic if we add a few
more keywords that keyword phrase it
then becomes longer tail so compared to
short tail keywords longer tail keywords
are generally less competitive and the
search volume is not as high okay some
point so if we go back to Moz and then
we look at the keyword Explorer and we'd
actually type in Italian restaurants and
let's just say Orlando Florida
Moz is going to generate some monthly
volume for us and they're going to allow
us to understand how difficult that
keyword is and so here you can see very
very little search volume in fact so
little volume there's 11 to 50 okay so
that means on average that this keyword
generates 11 to 50 queries a month so
very low compared to our short tail
keyword Italian restaurants the
difficulty here didn't necessarily
lessen but it is less uh competitive so
if you're interested in conversions and
you have an Italian restaurant in say
Orlando Florida then this is the keyword
you may want to use so there's a
trade-off between longer tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in Italian in Florida
Florida branded shoes in Florida
something very specific is going to
generate probably a higher conversion
rate than something more generic so
that's the trade-off and so I went to
use long tail keywords well we want to
use long tail keywords and for targeting
pages with a product or specific article
so for interested in that particular
conversion then longer tail keywords are
likely more the way we want to go versus
something more generic which means if
you're using a generic shorter tail
keyword you're more interested in the
visibility and the traffic not
necessarily the conversion how does a
search engine work so let's talk about
that for a minute so we know that
millions of people use search engines we
know that we want to be found on search
engines but how do we actually get our
content in the search engine so that's
the important part that we need to
understand if we have our own website we
have our content so these search engines
want your content in their search engine
index so how do they they get your
content well they send out Bots or files
and we'll just call them spiders so they
send out these spiders to crawl your
website and the whole idea behind using
the insect spider is because we're
talking about the world wide web and so
if Google for example sends a bot to
your website they're going to crawl your
website and spy to your website they're
creating a web of pages so all they're
doing is following link and every page
and Link that they hit they're going to
bring back to their server so these
spiders scan your websites they just
follow links and they take all the pages
and content that they're able to gather
when they hit your website and they're
going to pull all that information back
into their own index so if you think
about Google they're crawling or
spidering millions and billions of
websites all those millions and billions
of websites are sitting on Google
servers so when somebody does do a
search query Google because they have
all all these websites and their index
are able to quickly determine which
website is the most relevant for that
search engine query so that's generally
how search engines work so let's talk
about the types of SEO so if we want our
website to be found on these search
engines in Google or these search
engines have crawled our website then
what we want to do is we want to
basically look at it from a two-pronged
perspective it's a two-prong strategy so
the first strategy we're going to talk
about today is on page SEO so those are
on-page seos defined as what we do on
our website to be relevant for search
engine query on a search engine so again
on-page SEO is what we do to our own
website off-page SEO is the other the
second part of that SEO strategy and
off-page SEO determines what we do off
our website to be relevant for search
engine query and so off-page SEO
generally is synonymous with link
building and we'll talk about that a
little bit more as we go forward but
really when you want to do SEO when you
want to be found for a keyword on a
search engine you're going to have to
apply both on-page SEO and off-page SEO
so let's talk about on-page SEO and so
this is the first part of our SEO effort
we want to focus on on-page SEO first
and so on page SEO is the method of
optimizing elements of web pages
remember these are all the items we want
to do on our website to be relevant for
certain search queries so it's basically
the idea behind this is to make our web
pages more relevant for specific search
queries on search engines and so there
are a number of different elements on
our website on a particular web page
that we want to manipulate or optimize
if you will to be relevant for search
engine query and so let's start around
the idea that you know you there's a
number of things you can do so let's
start with schema first and so schema is
nothing more than it's a collaborative
effort between Bing Yahoo Baidu Google
and the idea is really they want to
understand more about the content of
your website and so the idea behind this
is that you want to be able to provide
Snippets of information to these search
engines so they understand a little bit
more about what your web page is trying
to portray or convey so that they can
find out exactly what's relevant to that
search engine query so it's nothing more
than Micro Data or bits of information
that you can add to your website or web
page in order to provide a little bit
more enhanced information to the search
engines so if you think about its collab
boarding with the search engine so the
more basic information you share with
the search engines that the better off
they have to understand what your web
page or website is all about and so the
more information they have the better of
an opportunity you have to be ranked for
that search engine query and so if you
have a website with reviews if you have
a website with images if you have let's
say a website with products with prices
in other words you have an e-commerce
website and you're trying to sell
products well to me you want to employ
schema because again schema is Snippets
of information that are provided to the
search engine so they can better
understand so you can certainly provide
Snippets of information in the terms of
images or prices or particular products
and how much is left in stock so all
this information these bits of
information you can provide to the
search engine so that they can better
better understand what it is you're
trying to sell how much it cost how much
is in inventory what people think about
the product Etc so if you have a website
that sell products you probably want to
employ schema and so when you do
employee schema again Snippets of
information provided to the search
engines the search engines are going to
better understand and then they're going
to present that information in the
search engine results so if you have
ratings and reviews you can provide
Snippets of information to the search
engines the search engines in turn are
going to present that information in the
search engine results so if you have
positive reviews then somebody typing in
in this example shoes they're going to
be able to see that you have positive
reviews for your website so that's the
whole idea behind schema is to provide
Snippets of information so again it's
not just related to reviews also for
images so if you have images you can
provide Snippets of information to the
search engine so they can see you know
what the the shoe actually looks like
when they type in in this example Puma
shoes or like I mentioned inventory
Snippets of information about your
inventory the search engines are going
to provide that information search
engine results so if somebody's looking
for women's training shoes or women's
Puma shoes and they see your product and
they see oh this is in stock great let
me go to this website and purchase these
shoes so that's the whole idea behind
schema is making sure you present
information critical to your website so
that the search engines better
understand what your website's about it
also helps with relevancy because the
more those search engines know about
your website the more relevant your
website becomes and the better chance
you have to rank for a particular
keyword there's also some other
information here involved with schema
and those are site links so site links
additional pages on your website okay
that show up in the search engine result
and so again the more information a
search engine has about you the better
chance you have to be found the better
chance you have to get a click so site
links are just additional links on your
site that appear in search engine
results and that's all a benefactor of
having a schema so here you can see in
this example we have additional web
pages that show under a certain search
engine results and so by having more
links in the search engine results you
have a better chance of getting the
click so if you want more information
about schema I would recommend going to
schema.org so when you go to schema.org
you can actually click on a link that
allows you to see all the information
you need to get started with schema.org
okay so it's got a lot of information
available to you it describes what it is
you have to do in order to get your
information in a set for the search
engines to better understand focus on
for on-page SEO is title tag and so
title tag is what which shows up in the
search engine results so if you've ever
done a search engine query meaning
you've gone to Google typed in a query
using a keyword like Italian restaurants
you're going to see specific search
engine results and the title tag is what
appears in those search engine results
so a title tag is important because it's
the title of a web page that appears in
those results and so the title tag is
something that's important because if we
want to be found for a specific keyword
we want to make sure that keyword is in
the title tag because that keyword is
going to describe what the page is all
about and so if we want to be found for
that keyword let's just say Italian
restaurants in Florida for example
that's going to be part of our title tag
so when somebody types in that
particular keyword query Italian
restaurants in Florida then we have a
good chance of showing up because the
title tag which is the title of the page
is going to have that particular query
in it and so you can edit the title tag
and and when you edit the title tag you
want to be able to put that particular
keyword in the title tag so if we do a
search on Google for example so if I go
to google.com and I type in Italian
restaurants in Florida
here I can see under the local search
results and here I could see Italian
restaurants in Florida Central Florida
Italian restaurants in Miami so you can
see that these are highlighted so the
title tag is not only stands out but
allows you to you know showcase exactly
what your page is all about and it helps
with the relevancy of that keyword query
so when you're trying to optimize your
website using the title tag for specific
keyword you want to keep it in mind a
couple parameters because title tags
show up in the search engine results but
certain search engines particularly
Google has character limits around the
number of characters you can use in the
title tag and so we want to keep that in
mind so ideally we want to format our
title tag appropriately and so to me the
most optimal way to optimize a title tag
using a particular keyword that you want
to be found for is to you use that
keyword in the title tag and then
separate that with your brand name so if
you actually have two keywords then you
can use the primary keyword first then
the secondary keyword and then the brand
name so to me this is the most optimal
format but keep in mind there are
character limits but if you look at this
format to me it's the most easiest
format to abide by because it makes your
title tag more relevant you don't have
to worry about necessarily fitting in
excess keywords in the title tag because
again the title tag has character limits
so if we take a look at our example in
Google search results if you go over
those limits and the title tag is
generally between 60 and 65 characters
long and so if you go over those limits
let's just say your title tag is more
than 65 characters Google in this case
is going to cut off the characters and
so here you can see the ellipses after
the title tag now if you follow all the
format that you know we had simply learn
recommend you could see if our keyword
is Italian restaurants in Florida and
then separated by the brand name this
gives you an optimal format for the
title tag it also makes it relevant for
the keyword query so you want to keep
that title tag probably no more than 60
characters because if you flirt with
putting more than 60 characters then the
search engines are going to cut off that
title tag and then that's not going to
look good and it's going to also become
less relevant so we want to keep the
character counts in mind so if you abide
by that format of the keyword and then
maybe the secondary keyword if you have
one separated by the brand name then you
should be good to go with making sure
your title tag is relevant for that
keyword query so let's then turn our
attention to the meta description so the
meta description is just a short
description about the content on your
web page so if the title tag is the
title of the web page The Meta
description describes the page okay so
it's a description about what that page
is so the meta description appears under
the title tag and then the URL so if we
go back to our Google search results we
look here at Italian restaurants in
Florida Maggiano's Little Italy is the
brand or the restaurant we could see the
URL which is underneath the title tag
and then here we could see the meta
description and so with the meta
description you have a little bit more
room to work with in terms of character
counts but the meta description just
like the title tag is just as important
because one it shows up in the search
engine results two it describes what the
page is all about and three it allows
you to optimize The Meta description so
the meta description becomes more
relevant for that search query that
somebody types into that particular
search engine so the optimal length for
a meta description you can go up to 300
characters but I would not even
recommend even flirting with that limit
because just like the title tag search
engines in the case of Google will
actually cut off The Meta description so
if we look here back at our search
results if you go over those limits
you'll see that the search engines will
cut off the copy of the meta description
with and they'll just put ellipses so we
don't necessarily want to go over those
limits so my recommendation is to keep
that meta description probably
165 characters to to no more than 200
because we're trying to describe not
only what the page is all about but
we're also trying to optimize that meta
description so it becomes relevant for
the search engine query and so you want
to keep it short and concise so if we
look at our example here Italian
restaurants in Florida Maggiano's does a
good job it's a book and event space
make a reservation at Maggiano's in
Florida to enjoy delicious few Maps
menus and more so very concise meta
description it includes their keyword
query that they want to be found for
Italian restaurants in Florida and so to
me it's short and concise describes what
the page is all about and uh allows them
to fit it all in within the character
limits so here in this example we want
to be found for Amazon Puma shoes so the
brand here is Amazon so Amazon wants to
include you know Puma shoes not only in
the title tag but they want to try and
fit that into the meta description
however the whole idea behind the meta
description more than anything else is
described what the page is all about
okay you want to be relevant for the
search engine query but you also want to
sound natural as well you want to be
able to really the whole idea between
the title tag and amount of description
is to get people to click on your link
because remember there there are nine
other listings on the Google search
engine results page for page one so we
want our meta description and our title
tag to stand out so we want it to be
relevant but we wanted to stand out so
it's important you write that meta
description according to what the page
is all about but you want it to stand
out uniquely and accordingly so once
you've done the title tag and The Meta
description you want to focus your
attention on the header tag and so
header tags are used on a web page to
really separate out content and so you
have headers and subheaders and so
ideally you want to be able to optimize
the header tag and the sub header and so
if we think about headers there's a
hierarchy for headers so there's between
a header one and a header six and so
we'll just shorten the word header and
we'll call it an H1 so H1 is really at
the top of the hierarchy for headers and
so if we use a H1 on our web page then
what we're trying to explain of the
search engines is listen this particular
keyword phrase in our header is is a
header and we're emphasis we're trying
to emphasize what it is we're trying to
say and that's how really the search
engines interpret headers they see an H1
H2
h3h4h5 and H6 they know that if you're
using an H1 you're trying to really
emphasize something so if you put that
keyword in the header tag what you're
telling the search engines is hey I'm
really emphasizing this particular
keyword and so the search engine will
interpret that as important and if you
use your keyword in that header then
really what you're saying is hey I
really this keyword is really relevant
to that query so naturally the other
benefit of a header is it really breaks
up the page as well so the header you
can use subheaders and subheaders are
nothing more than say a lower H tag so
if you have a header that's an H1 you
can use an H2 or an H3 as a subheader
and so forth and so on because what
you're really trying to do is not only
organize the content on your web page
but you're trying to emphasize that for
Google so if something's an H2 or an H6
you're basically telling Google or the
other search engines this is not as
important as say in H1 so if we take a
look at our example that we've been
using for Italian restaurants in Florida
and if we click on Maggiano's we could
see that they're using headers so if we
click on Maggiano's we could see that
this is a header here we want to bring
everyone together Maggiano's Italian
restaurant in Florida so they're using
that header to break up the text here
you can see they're using another header
here excellent Italian food and an
excellent experience to match so that's
a header to break up the content okay
they're not using subheaders they're
just using headers but that's fine
they're really trying to emphasize the
content by putting in that header and so
how headers help not only organize the
content but they help emphasize the
actual keyword it is you want Google to
recognize so if we're not sure if
something is a header we could simply
just Mouse over what we think is a
header and we can just right click and
if you right click on something you're
going to see a menu and if we click
inspect element then basically what that
browser in this case Firefox is going to
do is show us the HTML of that
particular thing of that item that we
right click so here we could see in this
particular case this is an H2 tag so
it's an H2 so if we scroll down and we
Mouse over this we could see this is
also an H2 as well so this particular
page is using H2 tags not H1 but in H2
so what they're explaining or trying to
convey to the search engines is listen
this is an H2 it's still relevant we're
still trying to put emphasis on it but
not as much so we want to be able to use
our H1s and our H2S accordingly so
remember in H1 is you're providing the
search engines with information by
telling them hey this is the most
relevant this is we're putting emphasis
on this keyword and H2 nuts as much as
an H1 and an H3 not as much as an H2 so
use your headers accordingly not only
just to break up the text not only for
styling but for emphasis for the search
engines so headers are very important
elements for on-page SEO okay let's turn
our attention to the URL structure okay
so URL stands for uniform resource
locator and so are you around is the
specific location of a web page on the
internet so basically if we're found in
the search engine results one of our web
pages are gonna go along with the title
tag and The Meta description in the
search engine results page so if I go
back to our search engine results for
Italian restaurants in in Florida we
could see that the particular URL in
question here is
locations.maggianos.com Florida so
that's the URL that shows up along with
the title tag in The Meta description so
if we click on that link that's exactly
where we're going to go so URL structure
is important for on-page SEO so why is
it important because not only does it
show people where they're going but we
have an opportunity to optimize at URL
for the search engines to make our URL
more relevant for that search query so
just like the title tag just like the
meta description just like the headers
we can also manipulate the URL so if we
look at a URL it consists of really the
protocol and the protocol means it's
either a secure site or non-secure site
so in this example we could see it's
https and that means it's a secure site
and so ideally search engines like web
pages or websites that are secure so
after the protocol you're going to see
the domain and then after the domain
you're going to see subdirectories okay
so that's generally the breakout with
URL structures you have the protocol the
domain and subdirectories and then you
may have more subdirectories so if we go
back to the example we've been working
with if I go back to Maggiano's you can
see here this is a secure site https you
can see the domain in this case it's
actually a sub domain so maggiano's.com
is the domain but they decided to put
locations.masgianos.com and that's okay
we call that a sub domain and then here
you can see they have one particular
subdirectory after the domain and that's
Florida so a well structured URL not
only provides the users with information
about where they're going when they
click on your link and the search engine
results but more importantly it also
provides the search engines and some
information about what the web page is
all about so going back to our simple
example with Maggiano's the search
engines know that hey if somebody clicks
on this link they're going to a page
about Florida pretty simple the URL
structure is pretty simple to understand
we know it's a secure site we know it's
maggianos.com and we know the sub page
is Florida with subdirectories Florida
you want to be careful like everything
else since in SEO there are parameters
just like the title tag has parameters
up to 65 characters The Meta description
tag has a limit of up to 165 characters
a well-structured URL also has character
counts but the idea here is we don't
want to get into numbers when we talk
about character counts for URL structure
really the rule of thumb or the best
practice for your url is to keep it
short and understandable okay if we keep
it clear concise not only does the end
user know where they're going but the
search engines know what the page is all
about so the rule of thumb is always if
you don't understand the URL or what it
means then the search engines are likely
not going to understand what the URL
means we want to keep the number of
directors and subdirectories to a limit
so ideally here you can see in this
example xyz.com if we want to optimize
that URL we could put the targeted
keyword in the URL if we'd like to but
we want to keep it probably to a minimum
of one to two subdirectories the shorter
the amount of subdirectories the better
off we are because that means that not
only the end user will understand the
URL but the search engines will
understand the URL as well so we always
want to make sure that URL is readable
again for the Yan user and the search
engine and so in this example you could
see amazon.com men's shoes slash
sneakers slash Puma very easy understand
as an end user I know that I'm going to
a puma page for men on amazon.com now
when you get into URLs with Dynamic
parameters in them then ideally you as
an end user is not going to really know
where you're going to go so in the
example here the middle example I can
see that I'm going maybe to a shoes page
but I have no idea what the rest that
URL means and in the other example where
you have a very low URL readability I
have no idea as an end user where I'm
going to go so as an end user I need to
be able to have confidence in knowing
where I'm going to go once I click on a
link in the search engine results so if
I don't have that confidence if I don't
understand what the URL is then you then
the search engines aren't going to
understand as well and it's not going to
bode well in terms of relevancy and
again the URL structure is an important
factor for being relevant and if we're
not relevant then the chances of us are
ranking higher is not going to be as
good because our URL is not readable so
ideally what we want to do is make sure
we're using keywords that the end user
and the search engines understand and if
we need to separate out those keywords
in the first example we could see men's
shoes we want to separate that out with
a hyphen and so ideally if you have a
URL that's readable and it's short and
concise then again your chances of
ranking higher on the search engine
results page bodes better than if you
have a very long Antiquated unreadable
URL so let's focus our attention on
image alt text or alt tags if you will
so alt tags or text tags as they're also
known as allow uh the search engine to
understand a little bit more about
what's on the page in terms of images so
images are a prominent part of every web
page on the internet unfortunately
images are you know usually files that
are not readable by search engines so we
want to be able to provide some
alternate text so that the search
engines understand what those images are
all about so again it gives us an
opportunity to communicate with the
search engines so that they better
understand what the image is all about
to make the page more relevant so
generally if an image fails to load on a
web page as an example well if you have
an ALT tag then the all tag is going to
show in place of the image not loading
more importantly if we have an ALT tag
in the search engines have spidered our
website and somebody's actually
searching for images then the alt tag is
used as a descriptor for the image so it
also helps us get found for the images
on search engine results pages and so
like everything else we've talked about
with on-page SEO there are character
limits to all tags you know generally
the rule of thumb is 125 characters for
an ALT tag and the alt tag is used in
the HTML so we want to surround our
image with an ALT tag by putting in a
descriptor and so ideally if you're
trying to be found for a particular
search engine query then you want to use
the search engine query as part of the
alt tag and so let me show you an
example here going back to Maggiano's we
look at their web page and we actually
inspect one of their images on this
webpage if we look at for example
Pinterest or Facebook we can actually
see in this example that the image here
has an ALT tag it's Pinterest and so you
want to be able again to put in all tags
for all your images so it better
communicates with the search engines
what the image is all about it also
allows the search engines to rank images
in the search engine results based on
that alt text and what the keyword query
was so all tags play an important role
because again if the image doesn't load
on the web page for some reason then the
alt tag is there as a replacement it's
also there to help the search engines
rank those images and understand the
page a little bit better so you always
want to be able to put in the keyword
query that you're trying to be found for
in the alt tag and so b as descriptive
as possible you have 125 characters to
use so B is descriptive making easy to
read because again this is what's going
to show up and the search engine results
Pages for images okay let's turn our
attention to internal links so when it
comes to SEO internal links also play a
vital role because basically an internal
link which is a link from one page of
your website to another page of your
website
um allows Google to or other search
engines really to follow the pages as
they index your entire website so it
serves that purpose of allowing search
engines to index so it definitely
improves the indexing but internal
linking also has many benefits and one
of the other benefits is it helps
spreads what we call link juice and so
link juice is basically a way another
way of saying you know this page is
important because it has links from
other pages on our website so if we link
I have a link from one page to another
other and a couple of other pages on our
site linked to that same page then
search engines tend to take notice and
they tend to note that you know if one
particular page has a number of
different links point to it then this
page may be important and so that's what
we mean by link juice it's a signal for
the search engine to determine what
pages on your website are important
because of the links that point to it
and so if we look at this example here
we could see that you know there's
usually a navigation on a website that
point to pages and every page on a
website tends to have a link but if more
than one page has multiple links then
again that signals to the search engines
that hey you know this particular page
seems to be important because it has a
lot of links pointing to it our
attention to sitemaps so site Maps
basically allow us to list all the web
pages on our website so we could do that
and a couple of different ways but when
we do it it basically is going to and
help the search engines find our Pages
easier just as I mentioned a minute ago
about internal linking when you have one
link point to another page on your
website it helps the search engines find
these Pages quicker while sitemaps do
the same thing except sitemaps are an
entire list of links on your website and
it allows the site search engines to
find all your pages in your website
fairly easily but it also helps the end
user too so if you have a big website
like Amazon has a huge website with a
lot of different products well if you're
looking for a particular product you
could do a search for it or you can look
at the site map and the site map will
list all the particular pages on the
site and so it's also good for the end
user as well so when we talk about the
end user and we talk about search
engines they're really two different
types of sitemaps you got the HTML
version which is for the end user that's
going to be nothing more than a link on
the website usually in the footer and so
when you click on that site map link
you'll get a list of all the links on
the website okay so that's an HTML site
map then we have the sitemap for the
search engines you know the spiders that
want to crawl our site so that's the XML
sitemap and an XML is just a different
format it's just a way to format all the
links on our website so the HTML site
map is HTML written in hypertext markup
language designed for the end user if
you click on it it helps the end user
navigate the website quickly because
they can find what they're looking for
and so generally that is an HTML now if
we turn our attention to the XML sitemap
that's basically designed for search
engines and thing about the search of
the XML sitemap is we work with Google
to go ahead and and submit the sitemap
to Google so Google can quickly
understand what pages on our website so
for example if if I went to a website
let's just say valleyfig.com so if I
went here and if I'm a search engine I'm
going to want to know all the URLs that
are on this website well as an end user
I can also just type in
sitemap.xml usually that's the XML file
where all the URLs are located and here
I can see all of the URLs on
valleyfic.com and so the idea behind an
XML site map is we want to communicate
that XML file to the search engines and
so Google in particular has what they
call a search console and search console
if you go to google.com webmasters so
search console as a way to communicate
with Google and one of the ways to
communicate with Google is to submit a
sitemap so we want to submit our XML
sitemap so if our XML sitemap is located
in the root directory so after our
domain valleyfig.com
sitemap.xml we know that that file is
sitting in the root directory I can go
into search console and I can submit my
sitemap and when I submit my sitemap
then I'm basically communicating with
Google telling Google hey Google instead
of trying to find all our web pages on
our website when you crawl the website
we're going to go ahead and submit the
sitemap to you so we're going to tell
you all the pages on our website and so
by doing that by submitting our
sitemap.xml file to Google it speeds up
the process because Google's able to Now
understand all the pages on our website
that have been submitted and then once
we submit those pages then Google's
going to quickly index a majority of
those pages if not all of those pages
and so that's the benefit of having an
XML sitemap for the search engines is
that we can quickly submit that file to
the search engine so our Pages get
submitted in indexed quicker so
continuing on with on-page SEO we now
turn our attention to page speed and so
page speed also known as page low time
of a particular page of a particular
website is important for SEO why is it
important because Google has millions of
users use their search engine and Google
wants their users to have a good
experience and so if Google ranks
websites based on relevancy they also
want to take into account page speed
because if a website does not load fast
or a web page doesn't load fast then it
would be detrimental for Google to rank
that page High because what's going to
happen is that page is going to get a
number of clicks and then the user
experience is not going to be that great
and so therefore it's going to have a
negative impact not only in the end user
but Google as well and so page load time
then becomes important for on-page SEO
so really when it comes to page load
time we really want to pay attention
into how long it takes our web pages to
load in terms of seconds because if a
page loads slow then chances are the
user experience is not going to be good
even from an analytics perspective
meaning if I go to Google type in a
query click on a link and then it's that
link takes me to a website where the web
page loads very slow chances are I'm not
going to spend a lot of time waiting for
that page to load I'm going to leave
that page and if I leave the page then
it's going to cause up what they call a
bounce so I'm going to bounce from the
page and that's just not good for the
entire search ecosystem and so we want
to pay close attention to page load time
because the faster a site or page loads
Google's going to recognize that and
that's going to help with ranking and so
how do we understand how our Pages load
well we can look no further than web
Analytics tool like Google analytics for
example people so if we turn our
attention to Google analytics if I go to
say valleyfig.com analytics account I
can look over the last 30 days and I can
see okay on average our page average
page load time for the entire site was
five seconds around five seconds and
ideally we want our Pages load as quick
as possible I would say the rule of
thumb on page load time is probably no
more than three to four seconds okay but
there are factors involved with page
load time so a couple of factors are the
browser that people use so some browsers
load pages differently than other
browsers the other factor involved with
browsers is the device so you could be
on a mobile device and say Internet
Explorer versus on a desktop using
Chrome and you're going to have various
Asian in terms of average page load time
so definitely browser device plays a
role but also country plays a role the
infrastructure how much bandwidth is
available so you could be in say San
Francisco United States and be on a
high-speed Network versus another city
or another country where you're not
necessarily on the same high-speed
Network you're on a lower bandwidth or
lower Network and that's going to affect
the page load time as well so in
analytics you can actually see the
breakdown of time per country and then
of course the page itself so when we
talk about average page load time for a
website we're talking about the average
for the entire site but we can actually
look at in Google analytics the average
load time for every page on the site so
ideally if you have a particular page
you want to rank organically in the
search engines and the average page load
time is not suitable or it's very high
then you want to address what the issues
are and so the great thing about Google
analytics is you actually have speed
read suggestions so if I go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics I'm
going to be able to see the average load
time for certain pages on the site and
then what Google's going to do is
actually give me some feedback so for
example I can see that the home page
loads about 5.59 seconds and so if I
click on page speed suggestions then
Google is going to give me suggestions
on how to speed up the page load time
not only on desktop but on mobile as
well so when you click on page speed
suggestions you're actually going to go
to a tool a Google tool called page
speed insights and then page speed
insights is going to allow you to see
how quick your page loads and then it's
going to be able to give you feedback on
what to do in order to speed up the page
load time not only for the page but for
the site and the great thing again is
you can see it for desktop and you can
see it from Mobile so page speed is
important we want to be able to keep our
page load Time Low no more than probably
again three to four seconds because if
it's any more than that Google's going
to take notice the other search engine
is going to take notice and they're not
going to want to rank that particular
page high on Google so some ways to
increase your page speed you always want
to optimize your images you never want
to have images that take a long time to
load you want to use a simple website
design now I know flash as an example
has long been disbanded but you don't
want to use other technology that's
really going to slow the page load time
of course where your website is hosted
does matter so the server it's hosted on
could be shared with other websites and
so that may eat into how quick the
server responds to people trying to load
your web page and so you want to keep
that in mind so server response time
does play a factor in loading and then
of course optimizing your code you want
to never have unnecessary code on your
website and when I say a necessary code
some examples could be tracking code if
you're doing any search advertising
let's just say on Facebook or Bing you
try to want to minimize the amount of
extra code you put on a site because
that code has to execute and that eats
into the page load time so you want to
be cognizant of how much code you put on
your website because that will eat into
the page load time so let's talk about
featured Snippets so featured Snippets
is the search result that generally
shows uh up at the top of the search
engine organic results so it's
informational content and you'll see it
above organic results but you'll also
see it below search advertising and so
some of the common featured Snippets you
may see are in the form of a paragraph a
table or or a list and so paragraph
Snippets tend to be the most popular and
let me show you an example of a featured
snippet so if I go to say google.com and
type in machine learning here you can
see some paid search ads okay and why do
I know they're paid search ads because I
can see ad next to them but if I look
below the paid search ads but above the
organic search results I see a paragraph
feature snippet and this is nothing more
than again just some an informational
content about machine learning and
really the whole idea behind feature
Snippets is really they're just
informational and really it's
informational and and what Google likes
to do is pull content in there that
really answers a question so if your
content doesn't necessarily answer
question then you can't expect your
content to show up as a featured snippet
so the whole idea idea is with the
search engines is really Google searches
through a number of different sites to
find content that will best answer a
user's question like for example what is
machine learning okay so if we ask the
question what is machine learning we can
expect to find a feature snippet and so
really what users do a lot when they
type in a query they use prefixes like
how does or how do or how to or what is
and so those types of questions are
normally asked as part of the search
query so if you can answer those
questions then generally Google's going
to recognize that and if it's relevant
it's going to show up as a featured
snippet so the whole idea is to really
create truly high quality content so
about feature Snippets is if you have
true high quality content that answers a
question then chances are your content
may show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is you know work to create
high quality content that provides a
really good answer to really basic
question it could be anything what is
machine learning what is a fig you know
how to ride a bicycle how do i surf all
these are related questions that content
can answer and Google wants to make sure
as part of a featured snippet that they
provide content that answers that
question and not just content the best
content that does the the best job with
the most relevant information answer
that person's search query so here we
can see our three examples you have a
table format so if we want to type in
aviation jobs we can see Snippets of
information about the latest job
listings for Aviation you can see in the
middle screenshot what is machine
learning so that's our paragraph
featured snippet and then if you type in
something like building a fence it's
going to give you a list of you know
ways to go about building a fence so
these are all answers to questions the
query may not necessarily be in question
form but the snippet is there just in
case you want to know more information
about that particular query so generally
that's how featured Snippets work and
the great thing about featured Snippets
it's open to everybody the key is to
have quality content if you have quality
content that provides answers to
questions then chances are your content
can show up above organic search results
which will give you more visibility
drive a lot more traffic to your site
and quality traffic because likely it's
answering somebody's question so let's
do a a recap of everything we talked
about with on-page SEO so before we move
on off page remember on page SEO is what
we do to our website to enhance our
website to be found in the the search
engines for Relevant keywords so it's
all about relevancy and remember before
you do anything to your website you need
to start with the basics of keyword
research you need to find keywords that
are highly relevant that have volume and
low competition and so when you can
focus on your keywords and you find out
and finalize what keywords you want to
be found for then you're going to
conduct on-page seo on-page seo consists
of number of different factors some of
which we talked about today starting
with schema remember we want to have
structured data to better communicate
with the search engines what our web
pages are about then we talked about
title tags so title tags appear in
search results remember 65 characters we
want to make sure our keyword is in the
title tag followed by our brand name and
then we talked about meta descriptions
meta descriptions allow us to you know
talk specifically about what that page
is all about meta descriptions fall
under the title tag and the search
results we talked about headers H1
through H6 H1 being the biggest in the
hierarchy of headers and having an H1
tag with your keyword provides the
search engines with an identity of how
strong or how important something is on
a page it also organizes the page with
headers and subheaders and it breaks up
the content so it's easily
understandable by the end user we also
talked about alt tags so remember images
on its own are not recognized by search
engines so we want to surround those
images with all tags with words that
help the search engines identify what
that image is they also serve a purpose
in the browser if an image doesn't load
then we can actually see what the image
is all about with the alt tag we talked
about featured Snippets there are lists
okay their paragraph crafts okay they're
they're different types of Snippets and
really the whole idea again behind
Snippets is answering a question with
quality content we talked about page
speed identifying how quick our Pages
load in Google analytics so if your
pages don't load very quickly then
Google actually provides suggestions to
speed up the page load time of a
particular page and some of the culprits
that you want to look at are making sure
you have images that are good quality
but also not a lot in size you want to
make sure they're optimized you want to
look at your server response time you
want to make sure you optimize code so
there's a lot of different factors of
page load time you just want to keep an
eye on what pages are are not loading
quick enough and remember we want to
keep it as low as possible but no more
than three to four seconds we talked
about internal linking internal linking
to a particular page from one page to
another provides LinkedIn is and Link
juice is nothing more than an indicator
for the search engines to identify what
pages tend to be more important than
another based on the number of links
pointing to that page and then we also
talked about site Maps so we talked
about the two types of sitemaps HTML and
XML htmls for the end user XML is
primarily for the search engines XML
generally is going to be a file called
sitemap.xml and we could take that XML
file and submit it to Google search
console and so that expedites the
process of indexing your site and helps
your site not only get index faster but
will help Google understand how many
pages are on your site and then get
those pages indexed so that they can be
found so that you can generate traffic
so all these are factors with on-page
SEO that you want to address before you
move on to off-page SEO okay let's um
turn our attention to off-page SEO now
that we have covered all the essentials
for on page we still need to focus our
attention on off page remember earlier I
mentioned that SEO is a two-pronged
approach we have to focus on on-page SEO
first and then to complement our efforts
and to continue our efforts and to
continue the effort of being relevant
for certain keywords we need to do what
we call off-page SEO and those are our
actions we take that don't involve our
website directly meaning we've already
updated the title tag The Meta
description the alt tags the headers Etc
we want to do things off our website
that's going to allow Google and other
search engines to recognize that hey we
are relevant these pages are relevant
for certain keywords on our website and
so really when we talk about off-page
SEO it's really the technique of
promoting your website using link
building when we say technique of
promoting our website using link
building that means establishing links
on other websites that's what we mean by
link building and so establishing links
on other websites really enhances our
SEO efforts because it improves first
and foremost and improves The
credibility of our website so if we're
on a you know a very popular website
that is known to be reputable then
having a link pointing from that website
to ours just improves The credibility of
our own website not necessarily in the
minds of the search engine but in the
minds of the end user the other benefit
here is it increases our domain
Authority and let's take a minute to
talk about domain Authority so domain
Authority is simply just a score between
1 and 100 and so in digital marketing
even including SEO as a marketing
channel everything is measured terrible
and we want to be able to measure
everything we do digitally and so off
page SEO is measurable one of the
metrics involved with off-page SEO is
domain Authority in other words it's a
score between 1 and 100 for our domain
so how does Google how does Baidu how do
these other search engines see our
domain how authoritative is our domain
how reputable is our domain and so
having links on other websites pointing
to our domain increases our reputability
increases our Authority and so I'm going
to show you an example so if you
remember back on on-page SEO I when
we're talking about keyword research we
use a tool called Moz moz.com and I
would recommend using moz.com to measure
domain Authority so if we go to mods.com
and mods.com has a tool called link
Explorer so if you put in your domain
you using their tool link Explorer
you're going to be able to see your
domain Authority and domain Authority is
a score between 1 and 100 and basically
it's simply just scoring your website in
terms of authority how does these search
engines see your site out on the world
wide web the higher the score the better
and so recommend using mods.com link
Explorer to measure the domain Authority
so the more links we have on external
sites pointing to our own site in theory
the higher the domain Authority so we're
going to come back to moz.com quite
frequently as we talk about off-page SEO
because we need a tool to help manage
our efforts so we're going to come back
to mods.com but let's let's talk about
some of these other benefits to off-page
SEO so we know it helps with the
credibility it increases their domain
Authority but what are some of the other
intangible efforts that are also
measurable well well it increases our
referral traffic and by increasing our
referral traffic meaning if we're in a
reputable site that gets a lot of
traffic and there's a link pointing our
site then naturally we're probably going
to see traffic coming from that site and
we can measure that in tools like Google
analytics we can measure referral
traffic and so that's that inherent
benefit to doing off-page SEO because
we're trying to create the relevancy of
our own website we're trying to be found
for Relevant keywords but yet at the
same time we can increase traffic to our
website and then certainly not lost in
all this is improving our page ranks so
the idea here is you need on page and
off-page SEO to work together to improve
our rankings and improving our rankings
in the search engine results will
inherently increase our rankings and
drive traffic to the site from search
engines and that's ideally what we're
trying to do we're trying to accomplish
traffic from search engines by improving
our rankings but at the same time we
improve our credibility and we crew
improve our standing in the search
engine world and we also increase
traffic to our site from all these other
websites and so there are a lot of
benefits to off-page SEO
um it's just let's talk a little bit
more about some of these other benefits
because according to a backlinko a web
page with more backlinks is going to
rank higher than a page with fewer
backlinks but let me just say this with
back linking especially from sites it's
all about credibility it's all about
quality over quantity so we want to pay
attention to quality over quantity so
let's harken back to moz.com and here we
could see we have a domain authority of
35 but we have a lot of links inbound
links from other websites pointing to
our website we have
575 domains out there on the internet
pointing to our domain valleyfig.com and
so if we want to take a specific look at
these domains we can just simply click
on linking domains and here we can see
all the different domains pointing to
our website now again it's about quality
not quantity so if we look at the Domain
Authority and that's the score that
measures the credibility of a website we
could see the domain Authority on some
of these domains like npr.org has a
domain authority of 93 and so to me that
helps boost the domain Authority for our
own website our own domain it also has
the chance of driving that traffic it
also increases the credibility but in
the end having quality links from other
quality domains is going to increase our
own rank on search engines and that's
the whole idea behind it so we could
actually see that we have quality
websites and quality domains linking to
our domain now you can also use another
tool I mentioned this earlier with
on-page SEO when I was talking about
sitemaps so if you go to search console
so that's a Google tool we can also look
at a link report and see what other
websites are linking to us so this is
Google's way of communicating to us what
websites are out there linking to us and
so here I could see the top linking
sites to our website valleyfig.com is
the crumby kitchen has
1443 links pointing back to our site
cookscountry.com Whole Foods magazine
mine perfect kitchen these are all Sites
with links pointing back to our site so
search console is a good tool it's a
good alternative tool especially the
links report is a good alternative tool
to get an idea of the types of sites
that are linking to your site now what
you're missing here in search console is
the domain Authority but you can use the
link Explorer tool in moz.com to measure
the domain Authority for any domain it's
just a matter of going to the tool
itself going by going to moz.com by
going to the link Explorer report and
just typing in the domain and from there
you'll be able to see the domain
Authority so it's all about quality over
quantity I can't stress that enough so
when it comes to off page really it's
Anonymous with link building so it's the
most effective method for off-page SEO
and it's simply just getting links from
other websites to your own so it's not
as easy as it sounds especially when
we're talking about quality over
quantity but building these links to our
website will help our rankings and
that's the whole idea behind off-page
SEO we want to be able to link from
other websites to ours so that we can
help our rankings in addition to some of
the other benefits I just mentioned so
Google recognizes backlinks as one of
their top ranking factors so in addition
to some of the on-page SEO tactics that
I mentioned earlier including title tag
and meta description and URL structure
and headers all those are important but
at the same time it's a balance so
Google wants to know hey yes we
understand you've optimized your title
tag for keyword but how does the rest of
the internet see your website are is
your website worthy enough to add a link
from a particular quality website to
your website so if there are a number of
quality links then your site must be of
quality as well and so that's the whole
idea behind link building being an
important factor because again it's
about from a Google's perspective it's
about the user experience they want to
make sure that sites ranked on page one
of Google are quality sites quality
sites that load well that have good
content that have fresh content not just
sites that have a gazillion links
pointing to them with you know keywords
stuffed into the title tag so it's an
ecosystem Google's and other search
engines want to protect that ecosystem
with quality so that's why link building
is an important factor and so there are
different types of links so when you
have a link pointing from one website to
your own okay the link could be a follow
link or no follow link and the whole
idea behind follow or no follow is
simply hey we know that Google and other
search engines they're spidering the
entire Web the whole idea is for them to
collect as many pages as they these
search engines can bring them back to
their servers so they can serve them up
in their search engines well as Google
and these other search engines spider
these sites they're following what
they're doing is they're following links
it's as simple as it gets they're
following links from one link to another
so remember we talked about internal
links earlier on on-page SEO internal
links are just links on your web pages
pointing to other pages on your own
website well when it comes to external
links so links pointing from one website
to your website that website that's
linking to your website has an
opportunity to say hey Google you can
follow this link or don't follow the
link and so if they choose to not follow
the link meaning they put a nofollow tag
into the anchor text then Google's going
to follow the link but not recognize the
link itself and what I mean by that is
hey if you have let's just use Valley
fig has a link from Wikipedia if
Wikipedia has a link pointing to
valleyfig.com but the link itself is no
follow then what Google is going to do
is not recognize the link itself they're
not going to recognize the link so
therefore you're not going to get credit
or link juice as we say you're not going
to get any juice from Wikipedia to
Valley Pig but if it is a follow link
then what Google's going to do is
recognize the link and give you credit
for the backlink and by giving you
credit for the backlink that's going to
inherently increase your domain
Authority it's also going to likely
increase your rankings so you want to
pay attention to the types of Link
building that's out there no follow and
so anytime you try to establish a link
on an external website just make sure
it's a follow make sure it's not a no
follow because if it's a no follow link
then you're not going to get the credit
from the search engines and so the whole
idea behind link building in terms of
SEO is to get some credit from a quality
website to your website and so if we
look here a follow Link in this example
is one where the href or the link itself
doesn't have a no follow in it but if a
hyperlink does have a nofollow in it
then that means you're not going to get
the credit for the backlink so remember
no follows they don't allow search
engine crawlers to follow the link so if
that's the case it's not going to pass
any link juice when you don't pass quote
unquote link juice you're not going to
get credit for the backwink and so if
you don't get credit for the back length
then if we go back to our tools that we
have available for measuring off page
SEO so if I go back to let's just say
Moz or even let's just say search
console you know I'll be able to see all
these links here these links that are
showing up are follow links why because
Google's recognizing the link if they
were nofollow then we wouldn't see the
link in here so that's something to keep
in mind as well and so just keep in mind
if it is a no file you'll see C in the
hypertext itself the nofollow tag and
you can always check that the HTML of
any particular link and so when we talk
about link building we talk about
off-page SEO really we're talking about
how to get links on quality websites and
how do we do that well I've listed here
a few ways to do that so you could do
guest blogging or blogging in general is
a good off-page SEO slash link building
strategy and I'll talk about more of
that in a minute but we can list our
websites in reputable and trustworthy
directories I mentioned Wikipedia as an
example even though Wikipedia may not be
classified as a directory but there are
other directories out there you could
ask for testimonials so if you're
working with clients or other websites
you could ask for testimonial or they
can provide a link pointing back from
their site to your site it's about
relationships really is what it comes
down to it's relationship bill building
and that's what a link is relationship
building or you could do content on
social media so these are just examples
of ways to generate links but let's go
back to the blogging part because
blogging to me is an essential part to
off-page SEO and why is that because
anytime you are part of a Blog you're
generating content and not only are you
generating content you're generating
fresh content that's likely to be
interesting to the end user and with
that content yes you can optimize that
content but the beauty about blogging is
really anybody can do it but if we want
to connect blogging with relationships
if we're a food blogger then we can
write on other food blogs as a guest
writer and we can have that blog post
linked back to our own blog as an
example or we can have other bloggers in
the same industry write a guest blog for
us on their own blog and point their
link back to our site blogging creates a
lot of opportunities for link building
because again it's a fresh canvas with
interesting content and when you have
interesting content then the opportunity
for backlinking is going to be there
because if you're writing about
something that's interesting the natural
you're going to want to link to
something else related to that that's
interesting and so that's the
opportunity that blogging creates so
again it's vital to get links from
authoritative web pages then multiple
links from low quality web pages so
going back to the link Explorer report
we want to be able to pay attention to
those domain authorities or those
websites with low domain Authority and
really you should pay attention to
really quality sites okay you want to
pay attention to Quality sites and so
when we talk about links there's inbound
links there's outbound links we're
interested in those inbound links we're
interested in getting links from high
quality websites pointing to our own
website and again that could be in the
form of a Blog it could be social media
it could be a partner site okay these
are all inbound links they just need to
be followed make sure they're not a no
follow so it's simple just getting an
external link that's a follow to your to
your own website and so the one thing I
want to mention here though on inbound
links from external websites and that's
making sure that not necessarily every
inbound link points to the home page we
want to be able to have links point to
internal pages so let's harken back to
search console as an example so search
console our links report shows us links
pointing from external websites to our
own website but what are those linked
pages so if we look at some of those
linked Pages here we can see the top
link Pages we could see on valleyfig.com
recipes is the topped link page then the
home page then the about us then slash
International so we want to make sure
that if we're trying to generate
backlinks from external websites to our
own website we want to make sure that
they're pointing to Interior Pages not
necessarily the home page and why do I
say that because one of the benefits to
link building an off-page SEO is ranking
so the whole idea about ranking is to
get some of our other Pages ranked not
necessarily the home page the home page
is just a doorway into your website if
we have interesting content out there on
the web and it's a food blogger as an
example and they're talking about a
particular food item well they're going
to want to link to a page that's related
to what they're blogging about that
particular food item they don't want to
link to the home page the home page is
just a doorway and so that's the whole
idea behind link building we want to
link to multiple pages on the site why
is that because if I tell take this
particular page valleyfig.com recipes
and I just put that into Moz and I look
at the link Explorer report for this
particular page the domain Authority is
still going to be the same 35 that's
what valleyfig.com is 35 however there's
also another metric called page
Authority so page Authority is likewise
with the domain authorities to score
between 1 and 100 and so the more
external links pointing to an internal
page with high domain Authority that's
likely going to increase the page
authority of that page so in other words
if we have good links from other
websites pointing to that page then it's
going to increase the page Authority for
that page and ultimately the domain
Authority for that page and so just like
the domain Authority in this case Valley
fig every page under the domain has a
page Authority score so the higher the
score the likelihood that that page is
going to rank in the search engine
results okay so that's the whole idea
behind link building is we want to
improve the authority of the pages not
just the domain but also more
importantly we also want to keep the end
user in mind so if it's from a blog or
social media the link pointing from that
blog or social media platform should
naturally point to something related to
what you're talking about not just the
home page because again the home page
more or less is the Gateway into the
website so we want to get people to
where they want to go we want to
naturally create a link from good
content to some other good content so
that's the whole idea behind backlinking
so outbound links will direct a user
from our own website to another website
so the idea here is it's okay to have
outbound links on your own website it's
a natural ecosystem of the World Wide
Web okay what I would recommend here is
not to have so many in a Century Located
place for example don't have one page
when nothing but external links on it
you know sprinkle these external links
these outbound links throughout your
website but also in if it's not a
reciprocal link meaning if a guest
blogger is not linking to your website
but you're just linking to theirs and
they didn't ask you to then maybe
consider a nofollow tag maybe you know
ideally you want to make sure that these
links are just natural in nature so
don't just have a habit of putting
outbound links because the whole idea
behind outbound links is you want to
keep people on your website but if it's
a natural link going from one content to
another and you think the end user is
going to benefit then no problem but
just don't get in the habit of putting
external links on your website because
that means that hey that user that's on
your website May click on that link and
leave your website and not come back so
keep that in mind as well because you
don't necessarily benefit from an SEO
perspective by having outbound links on
your own website you want to do it as a
courtesy if somebody else is linking to
you you want to do it for the end user
if you feel the benefit from additional
content on other website but from an SEO
perspective it doesn't necessarily
directly enhance your own website in
terms of ranking turn our attention to
duplicate content so a lot of us have
websites with a lot of content sometimes
we go ahead and take our website and
revise it create a new one or register a
new domain and put content on that new
domain and so we may find ourselves in a
situation at one point or the other
where we have two websites with the same
content or could be the same website
with a lot of content but some of that
may be duplicate as well so we want to
try and stay away from duplicate content
but for some of us we may stumble across
it accidentally we may find ourselves
having content that's duplicated and so
we want to try and prevent that because
that's a No-No in the world of SEO so if
we have duplicate content appearing in
more than one an URL there are ways to
rectify not having the search engines
recognize the content twice so some
examples of duplicate content are for
example a spammer takes an article and
posts the same content on his website or
like I mentioned before you create
another website or register another
domain and have that particular content
on the old website still or you're
writing a blog post and you tag it or
categorize it and the content shows up
under the tags under the categories and
just shows up in general so there are a
lot of scenarios where you can find
yourselves with duplicate content and so
we want to rectify that we don't want
duplicate content we want the search
engines to recognize the original source
of the content and so basically if you
have two versions of a web page you may
result in duplicate content issues
another example that would be for
example if you have products you may
find that that same product may be under
two different categories so how do we
Rectify that well there are a number of
different ways and so the simple way is
what they call a 301 redirect to the
original URL so if you find yourself in
a situation where you have a new website
with the same content you could simply
set up a redirect and we call it a 301
redirect because 301 refers to permanent
so it's signifying to the search engines
that you're permanently moving from this
page to this page the other way is
through a canonical attribute and so the
word canonical may not register with
some of you so let's just uh take a
minute to talk about what a canonical is
like basically a canonical tag it's a
page level meta tag so remember that
meta tag description we talked about an
on-page SEO well think about this as
another type of meta tag and it's placed
in that HTML header of your web page so
basically all it does is by placing this
meta tag it tells the search engines
which URL is the original version to be
displayed in index so it's the purpose
of a canonical is to keep the duplicate
content out of the search engine index
so we want to consolidate our page rank
our page Authority our domain Authority
all to original content that's the whole
idea of having a canonical and it's a
quick solution so all you need to do is
add a canonical tag to the header so let
me show you an example if you have a
site let's just use CNN as an example
CNN.com has a lot of content sometimes
given the breadth of content that they
have they may run into duplicate content
so they simply just put a canonical tag
into their their header and so by doing
that they're able to tell the search
engines hey this page this domain is is
the original if you find yourself with
multiple sites well you can also use
Google search console so remember we use
Google search console in earlier
examples when we talked about links to
your site or we talked about that site
map on page SEO well if we go into
search console we could basically say
look Google because search console is a
Google tool we want to confirm that this
is our domain so this is the domain you
should be focusing on so you can
leverage search console to communicate
with Google regarding which site is
important which is the one that should
get indexed you can use a canonical you
can put that on any page of your website
or you can set up a three one redirect
so those are the ways to fix duplicate
content issues 301s are the easiest
canonicals tend to be temporary because
they're just the page level and then
search console is a a good method
because it communicates with Google
directly and it allow allows Google to
crawl various web pages differently than
if you didn't tell them okay so if you
didn't tell them they're just going to
grab anything they can so by
communicating via the Google search
console tool it allows you to tell
Google this is the domain I want to
focus in on so let's talk then now about
how the Google algorithms work so we'll
shift gears here and we'll talk about
how these algorithms work on Google so
Google uses advanced concepts retrieve
data so what they do is they're
spidering they're spidering they're
collecting web pages and they're taking
all these web pages back to their server
and anytime somebody does a query
they're delivering those web pages
within milliseconds they're delivering
results based on your query so that's in
general how it works so it uses a
combination of different algorithms to
deliver the best results they want the
best results and so some of the most
popular algorithms below are Google
Panda Google pay penguin and Google rank
brain so these are all things that
Google has done to make sure that
they're constantly tweaking their search
engines to deliver the best results so
let's talk about some of these these
popular algorithms and before we talk
about these popular algorithms let's
just make one thing clear that Google's
always tweaking their algorithms on
their search engine and so if you want
to get an idea how often they do it well
they do it every day they're constantly
tweaking it but they what they do is
they release major changes to their
algorithm a few times a year so if you
want to get a sense of what those
changes look like well you could go to
moz.com and you can go to Google Dash
algorithm Dash change and you can see
here that hey Google changes its search
algorithm around 500 to 600 times while
most of these are minor Google again
rolls out major changes like panda like
penguin that affects search results in
significant ways so you can go here and
you can go all the way back to 2000 and
see some of the algorithm changes that
have occurred over the last few years
and you can see here the last major one
was done in August of 2018 that was the
Medicore update so they're constantly
making changes to their search engine to
deliver a more concise more better
ecosystem for the end user so if it's a
better search engine for the end user
end users are going to come back so the
whole idea is continuing to tweak the
system that the algorithms to better
show more accurate results and so let's
take a look at some of the the major
algorithm changes that they've done in
the past so the first is we'll talk
about Google Panda and Panda was an
algorithm released back in 2011. so here
we are in 2019 is a few years ago but
still significant in that really this
algorithm emphasized high quality
content because before Panda there was a
there's just a lot of content out there
on the internet and there was a lot of
spam content there are a lot of
duplicate content and so really the idea
behind panda is for Google to really
deliver in their search engine results
Pages high quality content so what it
did was it removed web pages that had
low quality or duplicate content so that
was the whole idea behind you know the
algorithm nickname Panda it removed low
quality and duplicate content and that
kind of cleaned things up a bit where if
you did a search query now you'd
actually see better better results and
one thing about panda is because there's
so much quality because Google's
indexing so much there on the internet
that it's constantly being updated it's
updated regularly so the next one we're
going to talk about is Google penguin so
penguin was released after Panda and
what that focused in on was low quality
lengths so remember we talked about link
building we talked about quality links
over quantity so naturally you're going
to have links naturally from all
websites whether that be high quality or
low quality the whole idea behind this
algorithm is to sever the links that are
low quality and so the idea behind that
was they focused on two areas so they
focused in on Links games and keyword
stuffing so that's what penguin focused
on was Lynx games were basically link
almost link farming where you produced
Mass amounts of backlinks and not all of
them were good quality they weren't
natural links links should be natural
from one high quality site or blog to
another high quality cider blog and by
creating lengths games you've created an
ecosystem where links just went to
irrelevant event low quality spam
related pages and so Google's Penguins
algorithm update focused in on that
effort to remove or combat pages that
had poor links from being indexed in
their search engine results and then
they also combated keyword stuffing
keyword stuffing is nothing more than
taking your targeted keyword and
stuffing it into the content of your
page or title tag your meta description
so any sites that were caught up doing
that basically suffer the consequences
because what penguin did was take care
of sites that basically were accused of
keyword stuffing or had characteristics
of keyword stuffing and they removed
sites that had a lot of links pointing
to it from poor quality sites and vice
versa sites that really had a lot of
external links pointing to other poor
quality sites so that's what penguin did
they took a look at those two areas and
so we talk about link schemes again
penguins aim was to decrease the ranking
of web pages that created artificially
by using black hat techniques and
basically what I mean by black hat
techniques that artificially creating
length that just didn't make sense just
for the sake of getting the backlink
just for the sake of passing link juice
and so that's what a link scheme is or
was and so Google basically tweaked
their algorithm to combat those poor
link schemes and so keyword stuffing as
I mentioned a minute ago it's just
repetitive usage of the same keyword and
that just basically suffers the content
is the thing that suffers here and when
the content suffers the end users suffer
so Google is all about quality content
and when you have quality content and
that quality contents indexed and users
find what they're looking for chances
are they're going to go back to the
search engine to continue to find what
they're looking for with the end result
being presented with quality content so
keyword stuffing really dilutes the
quality of the content and then let's
talk about the third algorithm which is
rank brain so rank brain is a processing
algorithm that uses machine learning and
what that does that machine learning
interprets search queries that users
search on Google so for example if
rankbrain sees a word or phrase it isn't
familiar with basically the machine can
make a guess as to what words or phrases
might have a similar meaning and filter
the result accordingly so basically take
these search engine queries and present
them in a way that's logical so that the
end result can be something that's
relevant to what you're looking for and
so for example if you're searching for
online marketing you will get results
related for digital marketing on search
engine room Pages why because rankbrain
will interpret that particular keyword
and they're trying to basically match
based on all the data they collected
what words or phrases might have a
similar meaning so online marketing
digital marketing have similar meanings
now that we've talked about some of the
different algorithm changes that Google
has made over the years and continues to
make let's um segue into the types of
SEO and so when we talk about the types
of SEO we're really talking about doing
what's right what's expected versus
doing something that you know is trying
to cheat the system and so you may hear
the terminology black cat SEO white hat
SEO or gray hat SEO and so the whole
idea behind these terminologies is that
hey what are we supposed to be doing
here in terms of following best
practices in order to get our Pages
ranked on the search engines for the
keyword queries we covet and so let's
talk about what not to do first and
that's always black cat techniques so I
just mentioned a minute ago with Panda
and Penguin algorithm updates you know
penguin took into account account you
know Links games poor linking techniques
keyword stuffing so those are considered
black hat techniques so black cat is a
technique used to improve page Rank by
violating search engine rules and
policies so it's clearly Google's made a
clear Line in the Sand they don't like
link schemes they don't like keyword
stuffing so if you take into account
this practices then you're practicing
black hat techniques to treat this cheat
the system to try and rank faster and so
some other ways of black cat or you know
redirecting or phishing having duplicate
content all these are are things that
are frowned upon by search engines so
the result of not only algorithm changes
is you could get your website
blacklisted from the search engines if
you are caught in violation of their
policies it's pretty clear-cut so that's
why the algorithms are in place the
algorithms try and create a system an
environment where you know good quality
content is shown so if your keyword
stuffy and you're creating lots of
duplicate content that's not an
inherence with you know Google's
policies for creating good quality
content and as a result you could get
blacklisted so with black hat techniques
you run the risk of being penalized and
you don't want to be penalized by the
search engines so white hat contrarily
used to improve search engine rankings
by following those rules and policies so
in effect it's everything we talked
about today from on-page SEO to off-page
SEO doing the right thing with your
content in terms of organizing the
structure with headers creating very
clear and concise meta descriptions
submitting a site map all of those are
white hat techniques addressing page
load time using really relevant keywords
naturally in your content and creating
high quality content that's fresh and
interesting for the end user that's
white hat technique that's going to get
you ranked higher and farther and with
better benefits so gray hat is just
simply a combination of black and white
it's the practice of improving by
following the policies but they
considered you know ethically dubious
and so what I mean by that is listen you
you don't want to purchase links you
want links to come across naturally you
don't want to do excessive internal
linking you don't want to have a lot of
links pointing to one page it's not
natural so you want to be able to do
things that are natural you don't want
to just take content from Another Side
and claim it as your own so you want to
do things that are natural that's going
to create a good experience for the user
because if it's for the end user which
it is then generally it's going to be
good for the search engines and so let's
talk about website architecture now so
basically when I say website
architecture what I mean is we want to
give the search engines an idea of how
our websites built so website
architecture and the structure of
websites important and so every website
has a hierarchy it starts with the home
page the home page is the top page it's
the the domain it's where most people go
to find other pages of your website and
so generally you're going to have a
scenario where you're going to have a
home page with you know if you sell
products multiple categories and in
those categories you can have multiple
products so the generally that's how a
web architecture flows it flows from top
down and the reason for having a good
website architecture is internal links
are spread equally so you want to make
sure again not to apply a black hat
method or a gray hat method of pointing
all links to one page you want links
naturally to spread throughout your
website because not just from an SEO
benefit but from an end user perspective
you want users to flow through your
website naturally so if you're planning
on developing websites from an SEO
perspective you know take these things
into consideration so we want to take
into account the site architecture
navigation we want to take into account
the URL remember we talked about URL
structure and on-page SEO the rule of
thumb is if you can read it the search
engines will read it so we want to keep
it clear and concise and relevant to the
content of that page when we talk about
responsive design we're talking about
multiple devices so you don't build a
website just for desktop especially when
mobile is being used by a majority of
the users around the world so you want
to build a website that's both desktop
friendly and mobile friendly we also
want to take into account A robot's text
file and a robot's text file is simply
just a text file that allows the search
engines to index certain pages it tells
them what not to index and so you can
always find the robot's text file
normally if you go to a website and
let's just say we go to valleyfig.com
and then we type in robot or robots.txt
file here we can see if I type in robots
dot text file here this basically is a
file a text file that's in the root
directory and it simply just gives the
search engines an idea of what they're
allowed to index and what they're not
allowed to index anything with a
disallow means hey search engines please
don't index these pages so that's what a
robot's text file does and every site
should have it because there's some
pages on your website then you
inherently don't want the search engines
to index and you want to optimize for
the Crawlers so that means that making
sure that your pages are available and
that means also submitting a sitemap
remember we submit our site map via the
Google search console so good site
architecture not only makes content easy
to find time but also helps to gain
traffic because hey if your site is easy
it's well organized it's built multiple
devices the URLs are easy then all
that's going to be appearance to the
search engines and when it's apparent to
the search engines it's going to get
indexed I want to get indexed then
you're going to get found and you're
going to get the traffic so it's just a
natural progression it's best practice
so some important features of good
architecture are again that URL
structured code your site navigation and
CSS or HTML make it easy for the search
engines to follow build a comprehensive
structure for an internal linking
meaning they should be natural internal
links if a page is relevant to another
page then create an internal link if you
have a very big website with a lot of
content or a lot of products then create
a breadcrumb navigation okay so we're
maybe familiar with that on Amazon as an
example
amazon.com has a lot of products and if
you're navigating from one product to
another in one directory or one category
to another category then Amazon creates
what they call breadcrumbs to help you
navigate back to where you were quickly
so these are all good best practices for
good side architecture good side
architecture equals search engine
results so responsive design helps to
make your website mobile friendly it
will increase the amount of time the
user spends on your website which may
improve site ranking so let's talk a
second about mobile friendliness so if I
go back to Google search console there
happens to be inserts console a mobile
usability report and so if I click on
that report basically what it's going to
show me is pages that are do not follow
Google's best practices so some of
Google's best practices are making sure
that the text is easy to read that
clickable elements aren't necessarily
close to one another and the viewport is
set to the appropriate device meaning
the screen is set to the appropriate
device okay and so basically if we are
found in violation then the page is
affected are going to get flagged by
Google and if the page is affected or
flagged by Google then those pages won't
get indexed and so we want to keep an
eye on the mobile usability report in
Google search console so remember it's
better to have a good site architecture
that Bots can easily index so Bots will
give preference to web pages with
relevant content and in the end it will
help your website rank better and as a
side note always use a site map to make
it easy for the Bots to crawl your
website so we covered that and on page
as a reminder if I go back to search
console and if I click on sitemaps I can
go ahead and submit my sitemap so if I
created an XML version of my sitemap app
called sitemap.xml and I submit that
basically what I'm doing is I'm saying
Hey Google here's my sitemap file and in
that sitemap file are all the pages on
my website that want to get indexed and
when you submit your sitemap to Google
basically they're going to discover
those URLs and index those URLs in their
search index and that expedites the
process of getting indexed it expedites
the process of getting found on search
and it expedites the process of getting
clicks on your search results pages on
and having that traffic go to your
website where they can enjoy the user
experience and convert and remember the
robots text file is there to allow
Google and other search engines to know
what pages to crawl so good website
architecture like for example Amazon
they use breadcrumbs they have a
hierarchy in terms of of categories okay
so you can see how it's evenly dispersed
on the left side on the right side of
poor website architecture is very
slanted in One Direction a lot of
internal links no bread crumbs the
navigation isn't very clear so we want
to make sure things are simple and easy
so let's turn our attention to local SEO
so local SEO is for those businesses who
focus on a specific Market it could be a
whole state like the State of Florida in
the United States it could be a specific
City in a particular State like Orlando
Florida or Miami it really depends on
the business and who you are trying to
attract and what geolocation you are
trying to attract so if you're trying to
attract a segment of audience in a
specific location then local seos should
be in your sites for optimization and so
when we talk about local SEO we're
really talking about optimizing your
website to get traffic from a specific
location so that's what local SEO is and
the idea behind local SEO is to put your
particular service or product or
whatever it is you're offering to that
particular Geo Market that particular
Locale or that City or that state so you
want to put yourself in front of the
Right audience that's the whole idea
behind local SEO and so if we focus it
on Google you know local results are
based on three factors and this is
according to Google so it's based on
relevancy so if somebody's looking for a
plumber and you happen to be a plumber
in that particular Locale or city or zip
code then chances of you getting found
are going to be great because of
relevancy and then distance so where
that person's located based on your
address or where you're located has a
role and how you display on local SEO
and then prominence so prominence is
also very important because you know how
prominent are you as a business are you
getting a lot of reviews do you have a
lot of different locations do you have
all your photos and all your information
posted so prominence does play a bit of
factor along with distance along with
relevancy on Google local SEO so these
factors combine to help find the best
match for your search just somebody
typing in that plumber or say that
Italian restaurant or any particular
product or service is going to find
local results and you want to be there
to to meet that person when they're
looking for your product or service so
that's the whole idea behind local SEO
and so one of the factors with local SEO
is having consistent nap or nap and so
what is an IP it's really name address
and phone number so it sounds very
simple and it it is simple you just have
to be consistent so if you have a local
SEO presence on say Bing search engine
you want to make sure that the name
address and phone number are can also
the same name and address and phone
number on Google so it's just about
consistency so that's what we want to do
we want to make sure that we're
consistent across the board because it's
important for companies that want to
link well have some consistency and it's
important too when we talk about
consistency to actually have that
information you need obviously the name
of your company you obviously need a
phone number and you need to put your
address in there but really of all three
the phone number is just as important
because we talk about local SEO we
mentioned mobile earlier we know that a
lot of people initiate their search on
mobile and so if they're looking for
local restaurant or local cafe or that
plumber and you appear in local SEO then
your phone number is going to appear
with the results and that gives an
opportunity for some money to go ahead
and just click on that number to call it
just makes it that much easier for
somebody to get in touch with you so
consistency and having all your
information are important factors for
local SEO so having an inconsistent nap
if you will is not going to bode well
for you on the local SEO results okay
it's important because it offers up
legitimate legitimacy it offers uh
better rankings and at the end of the
day it's going to help you get those
calls it's going to help you get traffic
to your website so for example if a
particular company that sells Puma
running shoes has yellowpages.com
listing we want to be consistent if it's
on yellowpages.com and this is their
address on their website then you need
to be consistent with that if it's
inconsistent and we're talking about
very minor details but these Minor
Details are important simply just put in
Rd as Road and then spelling out Road is
going to cause some inconsistency so
consistency is very important why
because local SEO is also tied to
mapping you know Google Maps and so
Google wants to see consistency so that
they can offer up the address and the
mapping services so that's one good
reason why it needs to be consistent
another reason is again you know
somebody may want to uh drive to your
location or call your location or see if
that location is close to them so that's
why consistency is such a key component
to local SEO so in order to get started
on Google for local SEO what you want to
do is you want to just do a search for
Google my business so Google my business
is the platform in which you're going to
set up your local business and once you
set up your Google my business account
whatever that account is you want to
make sure you have all the credible
information in there I can't stress that
enough you need to have that phone
number you need to have that address it
needs to be consistent but with Google
my business there's a lot of things you
can do here so you can manage reviews so
if you do have a location you can go
ahead and manage those reviews that
somebody puts in for your business and
so if it's a negative review you
definitely want to respond to that
negative review if it's a positive
review you definitely want to respond to
that positive review so you can manage
reviews you can upload photos so photos
is a big component as we talked about
with all tags and images you know having
these images help appear in the local
SEO results you can manage a lot of
other things your information you can
manage posts you can offer promotions
there's a lot of things you could do you
could set your business hours so the
more information you put in to Google my
business the more information is going
to can be conveyed to the end user
looking for your products and services
in Google my business even goes as far
as offering up the opportunity to have a
website so if you're a business that
doesn't even have your own website you
can create a website writing Google my
business and so the end result is this
if somebody's looking for let's just say
lice removal and Orlando let's just say
your child comes home from school with
some lice you need services that offer
up lice removal well you're going to be
able to see businesses listed in the
Atlanta region that offer up the service
you're looking for and if you're on a
mobile phone you can go ahead and
quickly you know call that person you
can go to the website you look at your
reviews so local SEO is a very important
to local businesses very important and
so you want to make sure you have
consistent presence not just on Google
but on Bing and some of these other
local platforms like yellowpages.com for
example so being prominent across
multiple platforms is going to put
yourself in front of the Right audience
who's looking for your products and
services let's talk about how to measure
your SEO performance so all that hard
work you've done with on-page SEO
coupled with all the work you've done
with off-page SEO are eventually going
to net results and positive results and
we want to be able to measure that as
you're actually doing the work as you're
putting forth the effort on on page and
off page and so we want to be able to
measure that and so you want to be able
to understand what to measure and where
to measure it and so when we talk about
SEO we really want to hone in on three
high level core metrics and that's
ranking traffic and conversion so when
we talk about ranking traffic and
conversion we can break that down into
this list here what kind of traffic are
we getting from organic search what kind
of traffic are we getting from mobile
devices remember mobile is very
important because as we talked about
with on page SEO as we talk about with
local SEO a lot of searches start with
mobile devices we want to look at
keyword ranking remember keyword
research is the first step in the SEO
process even before we do any work with
on-page and off page you know we want to
look at the local visibility if we have
local SEO results we want to look at
engagement metrics so all that traffic
we're driving from organic search we
want to be able to measure how they're
performing and behaving on our website
we also want to measure some form of
progress on off-page SEO and that's in
the form of backlinks so all of these
are different metrics we can measure
using different tools so let's talk
about how to go about looking at these
metrics and where to go look at them and
measure them and so really monitoring
all this Behavior will help us
understand how we're performing how SEO
is performing and so really what we want
to do is start with Organic traffic and
so we can look at that on a
month-to-month basis we can look at it
from a geographic perspective we can
look at it in terms of how many new
visitors we're driving versus returning
and then again more importantly
conversion rate and so to me the best
place to start to look at that traffic
from organic search is Google analytics
and Google analytics is a free tool it's
simply there to measure website
performance so if you go into Google
analytics we can actually go in and we
can look at all sorts of data based on
website behavior and so if I'm in Google
analytics and I go under acquisition and
then I go under all traffic channels
over a given period of time let's just
say the last seven days for a particular
website I can see what traffic is coming
from organic search and then I could see
the amount of new users that are coming
from we're going to search I can also
see engagement metrics bounce rate for
example so I want to be able to see if
somebody's typing in a query clicking on
our Link in the organic search results
and then coming to our website are they
actually engaging with our website or
are they leaving the website after only
visiting the page they landed on so
that's all and these are all important
metrics to measure and I can measure all
that right here in Google analytics if I
wanted to I can even take it a step
further and break that down by country
so if I type in country as a secondary
Dimension now I can see what country is
driving traffic from organic search so a
lot of your organic traffic information
is going to be centrally located in
Google analytics so we also talked about
Mobile Traffic a majority of searches
take place on mobile phones versus
desktop so Google basically is reporting
the nearly 60 percent of searches now
appear from mobile devices and so if we
go back to Google analytics and we can
also look at a mobile report so if I go
in Google analytics under audience under
mobile overview I can see a breakdown of
the amount of traffic coming from
desktop versus tablet versus mobile and
so you'll find as time goes on that your
mobile device is likely going to drive a
majority of the traffic from organic
search and so you can compare device
information with channel so if I just
type in Channel and Google analytics as
a secondary Dimension and look at the
default Channel groupings versus device
category I could see that you know
mobile from organic search driven
traffic over the last seven days this is
something you want to keep an eye on
because a lot of people tend to begin
their searches on mobile devices so
mobile ranking is different than desktop
ranking because because with mobile
ranking it's based on a responsive
website and with that responsive website
basically response of being that the
website's going to adapt to the mobile
device so it's going to respond to the
device that somebody's on and so
therefore the metrics or the engagement
metrics are going to be different but if
I look back to Google analytics I can
see again bounce rate I can see pages
per session average session duration so
if I look at line three I could see all
the different engagement metrics
compared to those metrics from other
devices and other channels okay so you
want to be able to do a comparison
because if behavior is not up to par
engagement is not the par on mobile then
you want to do something about that so
you want to hone in on Mobile Traffic
specifically from organic search because
the behavior is going to be different
you know people start their searches on
mobile well the site's going to be
different and so therefore it's a
different experience altogether so make
sure you track the behavior and more
importantly make sure you track that
page speed so earlier we talked about
on-page SEO when we honed in on page
speed so just as a reminder if I'm back
in analytics and I go back under
Behavior then if I go to site speed then
if I go to overview I'll be able to see
the average page load time on my website
I can also look at specific page timings
and I should be able to see that by
device so if I type in device category
I'll just be able to see how each page
loads per device and so this allow me to
understand which pages are loading fast
which pages are not loading as fast and
address those pages accordingly to
improve engagement metrics so we want to
keep an eye on page speed as well as
overall user behavior from mobile
devices you can also use other tools
that are out there like agency analytics
there are plenty of tools out there I
tend to use Google analytics because
primarily it's free and Google analytics
is a Google product so it works with
other Google platforms like Google
search console we want to keep an eye on
ranking so remember when we do our
keyword research we're choosing keywords
that have high relevancy high volume and
low competition so we want to be able to
track keywords that we choose that have
high relevancy high volume and low
competition and so the tool we use or at
least I recommend using is Moz so I
mentioned Moz earlier with on-page and
off-page SEO so if we go into Moz and we
know what keywords we're trying to rank
for we can go ahead and add the Namaz
and what Moz does they actually track
where these keywords Rank and so if I go
into Mods and I click on rankings I'll
be able to see on a weekly basis or
monthly base cases how are keywords are
ranking and for what page is the ranking
so for whatever keyword I choose to to
optimize for I want to make sure I put
those keywords in Moz because when I put
them in Moz Moz is going to on a weekly
basis tell me where these keywords Rank
and for what URL they're ranked for so
that way I can keep an eye on ranking
over time because in theory the higher
you rank the more traffic you're going
to get and so we want to be able to see
the trend in which keywords rank okay so
if I click on a particular keyword in
Moz it's going to give me over a period
of time where that keywords ranked be
able to see Improvement in ranking for
particular keyword the whole idea behind
SEO is to choose keywords that are
relevant optimize for those keywords so
that you can be ranked for those
keywords in order to get the traffic and
conversions so Moz is a good platform
that helps us monitor rankings for
particular keywords now if you don't
want to use Moz as an alternative you
can turn your attention to Google search
console and so remember we talked about
Google search console earlier when we
talked about sitemaps we also talked
about mobile usability with search
console we also talked about links to
your site with Google search console so
Google search console is a good tool to
help you understand how you're
performing with Organic search and so
there's one tool in particular which is
performance that helps us understand
what keyword queries people are actually
typing into Google search and so here I
could see the actual query and so with
this particular website valleyfig.com I
can see that dried fig recipes over the
course of the last three months had
5414 Impressions that means that one of
my pages either one or multiple Pages
appeared in Google search engine results
5414 times and over the course of those
5414 impressions I received 1100 clicks
so Google search console is going to be
able to tell me not only you know how
many Impressions I received for a
particular keyword but they also are
going to tell me how many clicks and if
I wanted to add more metrics to that I
can add them like the average ranking
position for keyword the click-through
rate so I can add multiple metrics to
this report to give me an understanding
of hey or any of my target keywords
being used or queried and if they are
where am I ranking and I am I showing up
and am I getting clicks so search
console serves as a good alternative if
not primary tool or platform for you to
measure how your organic search results
are showing so for local visibility this
metric is important for you know
maintaining local SEO so remember on the
local SEO we talked about Google my
business so if I go back to Google my
business this I can go into my account
and so Google my business is going to be
able to show me some metrics so if I go
into Google my business and I click on
insights I'm going to be able to see a
number of different metrics over the
course of a month I can see exactly you
know what queries were used by how many
users and when I appeared so I'll be
able to see how many views I receive not
only on search results but on maps then
I can also see what actions people took
when they saw my results in maps or in
search did they visit my website did
they request directions did they call so
I can actually see engagement metrics
right in Google my business I could see
a Breakout by ZIP code I could see phone
calls by day of the week I could see how
many people even viewed my photos so
there's a lot of insights into local SEO
on Google my business so that gives you
an idea of how you're performing
organically on local search church and
remember you want to be able to use
Google my business to hone in on your
specific audience so all these metrics
help you align with whether you're
getting in front of the Right audience
and whether that audience is actually
behaving the way you want them to
meaning you know are they actually
contacting you are they going to your
website are they calling you so local
visibility and understanding the metrics
involved with local SEO is very
important so Google my business is where
you want to turn your attention so
overall engagement metrics are important
they play an important role in
determining rankings for example we talk
about bounce rate so bounce rate is the
rate at which people go from organic
search to your website and then leave
after a scene one page and not going any
further so if they land on a page and
then leave the website after landing on
that page it's considered a bounce and
so bounce or bounce rate is a good
indication of how people are receiving
our website or the content that they're
reading on our website there are other
metrics involved like average session
duration or pages per visit all of these
are engagement metrics and let's not
forget about page speed so page speed is
also a good engagement metric all of
these metrics affect or determine
rankings so we want to be able to make
sure that if we're in Google analytics
and we're looking at engagement metrics
that our metrics are good because if
somebody comes to our website from
organic search and there's a high bounce
rate then what does that tell us that
there's a disconnect between what that
person's querying and then the content
that they're reading and so we want to
be able to address those engagement
metrics so that we can continue to not
only drive quality traffic but keep the
traffic engaged and then in turn drive
up conversions last metric we want to
look at is backlinks so content having
more backlinks from good domains will
effectively improve your SEO performance
we talk about backlinks with off-page
SEO and remember quality over quantity
and so we can measure backlinks going
back into Moz we can use moz's Link
Explorer tool so remember if I type in a
domain Valley fig I can get some metrics
related off-page SEO including my domain
Authority but more importantly I can see
what links are pointing to my site in
this case valleyfig.com so I can see
they're 575 link domains I can see
there's 7900 inbound links and so just
by clicking on that I can get an idea of
the types of websites that are linking
to my site and their domain Authority
and their spam score Google search
console so if you go back into search
console you can also just click on links
and we should be able to get an idea of
you know what websites are linking to
our site and more importantly we want to
be able to see not only what sites but
what pages they're linked to remember we
want our backlinks pointing to Interior
Pages not necessarily the home page so
here I could see the top link page for
valleyfair.com is slash recipes so we
want links pointing to our interior page
is not necessarily the home page that's
what's going to help your performance
your rankings for all your pages not
just your home page so having quality
back links pointing to Interior Pages
help boost the domain Authority and the
page Authority for that particular page
so again using Moz link Explorer tool or
using the links reporting search console
are good sources for you to identify
backlinks so so when we look at these
these reports we want to look at the
Domain authority of these sites that are
linking ours the number of outbound
links to the site or specific pages on
our site we want to be able to look at
the ratio of Link distribution you know
we want to be able to look at how many
follows and no follows so most of this
if not all of these metrics are in Moz
so if I go back to Moz I can actually
see you know which one's pointing which
ones are followed the total quality of
the link that's pointing to our site
again bam so Moz link Explorer report
tends to give us all the information we
need in order to measure and get a sense
of our backlinks that help us with
off-page SEO so there are other tools
out there there's hrefs again search
console there's other SEO platforms out
there that'll help you measure backlinks
okay now that we covered everything with
on-page SEO and all off-page SEO and
really everything SEO in general let's
take a little quiz and if you could go
ahead and just put your answers in the
comment section below so just a little
quiz here and we'll start out with
question one which of the following type
of site map is specifically designed for
search spiders so the answer is either a
HTML sitemap or B XML sitemap so go
ahead and put your answers in the
comment section below I'll give you just
another second to think about that okay
another question for you from a search
engine perspective which of the
following link types could cause a
negative effect on your rankings it's
either a purchase link or B no follow
link so again if you could if you know
the answer or just take an educated
guess go ahead and put the answers in
the comment section below okay next
question a websites robots text file
serves what function is it a tell the
Bots what pages should be crawled and
not crawled or B tells the Bots what
links should be follow and no follow so
if you know the answer you feel good
about your answer go ahead and put it in
the comment section below today we're
going to talk about SEO tips and tricks
so let's get started and throughout this
series we're going to have a few tips to
share with you and we'll start out with
tip number one up for smarter ways to do
keyword research and so if you listen to
any of our SEO tutorials in the past you
know that keyword research is the first
step but the most crucial step in
starting SEO so when we do keyword
research we want to be able to basically
find keywords that we feel are relevant
to our business that we want to be found
on search for and so here are a few tips
that can help you do that research in a
more efficient manner the first thing we
want to do do is identify a list of
keywords that are relevant so we only
want to focus on relevant keywords for
our business that's a given so what I
would suggest is as a best practice
maybe you know put down some of these
keywords in a spreadsheet so think of
them as a theme of keywords because when
you do research you're going to want to
include a theme of keywords related to
one another so you can pick the best
ones out of that theme and so as an
example if we have a company that sells
dried figs in a spreadsheet as an
example if I show you a spreadsheet
maybe we want to focus in on just dried
fig and maybe we want to focus on dried
fig recipes so go ahead and put those in
a column you know some of these keywords
that you know you want to be found for
so that's really the first step they
need to be relevant so put them in a
spreadsheet so that you can build
keywords around that list then we want
to choose keywords and when we choose
keywords we want to have some cry
criteria around choosing them and so we
always want to choose keywords with a
lot of volume and what I mean by volume
I mean how many people on average type
in that keyword or a related keyword per
month the second criteria is the keyword
a product fit meaning you know is the
keyword relevant you always want to stay
true to relevancy the third is
commercial intent what is the intent of
the keyword is it trying to get us a
sale is it answering a question so what
is the intent of that keyword and then
last it's difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality so remember seasonality in
this example Christmas tree you're only
going to have a spike you know during
the when winter or excuse me the October
November December months so be careful
of seasonality when choosing high volume
keywords and again keywords that are
relevant to your product even though it
doesn't have much search volume
relevancy always trumps uh volume or any
other metric commercial intent so we
want to look at keywords that for
example have Buy in them they may have
low search volume but if somebody's
typing in that keyword then we can
insinuate that the consumer who typed in
that keyword is ready to make the
purchase so we want to look at what the
intent is of that keyword and then again
the difficulty always up for keywords
that have low difficulty or competition
and so in order to get these metrics we
can use third-party tools and I'm going
to show you a couple of examples of
third-party tools you can use that will
give you some of this information so the
first tool I'm going to show you is
Google ads Keyword Planner so if I'm
having Google ads account I could simply
go to tools and then choose the Keyword
Planner and from there I want to find
new keywords so if I choose the keyword
dried figs because that's the key word I
put in my spreadsheet that I'm
interested in optimizing for and then
maybe drive fake recipes that was the
other keyword theme
so if I enter those two keywords in just
to begin with basically what Google is
going to give me is the average search
monthly volume so here I can see dried
figs I have an average monthly search
bomb 8100 that means on average over the
last 12 months that's how many people
have typed in that keyword here I can
see a little bit of a trend I just hover
my mouse over that graph I could see
again for seasonality impact if there is
any seasonality what the volume is on
average per month then I could see the
competition is high and because this is
Google ads because it's paid search
they're going to give me a sense or an
idea of what I should be bidding on the
keyword now that's another topic for
another day but it's good information to
have because if you're not ranking for a
keyword you could decide to bid on it
for paid search so don't discard the
bidding information go ahead and put it
in a spreadsheet for later use but for
now we're focused in on keywords that
are relevant how much volume how much
competition okay so once I get this
information here I can simply go back to
my spreadsheet and put that information
in there what's the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition notice that Google ads gives
us a high or low now if you're trying to
measure ratio between volume and
competition we want to get an actual
sense of what that competition is so
what I always do as a best practice is
go into Google search if I go to Google
Search and I type in dried figs I'm
going to see the actual volume is 34
million 500 000. so I could see that's
the actual search volume for this
particular keyword however if I add a
syntax called all in title before that
keyword with a colon space and then hit
enter Then I could see the actual volume
reduces to Thirty one thousand and
basically what this tells me is that 31
000 listings or results have the keyword
dried figs in the title tag so if a web
page has dried fig or targeted keyword
in the title tag then ideally we can
insinuate that that page is trying to
rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
Google we have to jump over thirty one
thousand results so we want to be able
to include this information into our
keyword analysis so if I go into our
keyword analysis here and I go ahead and
enter in that information so what's my
keyword my keyword is dried figs okay my
volume was 80 100 my competition was 31
000 and so that gives me a ratio of 81
divided by 31 000 if I make that into a
percentage basically 26 so that's my
keyword Effectiveness index or Kei or
ratio between volume and competition and
so that's a way that you can gather
information is by using Google ads enter
the information into a spreadsheet and
then sort all your data by Kei you could
sort it by volume you could sort of a
competition all these metrics matter
alternatively as another tool you can
use Moz so Moz has a keyword Explorer
tool okay so if I type in the keyword
dried figs and focusing on the United
States I could say that Moz says hey
look there's anywhere between 4300 and
6500 in terms of volume out of 100 the
difficulty is 41. and so I can expect a
click-through rate of you know 41 and so
basically the great thing about moz's
keyword Explorer tool is I can also look
at the serp analysis search engine
results Pages what serp stands for and I
can analyze the serp for a particular
keyword in Moz so I want to be able to
understand what my competition is doing
in so here I could see if I really want
to try and optimize for that keyword I
could see what the other pages are
ranked for that keyword in the on page
one I can also see what local results
show up for that keyword so here I could
see that we have a number of different
sites listed here so if we want to be
number one these are the sites that are
basically above us that we need to climb
over to be number one on Google so I
find that the keyword explorator in Moz
is very helpful for understanding your
competition as well as getting a
alternative check on volume and
competition or difficulty if you will
and so remember we want to identify a
list of keywords that are relevant I
can't stress that enough we want to
choose keywords based on difficulty we
want to choose keywords based on volume
on Commercial intent and more important
relevancy we can also identify Trends
from a site search query like Amazon and
know what your competitors are ranking
for so we can also go back into Moz and
we could see just by typing in some of
the keywords we're focusing on we can
see if our competitors are ranking for
the same keywords just by using that
keyword Explorer tool and then another
thing we want to look at is LSI or
latent semantic indexing so that's a
fancy word which basically means we want
to find keywords related to the topic of
the page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword and so if
we go back to our spreadsheet it doesn't
necessarily always have to be just one
keyword it doesn't necessarily have to
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant and if
we're analyzing nothing but relevant
keywords then we want to be able to
choose keywords that have a good ratio
between volume and competition so you
always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we could also stay up
to date on industry news as we'll help
you learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt
to subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here I'll show you
what that one of those sites look like
if I simply just go to search
enginewatch.com I find this is a good
resource to stay up on the latest news
when it comes to search engines here we
could see the Y SEO and front-end
developers are the perfect search
marketing team another article about
optimizing your channel YouTube channel
five easy steps so there's a lot of
information here on search engine watch
that pertain to SEO and keyword research
we could also look at other third-party
sites like Wikipedia Reddit and core for
example so if I go to quora I can do a
search for dried figs and I could see
what's being written about that topic so
that should give me some ideas to build
a keyword a list around so for example
the health benefits of dried figs okay
our dry figs safe for diabetes best ways
to eat dried figs so those are all good
keyword themes that we could build a
keyword list around and I did that
simply just by typing in dried figs on
cora so that's a a good tip for you to
leverage when you're trying to build out
a keyword list okay let's uh talk about
tip number two which is publish high
quality content to get more traffic to
your website so it's all about content
so we've already done the keyword
research we still need to kind of merge
the two but when we talk about merging
the two it's not just building content
around those keywords it's much more
than that when it comes to SEO and so
that's why we always talk about high
quality content so let's talk about some
of the tips that can help you create
high quality content so first tip is we
want to be able to publish longer and
engaging content longer engage in
content tends to rank higher in Google
why because you have more content to
work with and when you have more content
to work with you can optimize it you can
structure it you can insert different
assets like videos and images and by
keeping it long you're gonna likely keep
it engaging and so Google tends to lean
in favor of content that is well
organized structured and long because it
is more likely to be engaging for the
end user we definitely want to include
this target keywords so you want to be
able to you know insert those keywords
into those meta tag descriptions into
those title tags into those alt tags but
you want to work them in naturally you
don't want to force anything content
should be naturally written because if
it's naturally written it's going to be
engaging so we want to use LSI keywords
and the content so LSI or basically
latent semantic indexing basically just
means different terms and concepts
related to your target keywords so feel
free to use terms that are similar to
what you're currently using these
keywords can definitely be used for SEO
because they can create more visibility
and potentially higher rankings because
it gives you an opportunity to use
keywords that are natural and work for
different variations and let's look at
examples so if you're optimizing an
e-commerce category page and your
keyword is one mix used for men so we
want to use keywords closely related to
one mixed use for men for example
running shoes for men or sport running
shoes for men outdoor sports shoes or
air cushion shoes let's take a look an
example of Amazon so if I go to Amazon I
could see the one mix shoes for men page
and if I look at this page I could see a
lot of product and each product has
basically some content associated with
it I.E the title Battle of the
particular product and so you want to be
able to use different descriptors for
this particular product for example
men's running shoes or breathable
lightweight gym sports shoes or
lightweight casual sneakers or walking
casual sneaker all of these are LSI
related keywords they are similar to
what we're trying to optimize for so you
don't necessarily always have to be
brand heavy or stick with one keyword
you could definitely show variation
especially on the e-commerce side if
you're dealing with different products
so we want to make the content readable
with the help of visuals subtitles and
bullet points so if your e-commerce you
want to make sure that page is laid out
properly easy to read here I could see
the descriptor along with the title all
kind of merged together and so there's
no breakout of okay this is the product
name this description it's kind of one
all in one which I like it just makes it
more natural sounding okay and you can
see these are all broken out uh pretty
well laid out page and Amazon is more or
less you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long amount of content or large amount
of content so the use of subtitles
bullet points and visuals will help
break it out structure it and make it
more engaging for the end user you
definitely want to write an effective
and organized content in order to reduce
the bounce rate so there is correlation
between engagement and bounce rate the
more you structure the more you add
visuals the more you add subtitles the
more engaged somebody's gonna be the
less likely they are to bounce from the
pitch we also want to share customer
reviews and ratings so if you have a web
page you sell products even if you don't
sell products it's always good to have
testimonials or some type of customer
review so if we go back to our example
on Amazon and we clicked on a product
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we could see
kind of the description well I may not
be so interested in buying this product
I want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
Factor comes in where if I read other
reviews then I can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here I
could see that not only their reviews
but there's testimonials so I could see
that here you can see that there's a lot
of stars and you can see the kind of the
review title these running shoes are
very comfortable and lightweight so you
have a lot of different feedback and so
reading custom reviews is always helpful
because even though you're making the
decision it kind of will help sway you
in one direction or another at least it
does for me so that's the the beauty of
a customer review and a rating we want
to be able to use those to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis is so
and that goes for testimonials and
reviews you want to make sure you're
always getting reviews because if you're
always getting reviews then that's just
adding to the particular product and so
if you're always updating your content
on a regular basis as well then Google's
going to be able to see that and Google
likes fresh content okay we also want to
include the benefits of the product so
if you're selling a product any product
you always want to include the benefits
you want to do as much as you can to
make your product engage into the end
user enticing so that they can buy it so
in addition to customer reviews or
adding content about the product you
want to include benefits so if we go
back to Amazon here we could see Amazon
lists a lot of the benefits or one mix
in this case list a lot of the benefits
so here you can see all the descriptors
about the particular product it's got
Rubber Sole it's got a breathable
textile lighting you get free hot
quality socks with every shoe so these
are some of the features and if we can
continue to scroll down we can see some
of the details about the fabric type the
specifics about the fabric and a lot of
information on this product page even a
sizing chart so a lot of different
features that will help the end User
make the decision so don't hold back add
as much information as you possibly get
as much information as you have
available it doesn't hurt because in the
end what you're trying to do from a
product perspective is sell the product
and you can't really sell it unless you
have information that's going to
convince the user that this product is
what they want to buy so include the
warranty size recommendation return
policy and some offers so it should all
be listed on the page easy for the end
user to see so can't stress it enough
provide as much product information as
possible go back here here it has a
sizing chart what colors are available
again some of the descriptors if I
scroll down here I can see some more of
the benefits you know waffle rubber
outsole soft deodorant insole again
fabric type it's got all sorts of
information it's got images about the
fabric itself the shoe itself how it's
structured it's a lot of information
about this and it even does a comparison
and so there's a lot of information
about this particular product so don't
hold back add as much as you can to give
ends the end user so in the case uh the
one mix on Amazon you know they had a
sizing chart you know they had an FAQ
they had additional information what
other products that customers view from
one mix and then testimonials so these
are some of the basic bits of
information you want to add on your page
if you don't have customer views it's
okay add FAQ in its place again the end
result is to convince the customer to
purchase the product and then build a
comprehensive internal linking structure
of web pages so every product page
should link to similar products so if I
go back here here I can see other
products from one mix so you should
always have a linking structure so that
if the end user doesn't want to
particularly buy that particular product
then you have links available so they
can go to another page and then add
different varieties and related short
videos of the product so if we go back
to our product page you know they have
different varieties that they're
showcasing here they have the size chart
they even have a size convertible chart
so if you're dealing with metrics you
can go over to us metrics vice versa you
can add a video you know show a video uh
if you're selling running shoes several
videos somebody working out you know it
doesn't have to be a full-blown
commercial per se but it could be a
short 30 second video of what the shoe
looks like on somebody else's feed so
that they could see somebody walking
with those shoes on so video doesn't
have to be a big production you could do
it right from your phone so review your
content before where you publish this
goes without saying you want to do that
just you make sure you include
everything possible because when the
content does get published remember
Google is going to index that content
when they index it it's going to show up
in the search results so we want to make
sure we have all the information readily
available not only for the end user but
for Google as well we want to be able to
analyze our meta tags in url to improve
click-through rate so this is important
because the meta tags I.E the title tag
and The Meta description and the URLs
what shows up in Google search results
so we have title tags the first that's
the first important element that's what
shows up in the search results so what
we want to do is we want to optimize the
title tag and when we optimize it we
want to use modifiers and when I say
modifiers I mean you know feel free to
use the word best or cash back or free
shipping or discount so for example if
you're selling running shoes 25 best
sneakers or up to 70 off or free
shipping or buy shoes on discount very
action oriented but you know it includes
these modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so some tips
for optimizing the title tag in addition
to the modifiers we want to watch the
title lengths and we want to include
those Target keywords in the title tag
so remember you're likely going to have
two keywords to work with you want to
have at least one of those keywords in
your title tag so with the modifier you
know up to 60 to 65 characters in length
with that targeted keyword should get
you a good title tag that's going to get
somebody to click on it so let's look at
an example so if I type in the keyword
best recipes for dried figs you know
here I can scroll down here's my title
tag stands out my URL is right
underneath that and underneath the URL
are is the meta description and so here
I can see some modifiers 188 best autumn
dried fake recipes or 25 fantastic fig
recipes or 10 best cooking dried fig
recipes so these are all modifiers
they're going to help somebody get the
click get them to click on your link and
go to your website so when you don't hit
the 65 character limit if you go over
that Google's going to cut off the title
tag so we want to avoid that at all
possible so the whole idea is you know
like 10 best cooking dried fake recipes
by yummly that's a good enticing title
tag okay it takes them to a kind of
modifier includes the targeted keyword
and is under the 65 character count some
additional tips for writing meta
description we always want to provide a
unique description for each web page of
the website so no duplicate meta tag
descriptions every page use needs to be
unique then we also want to be specific
about what we're offering so if you have
say you're selling headphones and you
have a particular particular set of
headphones from a different specific
brand include that in the meta
description if you have that particular
product from that brand on sale include
that in the meta description so you want
to be as specific as possible the whole
idea behind a meta description is to
describe the page but also to get the
end user to click on your link so here's
an example of using modifiers and
describing a page if we look at Amazon
again we can see this example here and
if we look at it on Google search
results so if I type in Amazon Bluetooth
headsets ten dollars are on sale here we
can see a lot of Amazon listings in
Google search here you can see the use
of modifiers in the title tag and also
in the meta description here we could
see that you know this particular
headset Bluetooth headset is on sale 50
off so if something's on sale feel free
to include it be descriptive about the
page let people know where they're going
and use those modifiers don't be afraid
to use numbers in The Meta description
even if it's the price itself even if
it's not on sale but it is the price
included it's not going to hurt the more
information you can include in a meta
description the better chance you have
of somebody clicking on that link use
numbers symbols you know percentages off
always help use catchy words like
discount or cash back you're competing
with other listings on the page so if
you have something on sale if it's on
clearance list that it's on clearance
here I can see they even included the
coupon code so feel free to list as much
specific information about that page as
possible the whole idea is you're
competing with your own web pages but in
other cases with competitors so the meta
description along with the title tag and
the URL helps separate out you from the
rest of the listings on search engine
results and we don't want to keyword
stuff we want to keep it within 100 160
something characters or 160 65
characters because Google will break off
The Meta description just like they do
with the title tag and so we want clean
natural written meta descriptions that
separate you from the competition so
that means including the keywords we're
making sure those keywords are naturally
included in the meta description so if I
go back again to valleyfig.com and I
could see the meta description hey
welcome to the best resource online for
dried fake recipes Savers sweet snacks
are healthy dried fig recipes we've got
it all they start cooking with figs and
so it's natural sounding it does include
the keyword it's not keyword stuffing
it's natural sounding it's hopefully
going to get that person to click on
this particular website let's turn our
attention to the URL so we want to make
sure that the URL is basically taken
into account best practices so if we
take a look at this particular URL here
it doesn't necessarily look as
attractive as we would like so first of
all I don't understand some of it so
that makes it unpleasant boring and
messy to say the least so you want URLs
that you know basically are clean and
understandable so in other words we want
to make them SEO friendly because if
they're SEO friendly somebody
understands the URL then they're likely
going to click on it so the old rule of
thumb is if you can read the URL then
the search engines can read the URL so
here are some tips for creating friendly
URLs for SEO make it readable you want
to include the target keyword in the URL
so if it's dried figs the URL should
include dried figs if it's dried fig
recipes make sure it's dried fig recipes
now avoid using too many subdirectories
in the URLs so we want to keep it as
close as possible to the root directory
and match the URLs to titles most of the
time so let's go back to our example
here here there we could see this is
valleyfake.com recipes not necessarily
dried fig recipes but recipes
nonetheless it's in the root directory
okay so at all costs now this is in some
cases unavoidable given that you may be
dealing with an e-commerce website
that's calling you know content from a
database so if that is the case you're
going to have some Dynamic parameters in
the URL which is fine just make sure you
avoid having too many of those Dynamic
parameters it's understandable about
parameters but the rule of thumb
generally is no more than two different
parameters in the URL so prefer to
create short URLs that's really the way
to go the shorter the better is the rule
of thumb and you know if you're going to
break up the URL then use hyphens
instead of underscores it's just cleaner
it's a more understandable search
engines tend to read it a little bit
easier if it's hyphen so here's what a
friendly only URL looks like for search
you got your domain you got a
subcategory broken up with a hyphen and
then the product so that's like just to
clean URL for particular e-commerce site
that has categories and subcategories so
again we got amazon.com your category
can be Electronics your subcategory it
could be earphones and your product
could be boat earphones it's that simple
let's start with talking about rich
Snippets this is tip number four so we
want to add Rich Snippets to improve
your website's visibility on serps so
tip number four is all about rich
Snippets so let's start out by asking
ourselves what is a rich snippet so rich
snippet is simply just a term used to
describe structured data markup that you
as a website owner can add to your HTML
so hypertext markup language or HTML is
what is basically constructs a page so
if we can add more information into that
that will internalize search engines
like Google to better understand the
information that's on that web page so
the more Google understands about that
web page the more they can put into the
search engine results page so rich
Snippets is basically some structured
data markup that we can add to our
existing HTML and so if we want to add
Rich Snippets to search engines then how
would you prefer your products to be
displayed well if we have products then
we want to make sure that maybe we have
reviews or maybe we have so other
information in there like links to our
site okay so there's a lot of different
types of Rich Snippets that you know we
can add that Google can recognize and
add to the search engine results so if
you have a product then there's a lot of
things we can add like specifically
product reviews so we want to be able to
add more information to the search
engine results by working in some rich
Snippets so basically the whole idea is
to set up the rich snippet to drive
targeted traffic okay so because the
more information in the serp the more
likelihood you're going to get the click
and the more likelihood that click is
specific traffic so some of the benefits
of structuring the data for Rich
Snippets are as I mentioned increasing
click-through rates you know also
increasing conversion rates so when you
get the traffic from organic search to
your website if somebody's looking for
specific product and you have a number
of different good reviews showing up
let's just say five stars out of five
stars and you have a hundred reviews
showing five stars then you know
somebody's probably going to send take
some trust in your brand in your
conversion rate probability is going to
go higher it also helps improve your
search engine visibility because you're
adding more information so in other
words the more Google knows about your
page the likelihood it's going to rank
that page and it's more likely that that
information that's contained in that
rich snippet is going to get featured in
either the knowledge graph which is that
graph on the right side or in a featured
snippet which usually shows up at the
top of search engine results so in other
words the more information you give
Google the more they can use that
information on their search results page
and there's no disagreeing that the more
information that you have in your search
engine result the likelihood of getting
more traffic increases so for Rich
Snippets you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product page just a page
itself is an image you can always start
there you can always add a description
you can always add in ratings and you
can always add in reviews so these are
some of the most common attributes you
can add as a rich snippet so if you add
that Google picks it up it's going to
include that information and the search
results okay some others are offers
prices site links links to your site and
product availability so all that
information can be conveyed to Google
Google understands what you're trying to
pass along it's going to include that in
the search results so did you know that
according to hrefs over 99.58 of
featured pages that have structured data
already rank in the top 10 list of the
Google search results page so in other
words if you have Rich Snippets in your
page your chances of ranking in the top
10 of a Google result is going to be
very very very good okay let's talk
about tip number five optimize your site
structure for great user experience so
let's go over some of the tips that you
would do for planning a good website for
SEO and so tip number one is you want a
Ural structure that follows your site's
navigation hierarchy so obviously home
page interior pages so depending on what
type of site you have obviously the
navigation needs to follow that site's
navigation that site hierarchy and it
all starts with a home page you want to
optimize your home page to try up
traffic to your product pages so the
home page is nothing more than a doorway
into your website and so the site's
navigation should link to all those
different products so if you have an
e-commerce site with sub categories or
categories subcategories then you want
to be able to make sure your navigation
reflects that you want to build a
comprehensive structure for internal
linking as well because when you're from
the home page obviously you want to be
able to easily navigate to other Pages
however when you're on other Pages you
want to be able to have a link pointing
back to relevant pages and not
necessarily on the home page so this
serves two purposes one for the end user
obviously you want the end user to
navigate through your website sites
seamlessly right second for the search
engines they're following links they
want to be able to understand how your
website flows and links together so you
don't want a scenario where it's a
one-way street from the home page to
Interior Pages you want basically a home
page to Interior interior to other
relevant interior pages and that could
be a lateral or that can be a situation
where it's a hierarchy for example home
page category subcategory subcategory
Etc you want to be able to make sure
your site is constructed in a manner in
which the search engine can read it so
CSS or cascading style sheets or
hypertext markup language HTML are your
two most common languages that's
basically what browsers load that's what
search engines like to index it just
makes it easy for them to understand
what your page is all about remember we
talked about rich Snippets in the
previous tip writ Snippets are nothing
more than some supplemental HTML to
describe what the page is all about so
that the search engines can understand
that page and include reviews or include
site links in the search engine results
so this is all based on HTML so the more
you provide the search engines in a more
structured manner via HTML the more the
search engines are going to stay on the
page adding breadcrumbs to your product
pages is also a good practice if you
have an e-commerce site and you have a
category then a subcategory then a sub
subcategory then a product page what's
probably not a bad idea to make sure you
have a breadcrumbs so that was that way
somebody can easily go right back from
the product page to say the category
page or to the subcategory page directly
without having to hit the back button or
having to go through the navigation some
good examples I think Amazon does a good
example of using breadcrumbs given the
amount of products they have on their
site so go check out Amazon if you want
a good exam Temple for breadcrumbs and
then canonical tags we want to make good
use of canonical tags and that's in
order to avoid duplicate content so a
canonical tag is nothing more than a
link element basically or an HTML
element that basically prevents
duplicate content issues so in other
words if we have a canonical tag as a
meta tag basically we're telling the
search engines this is the preferred or
canonical version of a web page okay so
use this web page so it signals to the
search engines which page they should
basically index and pay attention to and
avoid at all the other pages that have
similar content so that's the idea
behind economical tags so that's a good
best practice and then optimize your
site for desktop and mobile I can't
stress the mobile part enough most users
begin their Journey on mobile so if
you're not sure about what the search
engines like or don't like you can
always refer to Google search console
for example so if you go to Google
Search console they have a report called
mobile usability so if you click on
mobile usability you can see what pages
they like what pages they don't like
from a mobile perspective and if you
have errors they're going to tell you
what those errors are so if your website
has text that's too small to read
They're going to tell you that these are
the pages with this error and so that
allows you to go and address those
errors because from a Google perspective
if you have if a page has a mobile
usability error then Google will not
index that page so leverage Google
search console to get a sense of what
type of Errors your site has from a
mobile perspective you also want to
prefer to keep your checkout page simple
so again from an e-commerce perspective
you want to keep the checkout page as
simple as possible for obvious reasons
you want the end use user to have a good
experience and you obviously want the
conversion so when I say keep a checkout
page simple really now with today's
technology you can create a one-page
checkout process you want to optimize
your site map so when we talk about site
Maps we want to make sure that it's a
file an XML file that basically includes
all of our URLs and we can then turn
around and give that site map to the
search engines so if you have a sitemap
in XML make sure you go to Google Search
console so if I go to Google Search
console and I click on sitemaps I can
just simply just tell Google where my
site map is located and when they
recognize that sitemap they're going to
be able to basically index the URLs from
that sitemap so we could see here how
many URLs they discover and how many
they index so make sure you create the
site map in an XML format submit the
sitemap via Google search console and
then you can can go back and see how
many pages they've indexed versus how
many you've submitted and you want to
make sure that sitemap is dynamic
meaning anytime you publish a URL that
URL is added to the sitemap fixing
broken links so broken links is not
something you want but it's something
every website has it's unavoidable you
know people publish Pages all the time
there's test Pages there's all sorts of
reasons why a site has broken links you
want to be able to address those and
again going back to Google search
console we can basically see just by
looking at some reports what pages I
have broken links and which ones don't
so we could certainly look at search
console to get information about
basically what pages are broken which
ones aren't and then we want to prefer
predictive searches and integrate
product typographic errors on your
search bar so basically have a search
bar that's a best practice but it
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
Google analytics and looking at the
Search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at Search terms uh to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts so that we don't run in any issues
on our website uh people not being able
to read based on a specific font that
you're using and then I think best
practice what I found and this is not
necessarily for everyone but using a
live chat widget sometimes helps in fact
I would even go beyond sometimes on most
the time again depending on your
business but I see most businesses now
have live chat enabled and so basically
having live chat enables somebody who
has a question to immediately reach out
to somebody versus picking up the phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous is gratification in some
ways so inserting live chat on a website
is more common practice than not
nowadays given it it lends to a better
user experience tip number six improve
your page speed and reduce the bounce
rate so let's talk about page speed and
how page speed correlates with higher
bounce rate if it's a high page load and
so according to Crazy page speed is an
important overlooked SEO tactic because
for every second delay and Page load can
result in 11 fewer page views sixty
percent decrease in customer
satisfaction seven percent decline in
conversion rate so you know you can see
here regardless of how specific the
numbers are when you have a page that
loads slow you're going to have lower
user engagement and a poor user
experience so you have to pay attention
to page speed and so since 2010 Google
has been using page speed as a factor
for page ranking in the search engine
results so here's some tips to focus on
making sure your pages are optimal in
terms of speed so enable browser caching
okay you can reduce plugins if you're
using Wordpress as an example you know
disable plugins you're not using get
using a simple website design going back
to tip number five stick with CSS and
HTML don't do anything fancy in terms of
Technology because it's only going to
complicate matters optimize your code
Minify files meaning hey if you're not
using any code just get rid of it
because code has to execute and that
slows down page load time so if your
website has numerous CSS and JavaScript
files basically Minify and combine them
and so that's what we're talking about
there you know you don't necessarily
need a lot of you know JavaScript on
your page you can leverage Google tag
manager or you know other features that
help minimize the number of JavaScript
files you have and so you can also get
some of these ideas by going into Google
analytics so in analytics under Behavior
under site speed under page timings you
can basically see how quick each page
loads and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is Google is going to
actually give you some suggested ways to
increase speed so if we let this report
load we'll be able to see some speed
suggestions per page and so here you can
see for example the home page has an
average page load time of 4.89 seconds
you can see right next to that we have
page speed suggestions seven total so if
we click on that basically what it's
going to do is going to launch another
Google product called page speed
insights and what page speed insights is
going to do is it's going to analyze the
page in question whether that be the
home page or an interior page and what
they're actually going to do is not only
analyze the desktop version of your
website but also the mobile version and
so now we can see opportunities to
improve our page speed by making sure
the images are properly sized making
sure server response time is changed
again defer unused CSS not using CSS
that's or getting rid of CSS or
minifying it so there's lots of things
you can do and again this is desktop and
mobile so on the mobile side we could
see some of the other issues too that
are causing High page load so analytics
site speed reports page speed insights
are good ways to get an idea really
excellent ways to really address page
load time issues so again these are just
some of the common issues with page load
time there could be other factors so
leaning on those page speed insights
reports will definitely help reduce page
load time so basically according to
Google a website should have you know
time to First Bite lesser than 200
milliseconds milliseconds are very very
fast so in case your website is slower
than 200 milliseconds such as 500
milliseconds or more you need to improve
it so you don't even have to measure it
by milliseconds you can even go by
seconds which is what most of us count
time and again you can see that simply
going into these speed suggestions
report in Google analytics so ideally in
terms of seconds you want something
that's about you know four seconds or
less three seconds or less obviously as
fast as possible so case study Walmart
Walmart reported the following results
so Walmart experienced a two percent
increase in conversions for every one
second of page speed Improvement so
think about that there's definitely
correlation between pay age load time
and speed so in conversions and user
engagement so the quicker your page
loads the higher the engagement so with
that Improvement they also experienced
an increment in Revenue so meaning the
pages load people had a better user
experience they were able to check out
easier and that led to more Revenue so
they were able to measure Revenue
against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate Revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate Revenue
with page speed tip number seven build
quality links and increase their domain
authority of your website so Google's
top three search ranking factors
includes link building so you need to
have quality links from quality sites
pointing to your site and so that's a
factor in terms of ranking so that's
falls under off page SEO you need to
build references and links on quality
sites and so building quality links to
your content can give your product or
category Pages or even content or blog
posts a boost in the serps so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should Implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a lift in the
serps so earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages so what's
authoritative well authoritative is
subjective to some degree but it's also
measurement in others so you could use
Moz as a good tool to measure page
Authority or domain Authority so if I go
into Moz Moz has a page in domain
Authority score between 1 and 100 and so
you can actually see what sites have
good domain or page Authority just by
entering in the domain so so relevant
you obviously want to rank to something
that's relevant so if you're in the food
industry something food related you want
to promote your content regularly on
social media so social media I always
consider it a whole low hanging fruit
when it comes to backlinking you know
there's so many different social media
platforms available Facebook LinkedIn
Twitter there's so many varieties from
images to Pinterest and Instagram to
video being YouTube so there's lots of
ways to get your content out on social
media that will allow you to not only
promote your band build a community but
also establish a reference back to that
page you can opt for guest blogging okay
so you can reach out to another blogger
and blog on that platform and it can be
reciprocal as well a blogger can
certainly you know blog on your platform
and have a link back and it works both
ways influencer marketing so influencer
marketing is working with somebody who
has a large amount of followers who can
influence those followers to you know
mention you in a hashtag link to your
particular product or brand or even
drive traffic to your site so you want
to take advantage of social media
platforms and start your own page as
well so Facebook's a good example it
could be you have any YouTube channel if
you're into video you can certainly set
up a YouTube channel build a following
around YouTube as well so always start
your own page if that's the platform of
choice the last thing you should do is
set up a page on social media and not
keep it updated you could certainly
participate in forums you can
participate in other websites like quora
or Reddit that's very you know content
based content driven user driven I
always recommend starting your own blog
blog is a good way to not only generate
content but it's a good way to
incorporate different types of content
so you can set up different types of
content and categories it's a good way
to incorporate different assets like
images and video it's a good way to get
users engaged by having comments or
having social share buttons it's a good
way to leverage that content onto other
social media platforms so there's lots
of benefits to blogging very few cons
the only con would be if time gets trade
but it's better to have one blog post in
one month consistently than not blogging
at all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like Yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there and
allow you to see what pages they're
linking from okay you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get creative but create
it in a way that's going to generate
quality not quantity quality is the key
so even if it's one source whether that
be somebody else's blog so be it as long
as it's quality that's what counts so
let's talk about some of the key
takeaways from today's tips so remember
tip number one we want to opt for
smarter ways to do keyword research so
remember we want to look at volume we
want to look at competition we want to
create themes put them in a spreadsheet
so we want to be smarter in which in the
way in which we choose our keyword tip
number two remember publish high quality
content to get more traffic when we say
high quality content remember break up
the content use different assets
organize it structure it you know make
sure it's answering somebody's questions
then we talked about in tip number three
analyzing your meta tags and URLs so we
want to make sure that title tag meta
descriptions are creative use modifiers
like numbers or promotions you know we
don't want to go over character counts
we want to make them unique and distinct
so that somebody clicks on them then we
talked about rich Snippets and tip
number four remember Rich Snippets are
just additional HTML that communicates
the search engines so the search engines
can understand exactly what's on your
page so if you have recipes if you have
reviews if you have videos if you have
images if you have ratings all these
things can be added to the serps just by
communicating with the search engines
via's Rich Snippets tip 5 optimize your
site structure we want to make sure that
you know you have good inbound links you
want to make sure you incorporate
breadcrumbs you want to make sure users
can navigate your site more easily and
then in tip number six if your pages
load fast then it's going to enhance the
user experience it's going to increase
user engagement and increase conversions
and then tip number seven we want to
build quality link quality to increase
the domain Authority so remember we can
use Moz to measure domain Authority it's
all about quality whether that be via
influencer marketing guest blogging
directories social media setting up a
social media page there's always
something you could be doing to generate
a quality link to your website today
we're going to talk about keyword
research so what are we going to talk
about when we talk about keyword
research we're going to talk about why
we would do keyword research for SEO
we're going to talk about the types of
keywords that we need to research we're
going to talk about some methodologies
best practices on how to do keyword
research some alternate suggestions
we're going to talk about keyword
clustering and then we're going to talk
about some tools that you can use to do
your keyword research so let's start
with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step piece of
recipes with sausage homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well what Jesse
needs to do is understand what's going
to drive traffic to these blog posts if
she's writing about you know different
topics around pizza recipes so she's
Unsure how these blogs are going to
drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords he is maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and shoes in the queue words to align
with your content so that's really the
idea why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they could
have slow search volume for example you
may choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found an
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
in a phrase or shorter in some cases it
may be two keywords in a phrase or
shorter so short tip keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short sale keywords
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short show keyword but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short taking words may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also going to
have lower search volume but with longer
tail keywords the keyword is probably
going to be more relevant with the
content you're writing about so
therefore the conversion rates likely
going to be higher so that's really the
difference between short-term keywords
and long tail keywords if you want to
look at simplistically short tail
keywords are Broad in nature it's going
to capture a lot of eyeballs but those
eyeballs may look at your content is not
relevant versus long tail K words that
may be very relevant but not as many
eyeballs on them so short tail keywords
the characteristics they're not as
specific usually they're less than three
words they have high search volume and
high competition so if you just choose
pizza recipes could take you a while to
rank for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is Broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same keyword and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tail key word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic's going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than thick keywords
in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipe so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted Pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the key word you likely would want to
use versus just pizza recipes so let's
look at an example between a short tail
keyword and a long tail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use Google's Keyword Planner tool so
Google's Keyword Planner tool is located
in Google ads the Google ads platform
and when you're in the Google ads
platform you can simply click on tools
and then Keyword Planner and so what
Keyword Planner allows us to do is get a
sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a key
the word over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
gonna click get results and what
Google's gonna do is it's going to show
us the volume of those keywords so for
pizza recipe we could see the average
monthly search volume is 33 100 for
pizza recipe so note that pizza recipe
and pizza recipes are closely related
keywords and so what Google does is they
consider that a close variance so
meaning if somebody ties a piece of
recipe then they're also in Google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33 100
queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here I
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 to 1000
and then I can see the actual volume
over the past 12 months and then for the
long tail keyword I can see homemade
pizza dough recipe again close variants
homemade pizza dough recipes I could see
over the past 12 months with the search
volume is for this on average it's 2400
but I could see here in December the
volume went up to 3 600 but for example
in May it was 1900. so it's gonna
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average is about 2400. so shorter
tail a lot of more volume longer tail
not as much volume but nonetheless there
is volume here and so these are the
difference between a short tail and a
longer tail and so well Google's Keyword
Planner also does is allow us to get a
sense of what the competition it is and
so here I can see the competition is low
for both of these keywords fair enough
so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get all 2400 clicks for that
keyword remains to be seen chances are
you're not going to get all 2400 you're
going to get a Lion's Share of those
clicks but you're going to at least get
some volume on it so even the longer
take keywords have a lot of Promise
because there is some search volume here
for this keyword how to do a proper
keyword research so we looked at
Google's Keyword Planner tool and Google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search File volume search
volume is a good indicator of the
potential traffic we can obtain so again
for the key word homemade pizza dough
recipe we know that it averages 2 400 a
month in search volume again we may not
get all 2400 but we're gonna get a line
share of that we also need to look at
competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
terms of the competition but if you're
somebody who wants to get a better sense
of what the competition is and you
should because competition is a key
component in choosing keywords and so
what I want to do is get a sense of how
many people are actually optimizing for
that keyword so Google's Keyword Planner
tool is going to give me a low medium
high really what I want to do is get a
better sense of that numerically so what
I can do is go into Google search and I
can type in pizza recipes and I could
see there's about 1 billion results
that's a lot of results however that
means that every potential web page out
there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all entitle syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all entitled colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
336 000. so what that tells me is that
there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close experience and I just
click enter or type the keyword in hit
my enter key I'm going to get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2 160 different results so here I can
see the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition in but
my competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm going to put two thousand
one hundred and sixty so now I have an
idea of what kind of volume and what
kind of competition I have now you want
to do this for a number of different
keywords and when you do it for a number
of keywords what you do want to do is
obviously choose a relevant keyword that
has high volume and low competition so
another way of saying it is the volume
or ratio of volume to competition and so
basically what we could do is take
volume divided by competition if I make
that a percentage I can see it's 0.35
percent is the ratio between volume and
competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tier keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for number keywords and examine the
volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so relevancy you want to choose
keywords that are very relevant to the
content that you're writing and then
again commercial intent what keywords
are going to drive more conversions and
revenue for the business so when we talk
about commercial intent we're talking
about you know are you choosing keywords
that are going to get somebody to do
what you want them to do so we could say
You Know download pizza dough recipes so
somebody's typing in the keyword
download pizza dough recipes then
chances are they're going to find you
come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or season out so for example if I saw a
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September number all the way through
October and then it's going to drop
after October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a key
word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 and Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again Trump's volume
and competition so always choose
relevant keywords first so when you do
that you're always almost guaranteeing
that at some point somebody's going to
find your content because somebody out
there might be looking for it and if
they do you're going to get found and
then the engagement is going to be
better so understand your business find
keywords that are relevant to your
business and then focus on those
keywords that'll help you with getting
the right traffic to your site always
keep in mind the commercial intent so
these keywords are more specific and
result in conversion rate for example
buying is a good commercial intent
keyword so if you really want somebody
to come to your website and buy then
focus on those types of keywords in the
case of the pizza recipes maybe it's
download could be our commercial intent
keyword again there may be low search
volume but those are the the type of
keywords you want to focus on because
that's the type of traffic you want to
drive to your site so some other
examples a commercial intent keywords or
discount deal your coupon shipping you
know don't be afraid to use some of
these keywords as part of your longer
till keyword phrase again the volume may
not be high but the traffic quality is
probably going to be better so keyword
research is the foundation for SEO so if
you have chosen your keywords properly
then if you do get ranked for those
keywords then it's going to lead to
better engagement with some conversions
and so when we talk about keywords we
also want to talk about our primary and
secondary keyword so every page should
have at least a primary keyword and then
a second carry keyword to work with so
primary keywords are really defining the
nature of your content the secondary
keywords are relevant to the primary
keyword so why do we choose a primary
and secondary keyword because you may
choose a keyword as a primary keyword
that is relevant to the content but may
not necessarily rank very high or have a
lot of volume that secondary keyword is
also relevant to the primary keyword but
also relevant to content and you may
rank for that secondary keyword so you
always want to go with two keywords
versus just one keyword you want to give
your yourself a chance to rank for at
least two different types of keywords of
relevant nature so for web page there
can be several secondary keywords but
only one primary keyword so your primary
keyword is always going to be relevant
to your content secondary keywords can
be relevant to the keyword but and you
may have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so for primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
the secondary keywords are also related
to content and play off the primary
keyword and so what we want to do is go
to cool Google's Keyword Planner tool
and get an idea of the volume for
healthy diet plan and then also the
volume and competition for some of these
secondary keywords like healthy diet for
weight loss healthy diet food low carb
diet healthy meal plans and diet plan
weight loss so if I go in to Google's
Keyword Planner and type those keywords
in I'm going to choose get results and
now here I could see healthy diet plan
keyword I'm focusing on is my primary
keyword has an average monthly search
volume of 9900 and then some of my
secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
that as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume to competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key
release two keywords I want to be able
to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also also related to
the content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you focus in on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to Google search
for example if I type in healthy diet in
Google search all I need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and I can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying low-fat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keywords
so if you're optimizing a page for a
healthy diet then you could choose
low-fat diet as a secondary keyword you
can use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or a snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on Python
and your content you want to support
that with LSI keywords and so that will
allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a key word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrase that you can use so the
answers are right here in Google so Cora
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community response with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good eye it's a
good place for you to go to get some
ideas about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing quora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're gonna probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna get some
responses to the the top topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If you scroll down I could
see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for men healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
that are being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on Quorum so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword where areas
that somebody types in and they're
suggesting some of the most popular
terms that people have typed in so if I
go back to Google again if I start to
type in recipes I could see some of the
other queries that somebody else has
typed in or some of the most popular
queries related to that topic so if you
enter the keyword healthy diet Google's
going to suggest multiple keyword
suggestions that users have asked in the
past and you could certainly get the
search volume of those keywords just by
looking in Google itself I could see for
healthy diet recipes billions of pages
related to healthy diet recipes I can
also get the search volume by going into
Google's Keyword Planner so if I type in
healthy diet I'm going to be able to see
what my search volume is for that
keyword and in addition I can see the
seasonality of that particular keyword
and in addition to that Google is going
to provide some other related keywords
to my search query so if I'm looking for
healthy diet Google is going to suggest
hey maybe you should choose healthy food
or healthy eating or how to lose weight
so those are allocyte related keywords
that Google provides in the keyword plan
which is built into the Google ads
platform another option for you is
Wikipedia so Wikipedia is a vast
platform of content so we could turn
Wikipedia into our own assets and use it
to our own Advantage by finding relevant
keywords in an easy fashion so with
Wikipedia we can identify a list of
keywords in The Meta description itself
we could choose keywords from the first
paragraph of Wikipedia that has many
relevant keywords or we could take a
look at keywords from the Wikipedia
content section so we can also see
additional Pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wiki Wikipedia here I
can get just in the first paragraph
alone I can see some additional keywords
that I might choose to use like
micronutrients I never knew that
micronutrients was related to healthy
diet but Wikipedia is providing some
information about what micronutrients is
and maybe I can use that as a keyword an
LSI related keyword to my content so if
I scroll down I get to see also section
so it might give me some information
food information consumers for example
dietary guidelines I can look at
categories like dietetics and diets I
can also look at the references section
so I can also see what information was
provided like health effects of
overweight and obesity I can look at
diet and physical activity so all of
these are related to my main keyword
healthy diet so the answers are right in
here on the platform they're just all
over the page so Wikipedia has an
abundance of information you just need
to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further in the
first paragraph you look no further than
the C also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags on
the serp so you can also do that as well
so if I type in healthy diet Wikipedia
and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content and discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits and in individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so the
keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a Word in key Reddit and choose
keywords from the auto generator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a website
then we have a better opportunity to
rank so in other words why do we have to
Target just one keyword when we can
Target many so keep in mind you know LSI
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar for
Content so for example after some
keyword research you can thematically
group keywords into a core topic so for
example we can cluster these group of
keywords together like for example what
is SEO how does SEO work intro to SEO
what are the basics of SEO all of those
are related to the chord theme what is
SEO another cluster keywords for example
could be SEO techniques SEO best
practices tips and tricks website
optimization on-page SEO techniques Etc
so those are clusters of keywords okay
that we can group together in themes and
if we group keywords together in themes
we can apply that to a particular
content on our website so the whole idea
behind clustering keywords it's going to
provide more diversity more of an
opportunity for us to be found so that's
the whole idea behind clustering so some
additional steps remember stay up to
date on industry news to brainstorm your
ideas first and identify a list of
keywords like ethema keywords that you
can cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword SEO best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword pause
if I go to keyword the keyword Explorer
tool and Moz and just type in SEO best
practices what it's going to do is it's
going to give me some volume related to
that particular keyword but more
importantly what it's also going to do
is going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword so here I can see Moz Moz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to rank for myself so if we look
at tools for keyword research look no
further than Moz that's the mods of the
tool I would just choose but you could
also use Google's Keyword Planner which
we used in the example so for example if
I go back to the Google ads Keyword
Planner if you're in Google ads you
click on tools you click on Cleveland
planner and what Keyword Planner does is
it provides you for particular keyword
the average monthly search volume of the
past 12 months it provides you
information on seasonality so if I hover
my mouse over a graph I'm going to be
able to see the volume per month over
the last 12 months what the keyboard
planner also does is it provides me some
additional ideas for my particular
keyword and in addition to that it's
going to provide me some sense of how
competitive that keyword is by telling
me whether it's low medium or high in
terms of competition so there's sem Raj
there's also other additional keywords
tools out there like word stream or href
or the Reddit tool keyword it and then
Moz is is another tool I particularly
use so if I go to Moz again here I can
just type in a keyword that I'm
interested in it's going to give me the
search volume of that keyword it's going
to give me the level of difficulty so 50
out of 100 so it's halfway between
difficulty and easy and then it's is
going to give me some additional metrics
like for example what my expected
organic click-through rate would be if I
were to rank for this keyword but more
importantly what I like about this is we
could see exactly what other sites are
linked to this particular keyword we're
interested in so here I can look at the
top 10 list so this is mazuski word
Explorer tool so that's what this tool
is and it's part of moz.com so there's a
lot of tools at your disposal I
particularly use Moz I particularly use
Google's Keyword Planner and those are
the tools I use but there are lots of
tools out there let's go with the
scenario that you have a friend named
Sam and he has a website where he sells
shoes but Sam doesn't understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on Google and so typically the ranked
number one on Google there are some
factors involved and those are factors
that are going to help Sam get his
website ranked number one on Google so
he can sell his shoes get traffic and
convert that traffic to conversions so
there are factors involved and so what
are those factors well it always starts
with keyword research so in order to
rank for a website where you sell shoes
or you sell products other products like
clothing or food or you're at automobile
website you know you're a mechanic it
doesn't matter whether you're selling to
customers or selling to other businesses
you have to start with the keyword
research and so we're going to go into
really explicit detail on how to conduct
a proper keyword research and then the
second factor involved is high quality
content so in order to rank high on
Google search you need to have high
quality content so we're going to go
over what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to take
that content we're going to opt optimize
it using on page elements and website
level factors so we're going to take
into account what's involved with your
website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on Google then we're
going to get into the off-site
engagement so when it comes to ranking
on Google you need to optimize your
website and you need to do some elements
off your website you need to be engaging
off your website meaning on other
websites and so we're going to talk
about what's involved with off-site
engagement so SEO being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
and there's a lot of work involved and
so ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on Google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 percent of our effort and
80 percent of the results are obtained
so we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bring in 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20
percent of our landing pages Drive 80
percent of the overall traffic that's
following the 80 20 rule or 20 of our
backlinks pass 80 percent of our link
choose that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to Target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 of our effort on those
keywords landing pages and backlinks in
return for 80 percent of the results so
without further Ado let's get started
with the keyword research let's talk
about that keyword research search for a
website with shoes and it doesn't really
matter what particular product you have
if you need to rank number one on Google
it all starts with the keywords as I
mentioned before and so in this example
if you have a website where you sell
shoes for kids you're going to want to
be found for certain keywords so the
obvious keyword here would be shoes for
kids well every key word that you target
has search volume associated with it so
that means when we talk about search
volume we're talking about how many
people on average type in that keyword
or related keyword on google.com or
Google search and there's always an
average number of searches associated
with every keyword and we call that
search volume how much search volume so
obviously if we're going to Target a
keyword we want to have as much volume
as possible however there's always going
to be competition for those key words
meaning there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
Google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to Target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea be on keyword research is analyzing
and choosing the best keywords so we
want to add identify a list of keywords
that are always relevant we want to
choose the keyword that your competitors
are ranking for and we want to use
third-party tools to choose keywords to
identify which keywords have low
competition and what keywords have high
search volume so one thing to take into
consideration when you're doing keyword
research is that the longer the keyword
phrase or in other words long tail
keywords or keywords with three keywords
in the phrase or more you're going to
always have less competition but there's
always a trade-off with long tail
keywords meaning the longer the keyword
phrase there's going to be less volume
but the trade-off is less competition
and so what we want to do is we want to
brainstorm some ideas and find those
relevant keywords so let's look at an
example here so if we go to Google ads
so Google ads has a toe call Keyword
Planner and let's just say I have a a
website where I'm selling dried figs and
if I'm selling dried figs I want people
to buy these dried figs however in order
to attract them I want to be able to
show them that hey we have a bunch of
recipes and if I show you a bunch of
recipes where you can use dried figs
maybe you'll buy these dried figs to use
in these recipes and so we're going to
look for keywords related to bread
recipes because if we can optimize for
our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the Keyword Planner and Google ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to do keyword research what I would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if I go into a spreadsheet here my theme
of keywords is bread recipes my keyword
is bread recipes and my volume therefore
is going to be sixty thousand five
hundred however if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner Google's
telling me the competition is low so
that's great I want high volume I want
low competition but how low is low so we
want to be careful so if we're going to
put in numbers into a spreadsheet we
want to figure out what that competition
really is for the keyword bread recipes
so if I go to Google and just type in
bread recipes I'm going to be able to
see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want want to do is put in a syntax and
we want to put in the syntax all in
title and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites or trying to
rank for bread recipes and if we put in
the syntax all entitled colon and then
our keyword bread recipes we'll be able
to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means that 998
000 sites or listings have the keyword
bread recipes in the title tag and the
title tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one Google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on Google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on Google and
so therefore I'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now I could see for the
keyword bread recipes I have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my Kei
or keyword Effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner if I typed in
bread recipes you could see that Google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say I have another
keyword that I want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on Google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if I type
in banana bread recipe and Google's
Keyword Planner now I could see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368
000. I can also say the competition is
low so those are good signs so now I can
see 368
000 I'm going to go ahead and put that
in my spreadsheet now I'm gonna go into
Google I'm going to put in my syntax All
In title I'm going to put in banana
bread recipe I'm going to hit enter and
now I can see I have 233
000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if I
look at the title tags I can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
Google search results so that tells me I
have 233
000 results that I have to jump over in
order to rank number one on Google so
I'm going to put 233
000 in my spreadsheet now I can see my
Kei or my volume to competition ratio is
157 158 percent and so to me that's a
lot better number to work with or in
other words that's a lot better keyword
because it's just as relevant and it has
a higher ratio of volume to competition
so therefore banana bread recipe is is
going to be a better keyword to optimize
for in order to rank number one on
Google so that's the whole idea behind
keyword research you want to brainstorm
ideas there are plenty of tools out
there so the tool I recommend is Google
ads Keyword Planner Google is going to
give you how much search volume they're
going to tell you the competition but
then you're going to go into Google
search you're going to use the syntax
all in title to get a more accurate read
on the actual competitive number and so
to find out how keywords that your
competitors are ranking for you can use
those keyword tools that I mentioned
another tool that I use is moss so Moz
if you go to moz.com they have a tool
called keyword Explorer so if we just
type in the keyword for example bread
recipes it's going to be able to tell us
how much volume and the difficulty so
you can use other tools that you're
disposal figure out the volume and the
difficulty there are plenty of tools out
there but the one thing I would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you could check other platforms
that have a lot of shared content like
Reddit and quora where you can ask
people about certain topics using
keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
could stay up to date on industry news
to get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket meaning we
won't want to put our emphasis just on
one keyword to rank for we want multiple
keywords to try and rank for so the
primary keyword can Define the nature of
our business the secondary keyword could
be just highly relevant to our keyword
at the end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords to try and rank on
Google for that page so for example we
have a Blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have the primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
around other similar keywords like
low-fat ice cream recipes or fat free
ice cream recipes or low-fat homemade
ice cream recipes those are
complementary keywords just like our
bread recipes and banana bread recipe so
one thing we want to do when we do
keyword research is we want to be able
to Target one keyword per content when
you can Target many we want to be able
to Target multiple keywords not
necessarily Target one keyword and so we
want to be able to Cluster keywords so
we don't want to Target just one we want
to Target multiple keywords per page and
when we talk about clustering if we go
back to our keyword research what we're
doing is we're clustering a bunch of
keywords under the theme bread recipes
and so by looking at the volume looking
at the competition looking at the Kei we
can choose different keywords for our
page and that's what we mean by
clustering we want to cluster keywords
into a Content frame so why Target only
one keyword per content when we can
Target many because we don't want to put
all our eggs in one basket we don't want
to Target just one keyword we want to
Target many and so that means clustering
your keywords into a theme and choosing
multiple keywords for that particular
page and when we do that we have a
better opportunity to rank high on
Google Search and the whole idea behind
ranking high on Google Search is we can
get the volume so if we know we're
ranked number one on Google search for
bread recipes or banana bread recipe we
know we stand a chance of getting a
majority of the volume associated with
that keyword and if we can get the
volume and get the traffic then we can
get the conversions so let's move on to
high quality content and talk about the
impact content has on your ability to
get your website ranked number one on
Google so let's just say you have
content on your website and the content
is ranking on you know page four of
Google and it's that blog with ice cream
recipes and if it's just content for the
sake of content it's not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page
nine what can we do well we want to be
able to you know take that content and
do something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search
engines says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in bounces and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on Google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
Google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do I make you
know a bread or how do I make a specific
type of bread or how do I make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number different tools
when we talk about keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called phrase.io and that will help you
do quick research on you know keywords
and Trends and whatnot so if you know a
better research tool that you use for
keyword research then drop us a comment
below I'd be interested in getting your
comments about keyword research and what
research tools are out there so if you
know something better than phrase.io
drop a comment below and we'd be
interested in getting your perspective
so keyword research is key but creating
content that fulfills users requirements
so answering those questions it's a
recipe we want to answer that question
if it's directions we want to answer
that question if they don't know how to
do something we want to answer that
question and that's the whole idea
behind content content is not just a
fill a page it's to really fulfill users
requirements that's when you get good
engagement so if somebody's typing in
something on Google and they're looking
for an answer your content should answer
that question but we also want to make
the content readable so in other words
you know write for your audience don't
impress anybody with very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add The
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey I've done my
research on this topic and this is is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
Remember When creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
wide hacked techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you just write words to
install text based you could also use an
infographic infographic is simply just a
graphic that visualizes exactly what
you're trying to explain for example if
we want to write an article about how to
write good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
as a text we can create an infographic
so for example here's an infographic on
20 effective ways to basically not bore
your readers but write engaging content
so you can see this is an infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the points of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
I like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you could
save them from really any social
platform so infographics tend to tell a
better story and versus say just writing
text you can use video and images so you
don't necessarily have to lay it all out
in an infographic you can certainly
insert a video or an image into your
content especially if it's a blog post
if it's a blog post then sometimes video
and image is on its own tell the story
you don't necessarily need text to go
ahead and tell your story a video or an
image as they say tells a thousand words
and so images and videos are great to
use in a blog post so using different
forms of content you know you always
want to review your content when a user
dwells on your web page for a longer
time Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
HubSpot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create high quality content so you want
to begin with a comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content remember the content should be
relevant to the keywords so if you're
choosing keywords and your keyword
research think about answering that
question if somebody's typing in bread
recipes maybe they're looking for banana
bread recipes how to make the best
banana bread or how to make banana bread
using dried figs we want to be able to
align our content with that keyword
naturally you want to create a title
that's worthy that's click worthy so
remember if you're in Google search and
you're doing search for something simple
like bread recipes we want to make
something that's going to be you know
engaging for somebody to click on like
easy perfect yeast bread or easy crusty
French bread or something that's going
to be engaging you know the best bread
recipes or how to make the best homemade
bread you know something that's going to
draw somebody's attention to the title
of that blog post so we want to include
LSI keywords so what I mean by LSI
keywords in your content we mean you
know long tail keywords make it natural
headings and subheadings should consist
of keywords and variants so if you're
writing headers and subheaders include
the keyword in there and that way the
content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences in
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read and we want to always
put internal links on our blog post why
because if we have internal links then
if we have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say our blog post
to an internal page on our web website
we want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way somebody's reading
something and you have an internal link
let's just say from a bread recipes page
to a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to pan the image with
text so that way if the image doesn't
load then at least the alt text will
load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to Crepe in Enterprise red or
always just coming up with ways to
update the content so we want to keep
our content our blog post fresh and then
we want to include a CTA call to action
if we include a call to action then
that's going to keep somebody engaged
and have them act on your content so
these are steps to creating high quality
content and so let's look at an example
here and this is a three-month-old post
on BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012. again a lot of
Engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's been
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
but because listen you know it's
engaging content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high Authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices I mentioned
about creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content I.E in the form of infographics
Graphics or videos or text or images you
can add images from public domain sites
you can be relatable and use examples to
clarify points just like the BuzzFeed
article simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some Do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
Adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long pair
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
hint in order to get your pages ranked
high on Google search let's turn our
attention to optimizing on-page elements
and discuss some website level factors
that are both going to help you rank
high on Google search so let's just do
an overview of what we're talking about
when we talk about on-page elements and
website level factors so optimizing on
page elements include a number of
different things but primarily we're
going to focus in on meta tags also
known as meta description tags header
tags also known as title tags and URLs
so those are just some of the on-page
elements we want to be able to optimize
using relevant keywords in order to rank
on Google search we also want to take a
look at some website factors that will
affect our ranking on Google search they
include website architecture having a
secure website how having a site map and
taking a look at page speed so all of
those are some of the website factors we
need to take into account in order to
rank high on Google search so title tag
and meta description together are
considered meta tags so both play an
important role in ranking high on Google
so we want to be able to write unique
title and descriptions for each page on
our website when I say unique that means
a title In The Meta description need to
be different for every page on the
website and so if you're not quite sure
what a title tag in a meta description
tag is if you go to search and just type
in any particular search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here in
bold and then the description is going
to show up below it below the URL and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what Google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results Pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get trunk at it and so if we
look here for example we could see all
of the title tags here fit the 65
character limit but if you run over the
character count on meta description then
Google is going to truncate the copy so
you want to stay within your parameters
in order to avoid getting your content
trunk at it and so the other thing when
we're writing title meta description
tags we want to minimize keyword
repetition so if we're optimizing for
keyword we don't want to know
necessarily just plug that keyword into
the title tag and meta description
multiple times we want to make sure our
title tags and meta descriptions are
naturally written so if somebody's
typing for banana bread recipe with
dried figs you know we want to have a
nice title tag and a description that is
going to get somebody to respond based
on their need and so we definitely want
to avoid keyword repetition but we want
to be able to use that keyword in the
title tag because if you remember from
the earlier segment when we did the all
in title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again in the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and the metadata description
to describe the page sound natural but
also be engaging because the point is we
want people to click on our link and go
to our website from search engines so
title tags with numbers tend to results
and higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example if you
just put in a title tag that says learn
digital marketing well that may work but
if you put a number in there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click on your
link and go to your website so having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but the engineering but if you
put it into the formal question how to
rank number one on Google it's more
action oriented it's going to get
somebody to resonate with the question
that they have and that may be their
query how to rank number one on Google
and so the these techniques will help
you get higher click-through rates and
so according to backlinko title tag with
a keyword can improve site ranking so
remember we want to include that keyword
in the title tag even though we only
have 65 characters we want to include
that keyword but we want to avoid
stuffing the keyword in there we want to
again make the title tag action oriented
maybe with a number maybe as a question
with the keyword in there once naturally
not easy to do but that's the beauty of
SEO if you can follow these best
practices and write a good title tag
then the chances of you improving in
your search results are going to be
greater so having only one H1 tag in
your post is going to be good so
remember when somebody clicks on a link
so let's say they do find a title tag
engaging and they click on this this
link here and they they go to that
website you know you want to start out
with having that particular H1 Tech
because the H1 tag especially with the
keyword in it is going to signal to
Google hey we're organizing our page and
because it's an H1 tag it's important
we're structuring the page according to
best practices so having only one H1 tag
in your post is definitely helpful
having multiple tags H tags in your post
help organize the page a lot better so
we want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your tatter tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
California fake banana bread and
remember the last segment when we're
talking about high quality content well
look no further than including a video
into our content so not only will this
video help keep the engagement high but
it breaks up the monotony of the page
and it's from a third-party source so it
adds credibility to the page so adding a
video based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on Google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those H tags in there H2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of H1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same H1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those H1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden text we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your H1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long H1 tags so
if you go back to our page exam sample a
short sweet tag here California fig
banana bread it's relevant to the
content it's short sweet it breaks up
the monotony of the content and more
importantly and again any content you
have on the page should always answer
the user's intent remember people are
using search to answer questions find
information our content should be able
to answer that for them so according to
John Muller senior webmaster Trends
Analyst at Google header tags would
definitely help Google for rankings in
the search results so we want to use
header tags so when it comes to URLs we
want to use hyphens and avoid
underscores so if we look at this URL
here this uses hyphens fig and banana
bread so it's all broken up with hyphens
that's a best practice remember
canonical URLs a canonical URL signals
to Google this is the original content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different websites we
want to use a canonical tag to signal to
Google this is the original content
please Index this content and that
doesn't hurt to use a favicon URL
meaning a small icon it helps to break
up the monotony and help your URL stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
URL so again looking at the URL here I
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the URL structure fig and banana
bread and that is the H1 tag is fake
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally URLs that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those URLs
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for Google that says Hey Google
this page is no longer available but it
we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to Google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no longer
there that's fine you're just going to
go to this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
URLs you want to include those in the
site map and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account this
best practices keep your URLs short use
hyphens put the keyword in that URL and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the URLs the URLs are
case sensitive so go lower case you
should always go lowercase from the URL
readable URLs again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the URL
is then Google is going to understand
what the URL is so the shorter the URL
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on Google search so according
to backlink to URLs that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those URLs
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
write content Google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine Bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that Google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
Children's Shoes then under men's shoes
you can have it by brand it could be
Nike Puma Adidas on the women's side it
could be 9 Puma Adidas on the child side
it could be Nike Puma Adidas and so you
want to keep the structure flow and a
hierarchy do we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has Nike
Puma Adidas the women should have Nike
Puma Adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and CSS or HTML meaning
we want to be able to use something that
Google's going to be able to index so
most sites are built in HTML and that's
what Google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural links
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going we don't want
to have unnatural inbound links you
always want to have natural internal
lengths to keep the flow of the user
going from one page to the other so here
here I could see as an example all the
ingredients in this recipe well this has
an internal link to another page on our
site and this happens to link to a page
where somebody can buy the ingredient so
it's a natural internal link so John
Doherty of Credo has claimed that one of
the biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the creative website is
architecture so for example in Credo
John Doherty has increased the organic
sessions by 74 in Pages by per session
by 41 just by changing the site
architecture so you'd be surprised by
changing the side architecture what that
will do to engagement and so let's turn
our attention to secure versus
non-secure so what we mean by that is
securing your site we want to make it
sure that compliant with certain
protocols and so if we go back here we
can see that this particular site is
compliant it is secure https means it
has a secure license meaning the site is
secure so Google likes secure versus
non-secure so non-secure would be HTTP
so we want https as our protocol and
what that means is just enabling SSL
certificates and that means when you
enable an SSL certificate that means
your domain or your protocol is going to
be turned to https so Google prefers
sites that are secure versus non-secure
so if you use hsts as a protocol that
adds an extra layer of security over the
https and hsts prevents cookie hijacking
so adding multiple layers of security
always helps in my opinion if you have
an HTTP website a non-secure website you
should look into buying an SSL
certificate getting your sites flipped
over to https because what's going to
happen is your url structures going to
change when your url structure changes
Google's going to recognize that because
they're going to index your site and
when they index your site they're going
to see those secure URLs and that's
going to work favorably in your favor
and help you rank higher on Google
search so websites using secure or https
have a higher chance of ranking higher
so https is a ranking signal because
Google indexes those pages so let's also
talk about site Maps so sitemap is one
of the most important ways to improve
your website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
URLs into one file so we're basically
going to prioritize all our web pages in
a sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap XML
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the site map
is located in the root directory so if I
I type in sitemap.xml I'm going to be
able to see all the pages in my root
directory and I can also prioritize them
I can also alert Google as to how often
they change and every page is going to
have a date stamp associated with it so
Google can actually see how often it
changes so remember we want our content
to be updated frequently so content's
not updated frequently or it's not fresh
then Google's gonna see that size that
date stamp that last modification down
so we want to be able to make sure
contents updated frequently we want to
let Google know that we changed it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our Pages let Google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a site map we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
URLs in the site map so we want to be
able to add all our original URLs in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
Dynamic URLs site maps for larger
websites and what I mean by Dynamic URLs
that means that if I look at this side
map and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a Blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
site map grow with more URLs when the
sitemap grows with more URLs then that
means then Google's going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
Dynamic sitemaps is we want to be able
to capture all the URLs just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our sitemaps and so I would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called XML
sitemap so if I I just type in XML
sitemaps into Google search here I can
see XML sitemaps generator and I can be
able if I have a small website just
create a free and simple site map on my
own when XML sitemaps creates it or your
platform creates a dynamic sitemap
either way the site map is going to sit
in the root directory and then what we
want to do in turn is let Google know
where that sitemap is so in search
console we want to be able to submit the
sitemap so you're going to add the site
map you're going to let Google know
where it is it should be in the root
directory and it should be called
sitemap.xml and when you do that
Google's going to be able to take those
URLs and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 URLs Google index 521 so
one thing about URLs here is when we
create a site map we're putting all your
URLs in there we do not add no index
URLs in your site map when what that
means is that any URL we don't want
Google to index we're just going to
exclude from the sitemap okay so we want
Google to take all the URLs we want
indexed and put them in the sitemap so
according to edgy using sitemaps for SEO
can increase your website's visibility
and help you get indexed why because
what you're in fact doing is taking all
your URLs that you want indexed you're
telling Google how often they're
modified you're telling Google which
ones are important and you're submitting
that to Google and so Google's going to
be able to take all these URLs quicker
index them quicker and when they're
indexed quicker you can get ranked
quicker and when you get ranked quicker
you can get traffic quicker so that's
the whole idea behind sitemaps so let's
turn our attention to page speed now so
when the last factors for our website
besides architecture making it secure
and adding sitemaps is we want to take a
look at how quick our Pages load here
are some tips in order to optimize page
speed because ideally the quicker a page
loads the more engaged the user is going
to be if it takes a longer time for the
page to load all the elements of that
page then what's going to happen is the
user is going to get impatient maybe
leave the website all together or go to
another page and so we want to be able
to optimize images so any image that's
of large size in terms of megabytes we
want to be able to optimize that
compress the image so that's one way to
speed up page speed we want to use a
simple website design you know HTML with
CSS or cascading style sheets just a
simple design with simple a hierarchy
and website navigation structure so
nothing fancy nothing complex just a
simple website design with optimized
images we want to leverage browser
caching and we want to upgrade the
server response time meaning all your
files are sitting on the server so when
somebody it goes to web page the server
is serving up all of those files the
images the text Etc and so we want the
server to respond as quick as possible
so when it comes to page speed we can
look at the factors affecting page speed
and Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I go under behavior
and I go under site speed and I go to
overview I'm going to be able to see
what my average load time is for my site
and ideally we want our pages to load as
quick as possible so that means anything
under four seconds anything four seconds
or higher and it's likely the end user
is going to leave the page there's a
correlation BP between page load time
and bounce rate and so what Google
actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then Google's
going to be able to tell us hey okay
this particular page load fast this
potato page loads slow and if it loaded
slow why is it loading slow so here we
could see the home page of the example
is loaded on average of seven seconds
well if we look here they're going to
give us some suggestions so if I click
on this page speed suggestions it's
going to load a report and a tool called
page speed insights and basically what
it's then going to do after it's done
running is it's going to tell me all the
ways in which I can optimize my pages
not only for desktop but also for mobile
so here I can see for desktop or for
mobile I can look at some ways in which
I can optimize it to increase page speed
for example sizing my images properly
server response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within Google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank Pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experience decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increased conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase
and Page low is low time will make a
world of difference in terms of
Engagement and conversions let's turn
our attention to off-site engagement so
previously we talked about on-page
elements and website factors that are
fact our rankings for search results but
we also need to turn our attention away
from our website meaning what we do on
our website and turn our attention what
we can do for our website off our
website and onto other websites so
that's offside engagement and so let's
look get an example so that ice cream
recipes blog so we did everything we
possibly could we updated The Meta tags
the title tag The Meta description we
added H1 tags we've made sure the site
architecture was sound we submitted a
site map we we made sure the page load
was good and fast so we did all the
things we're supposed to do on our web
page but we're still not ranking well
what do we need to do well we need to
turn our attention away from our website
into other websites we call this off
site or off-page SEO and we need to
basically generate links from high
quality sites back to our site so if
we've done everything we can on our own
website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality uh other websites that have high
domain Authority then we're going to see
an increase in rankings so it's just a
matter of getting quality links from
quality websites that are relevant
that's what's going to move the needle
on search after we've taken care of all
the on-page elements so more backlinks
from high domain Authority results in
higher rankings SEO is a combination
between what we do on our website
meaning optimizing the page and making
sure our website has good site
architecture and follows the best
practices in terms of site maps and Page
load then we need to turn our attention
to the backlinking to improve our domain
Authority so according to backlinko
analysis off-site engagement is one of
the most important elements for ranking
number one in Google so you can't just
focus your attention on updating the
title tag and making sure the pages load
fast you have have to turn your
attention as well to getting back
lengths from high quality sites that's
off-site engagement and so gaining links
back links from multiple domains is
vital it's vital because they bring
referring traffic to your site they
bring credibility to your site but more
importantly Google is going to recognize
the relationship between these sites and
your website and if these sites that
have backlinks or links pointing to your
site and if they're of high quality then
we call that passing link shoes so it's
going to bring quality to you in terms
of organic search so if we look at an
example if I do a search for banana
bread recipe they're 241 billion results
for banana bread recipe Why did this
particular page from Simply Recipes rank
number one well we can turn our
attention to Moz and Maz has a report
called link Explorer and so Moz link
Explorer report helps us identify our
own page Authority our own domain
Authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if I put
that particular URL into link Explorer
and notice the URL here is short even
though it uses an underscore when it
should use a hyphen it's still ranked
number one and why because off page
elements help this page rank number one
why their page Authority out of 100 is
58 their domain Authority out of 100 is
82. and what does that mean well that
means that they have a lot of good links
from other domains of high quality they
have 824 linking domains to this one
domain they have 3600 inbound links and
they're ranking for a lot of different
keywords so if we scroll down we're
going to be able to see kind of a
breakout the quality of websites that
are linking to them so they have 19
domains with a domain authority of 91 to
100 linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90. so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to it and so
we could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we can see the page
Authority so the link Explorer report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page Authority and
domain Authority are because domain
Authority and Page Authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
Google search in order for it to get
high we need links from high quality
sites so that's the whole idea behind
off-site engagement so some of the
offsite engagement prints are influencer
marketing meaning is there somebody out
there on social who has a huge following
but not only do they have a huge phone
but are they relevant to our product for
example Usain Bolt who's a famous
Sprinter if we're selling shoes and
we're selling Nike shoes maybe Usain
Bolt can reference us on Twitter or
Facebook that's influencer marketing
getting people to influencing people to
buy our product we can engage with
audiences on multiple social media
platforms like Facebook and Twitter
meaning if we're running a promotion on
those running shoes then we can promote
that on Facebook okay we can promote
that on Twitter we can also bookmark our
webpage on popular bookmarking sites
like StumbleUpon we can also put our
content on discussion forums like Reddit
we can join High PR quality q a sites
excuse me and post answers to questions
related to business like quora.com so we
can engage in sharing our content and
answering questions so there's lots of
ways to get links to your website if you
have a blog post as an example you can
make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so if you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and have a back
link pointing from that blog post to
yours as an example and you can
reciprocate so the whole idea of content
is sharing the content but at the same
time of sharing it you're producing
backlinks and backlinks help domain
Authority so not only did I help domain
Authority but they improve the search
rankings so in Google's eyes the higher
your domain Authority higher the page
Authority in Google's eyes that means
your page is important it's credible
level and we're going to improve it in
the search engine rankings it increases
brand visibility if we have our content
on a highly engageable website a highly
popular website or blog it's not it's
going to lift our brand visibility if we
have Usain Bolt who's very famous
Sprinter do some influence in marketing
for us then that's going to increase our
brand visibility so anytime we can
associate with something that has some
influence or some clout or high domain
Authority then it's only going to
increase our brand awareness and
visibility so again it's going to
increase our domain Authority because of
the association of passing link juice
from one domain to another it's going to
then as a result increase referral
traffic because if we're on a high
quality website that gets a lot of
traffic then the chances of some of that
traffic going our site is going to be
great and again it improves The
credibility and Trust of our website and
that's what we want we want Google to
trust us and a way to build trust is is
by associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about off-site
engagement we want to do some guest post
on relevant websites so if you have that
ice cream blog go to another blog like
the dessert blog and do a guest post so
not only that will that improve your
brand awareness but it'll generate a
backlink and maybe drive some referral
traffic you can participate in forms and
blog discussions like core.com or Reddit
get your content out there start a
discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your your site on a
directory like Yelp for example or Yahoo
directory you could prefer testimonial
link building meaning if you serve
products or offer up a service well
somebody could provide a testimony on
their website or you can just earn back
links from relevant authoritative the
web pages like we mentioned quora or
Wikipedia or there's plenty out there so
the idea is to associate yourself with
high quality websites but do it
naturally you don't want to force
anything so if you're selling a specific
service or you're selling a specific
product look for like mining services or
products that complement what you do and
that'll create the natural environment
natural ecosystem that will eventually
give you the benefits that you need to
rank higher in the search results pages
so we don't want to purchase any links
we don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject links on sites that
aren't relevant we don't want to just
have site-wide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with off-site
engagement so having offside engagement
complements what you do on your website
for on-site together both of those
efforts will get you higher search
engine results so let's start out with
why GTM so let's just say you're Sam and
you have your own e-commerce website you
want to understand how people are
interacting with your website well Sam
today's world of websites contain a lot
of interactivity everything from videos
to PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM get because it
helps us track all that interactivity so
all GTM is is really allows you to
really place a piece of java code which
is just script and the script that's
added to a web page to collect
information so that's really what a tag
is it's just some script that gets put
on a web page in order for you to
collect information like page views
clicks Etc and they send it to
third-party tools okay so that's what
GTM does it basically allows you to take
all these tags that collect information
and you can use them in GTM so if you
want to for example collect how many
people you know enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information so that's really what
GTM is it just allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track well you can put all those
those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into GTM let's just say you know
you're communicating with your developer
and there's a new user request on your
web page and you want to update the tag
well your developer considering it's
probably a small update your website is
probably gonna not
um hesitate and is going to go ahead and
turn around and do it normally and so
normally what happens is the developer
is going to go to the website and update
the tag well what if you have a few
things that you want to track all those
things I mentioned before from downloads
to clicks to you know somebody checking
out to watch in a video well your Web
Master your web developer is going to go
well hold on a second now all these
requests are going to take time I need
to put them in into the work queue so to
speak well what happens is when they go
into work queue usually it's going to
take some time and in some cases you as
a marketer need to launch a campaign and
you want to get that tracking uh added
to the website in time for the campaign
launch so you want to go ahead and
quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign and you're
sending people to a landing page that
has a form submission and you want to be
able to track how many people click on
the submit button of that form
submission well if you need to turn that
around your developer's like well I need
to put that in a work queue the timing
isn't going to always work out between
you and your developer is my point and
so that's where GTM comes in because
there is a solution to update your tags
faster and that's Google tag manager so
when we say GTM that's what GTM stands
for Google tag manager it's a place for
you to add tags quickly and easily so
tags remember are just Snippets of code
that allow you to track things on your
website interactively interactive
actively and basically when you have GTM
you can bypass the webmaster and do it
quickly and easily so that's what GTM is
all about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster and so that's the
benefit of GTM so the benefit you get
those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
JavaScript and tags and all all this
jargon is just new to you today okay
well don't fret sit back we're gonna
take it slow this is an introduction
into Google tag manager again let's
start out with what is tag manager so
we've already introduced it to some
degree because we already introduces a
tool where you can put all your tags
into a toolbox toy box or container so
to speak right and we already already
mentioned that hey you can bypass your
webmaster so you're probably thinking
well if I'm if you're not familiar with
tag manager how can I bypass my
webmaster well first of all it's a free
tool and it's a Google tool hence the
name Google tag manager and it helps you
really that's the main point it's deploy
and track tags on your website bypassing
your webmaster so that's tag manager and
so examples of tags that can be deployed
vehicle attack manager are numerous
these are just some examples like Google
analytics Facebook's pixel tracking or
Google ads there's no limit into the
number of texts you can track and tag
manager there is no limit you can add
any number of tracking tags and tag
manager okay so some of the benefits
well again I we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to test and deploy your
JavaScript codes quicker so remember
these JavaScript codes or Snippets of
codes are just there to track certain
things on your website whether that be a
page view or somebody clicking on a play
button or tracking somebody who converts
or even just goes to your website so the
biggest benefit is you can take that
snippet of code let's just say Facebook
let's just say you're doing Facebook
marketing and you want to put that
Facebook pixel on your website so that
you could track people who come from
Facebook and convert well you don't need
to put that Facebook pixel on your
website you can go right to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager really quickly and
the other benefit here is all tags are
managed in one place and that's that to
me is really a good benefit because when
you start adding tags on your website
and you have some tags and tag manager
it just gets very confusing so ideally
all the tracking codes you have on your
website needs to be in tag manager think
about that all the tracking so if you're
doing Bing or you're doing Facebook or
you're doing Twitter or you're doing
LinkedIn and you're doing Google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're going
to have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting all that code on your website
return gonna slow down the slope load
time of your web page and website you
want to put them all in tag manager so
they can be organized and you know
exactly what you're trying to track and
the other great benefit of tag manager
is there's a versioning control so let's
just say you have added tags to your
website via GTM for the last six months
well and let's just say you add another
tag yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version It's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a peace of
mind so to speak just because you've
added code to your site there's no
guarantee it's going to work and so you
can always control what version you're
dealing with in tag manager and we'll
talk a little bit more about that so the
biggest benefit here to me with tag
manager is you have event tracking and
so we talked about some of the things
you could track on your website from
videos from play buttons to somebody
clicking on the stop on the video or
pausing it all the way to somebody again
chatting or let's just say somebody
clicking on the that purchase button on
your website okay and you want to track
all these different things these
different interactivities and buttons
well event tracking is what you're going
to use to track all those buttons and to
me this is the biggest benefit of tag
manager and I'll show you some examples
as we go along and if we didn't mention
it already I'll mention it again it is
free tag manager is free there's no
limit so once you have tag manager going
you can add as many tracking codes as
you want there's no limit on the number
of tracking codes you can add to tag
manager okay so it's free and you can
use it to its fullest Advantage okay so
it's also high security meaning that it
has different levels of permissions okay
so you can have uh somebody just go in
and look at the different tags and
tracking codes you have in GTM or you
can ask somebody who is very familiar
with tag manager it can go in and add
the tracking code to tag manager and
then publish that tracking code when it
gets added so those are all the benefits
let's talk about how it works now
specifically how does tag Manager work
because you're like Rob okay again a lot
of jargon you know you you got tags and
JavaScript and and versioning and
Publishing and all this other stuff well
I know I'm throwing a lot at you at once
but just bear with me here okay so let's
start talking about how it actually
works so you have a website okay
whatever that domain is you have a
website and there's chances are on your
website you have some form of
interactivity whether that be a video
whether that be a Blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity and let's just say
you're even thinking about getting ready
to launch some type of campaign on maybe
Google or Facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also Drive traffic to
the website so incomes Google tag
manager and so tag manager is important
because again we know we want to track
people coming from that Facebook
campaign or that Google campaign and
interacting with our site so if you are
running Facebook and you are running
Google analytics well guess what you
want to put that tracking code in tag
manager so Google analytics being a
Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
Facebook campaign to your website so
you're going to get that tracking code
from Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say a Google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
managers controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag
manager.google.com and here I could see
a list of tags so in our conversation
we're talking about tracking Facebook
and we're talking about tracking Google
analytics well Google analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through tag
manager let's just take a look at Google
analytics so if you're going to use Tag
manager you might as well put the Google
analytics code in here so here I can see
I have Google analytics as a tag in tag
manager now for Facebook if I'm running
a Facebook campaign well I can take that
pixel tracking and put it in GTM as well
and here I could see Facebook pixel that
is that code is added to GTM I just
basically took what Facebook gave me and
put it in a Google tag manager so you
can see I can add and Facebook and
Google analytics and again I can't
stress it enough any tracking code from
any platform I can add to Google tag
manager in order to track the behavior
from those sources so let's take a
little bit deeper dive into how tag
manager works so I just showed you an
example of how you could take Facebook
and Google analytics code and put it
into tag manager but if you're not
familiar with tag manager then how do I
do that well let's talk about the
structure and how tag manager works so
when you have a tag manager account you
have a container remember I mentioned
Toy Box earlier you have a bunch of toys
if they're they're code and you're
tracking different bits of code from
different platforms like Facebook think
of those as toys and you have a toy box
okay well that's what this code is and
that's what a container is the code is
the code and that's going to go into the
toy box for a container and so the way
tag manager works is you have tags
triggers and variables so if I I take my
Facebook tracking code and put it into a
container I need to set up a tag and a
trigger okay so let's take a look at
what that is so first if I go back to
tag manager I'm going to have an account
and if I have an account I'm going to
have a container so here I'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code to so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote-unquote
tag well if it's Google analytics that's
easy here I could see I have Google
analytics added so if I click on Google
analytics here's my tag and if I take a
little bit of a deeper dive there since
Google analytics is is a Google product
it integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy I can just choose
Google analytics then I'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now every
tag needs a trigger okay so I need to
tell tag manager how or when to fire the
Google analytics tracking code so in
this case I'm going to tell tag manager
to fire on all pages so if I get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
Google analytics is gonna fire so that's
really what it comes down to is I have a
tag and I need to tell tag manager when
to trigger that tag that's really what
the structure of tag manager is it's
tags triggers and variables and
variables we're going to talk about here
in a couple minutes but you have a piece
of code you're going to go ahead and put
that into tag manager you're going to
tag it and then you're going to fire
that trigger so let's take a look at
another example here if I go back here
you can see Facebook well here's my
Facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell GTM when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the JavaScript code
that you get from say Facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and Trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and Trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
URL or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples I just
gave you are there to get your tag and
Trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if I
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side I can see variables so
remember I have built-in and user
defined so built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case I need to get my trigger to work
with my tag I can use a variable so
those are built in and then I have user
defined so these are what I Define these
are what I created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
Trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that JavaScript code okay in the
case of Facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
I click on adword search remarketing
again it's a Google product so I don't
really need to even deal with code I'm
just going to select Google AdWords for
marketing okay so you can see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling GTM when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of JavaScript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track in
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a Facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that that by defining
a variable you're making sure that
you're telling GTM how that trigger
should be fired so let's take a look at
another example here of how all three
play together if I'm in this account I'm
in this container if I look down here I
can see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's gonna fire on specific Pages how
do I I know that well if I look at the
trigger here I can see the trigger is a
page view but I'm telling it to fire on
this particular hostname so the tag and
Trigger go hand in hand
[Music]
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tagmanager.google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for amp except an accelerated
mobile page so most people by default
are probably going to set up tag manager
for their website and so when you do
that when you actually select website
what's going to happen is you're going
to get some Google tag manager code in
return and so the whole idea here is
you're going to do a swap what you're
doing is basically you're saying Okay
Google I'm going to take this Google tag
manager code and I'm going to put it on
my website I'm going to put it on every
page in my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be Facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in GTM
okay it's going to go into the Container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing I wanted to mention on the account
is it's a Google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say Google
analytics or some other Google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
Google analytics right to Google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing Google tag manager then
what I would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of GTM so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in Google tag manager
well when you create an account account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific ID
so if I click on that specific ID here's
where I can get my code okay so again
when I'm logged in to tag manager I'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation I'm going to see my
unique GTM ID if I click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to Google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed I'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all all you need to do is basically
you're looking at all your tags if you
click on tag in the left side navigation
you'll see all your tags and there's a
new button there so you just click new
and so basically what you're going to do
is you're going to create your first tag
and so what I would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
going to click on Google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to set a select a
variable and so what you're going to do
is you're going to select new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking ID here that's going to be your
variable so where do I get my tracking
ID and analytics well if I'm in
analytics I'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings I'm going
to see my tracking ID and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you got a copy over
that tracking ID then you're going to
get a tag manager I'm going to paste it
and then that's going to create a
variable for you and then when you
create that variable you're going to see
it in the drop down here so I've already
created it and basically that's your tag
with a variable then what are you going
to do you're going to set up a trigger
so see I have some triggers already set
up you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and it's going to
be all pages so ideally what you want to
do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if I get a visitor to any
page on my website then I want you to
fire Google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be Google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking ID and so you get the tracking
ID again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking ID over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so so
that way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking ID and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying Hey
I want this tag to go live now this tag
and Trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
Google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called Google tag
assistant and that's a an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually add a tag manager to your site
or you you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how Google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for Google
tag assistant you're going to see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in Chrome and unfortunately
it only works in Chrome browser it
doesn't work in any other browser so go
ahead and install that extension into
Chrome and when you do that you're going
to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and I click on Google tag assistant and
I click on enable Okay so basically I'm
loading Google tag assistant and now
once I refresh the page I can see that
this particular site has Google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed I can see
that it's also has Google analytics
running I have also Google optimize
running and I have Google ads
remarketing tag running and tag manager
so that's what tag assistant does it
allows you to see if one tag manager is
on the site and if it is great what
other tags are firing on this particular
site so tag assistance telling me I have
these particular tags firing on that
site and they're firing within tag
manager so tag assistant is a great way
to confirm if one tag manager is on the
site and two what other tags are firing
on the site now another way you could
confirm if tag manager is firing on the
site is you can go into preview mode so
even before you submit and publish your
tag and Trigger you can click on the
preview mode so if I click preview in
tag manager so basically that's going to
put me in preview mode and so what does
that mean well that means that now I'm
free to go to my website and see if
those tags are firing and so let's take
a look look at what that looks like so
if I go to the website and just click
refresh then what's going to happen is
tag manager is going to load in preview
mode just as you see here okay so that's
going to take a second couple seconds to
load up and now what can I see in
preview mode I could see that I have GTM
firing but I also have some other tax
fine on this page remarketing I have
Google analytics I have Google optimize
I have some other tags firing as well
and so the preview mode shows me what
tags are firing on any given page and I
can also see what tags did not fire okay
so here I have a number of tags already
in GTM but they didn't fire on this
particular page so let's just say I
clicked on the Donate Now button I'm
still in preview mode so I'm going to be
able to see what tags fired now I could
see I have a couple of tags that I've
fired on this particular page and then I
can see what tags did not fire on this
page okay so that's the preview mode you
can use the preview mode before you even
submit a tag and Trigger to see if it
fires and that's the great benefit of
tag manager so if you're not sure if
something's going to fire or not then
you can always go into preview mode um
and if you are sure it's gonna fire then
you can go ahead and submit it so you
can leave preview mode and just go ahead
and submit that particular tag and
Trigger so here I'm going to leave
preview mode and now once I'm done and
I'm sure the tag is going to fire and go
ahead and submit all my changes that
I've worked on in terms of setting up
tags and triggers so that's really GTM
in a nutshell so I have my tags okay my
tags are just Snippets of code that I'm
going to put in whether that be Facebook
or vet tracking or any other Google
product like optimize or page view then
I have my triggers my triggers are there
to tell G GTM when to fire that tag and
the variables are there to help those
tags and triggers work together so
remember that particular variable we set
up for Google analytics okay so here it
is right here because we want to tell
GTM what property to specifically fire
in Google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables Google tag manager has
built in or variables already created
for you or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again I can't stress
that there is an unlimited number number
of tags you can add to tag manager
there's no limit so you got everything
from anything from Google to non-google
to event tracking okay to Facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
I want to go back to an older version I
can simply do that so here you can see
I'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and I can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter
sign-ons Facebook YouTube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're gonna need tag manager and
when you have tag manager you're going
to be able to track all of these button
clicks and interactivity on your website
with that we have come to an end of this
tutorial on digital marketing and
hope the tutorial was informative and
interesting if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session then please feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning to
be Future Ready don't forget to
subscribe and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here